SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER, IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD COME TO ROOM
2100 SO WE COULD ESTABLISH
QUORUM FOR OUR HEARING, WE'D
APPRECIATE IT. WE HAVE 20 BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, SEVEN OF
WHICH ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
BILLS. WILL BE HEARD IN FILE
ITEM ORDER. WHERE APPROPRIATE.
WHEN AUTHORS ARE PRESENT. IF
NEED BE, WE'LL ADJOURN AT NOON
AND RECONVENE IN THE ROOM IN THE
AFTERNOON. SO WITH THAT, SINCE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL
PROCEED BY SUBCOMMITTEE AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WHO IS HERE, WHO IS ASSEMBLYMAN?
ASSEMBLYWOMAN REYES, AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE FILED ITEM NUMBER
18, AB 2827. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU
CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. MY WITNESSES,
IF YOU WOULD COME UP. MISTER
CHAIR, DO THE WITNESSES COME TO
THE TABLE OR AT THE DAIS WOULD
BE GREAT. THANK YOU, CAN WE GET
WELL? THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I AM PRESENTING TO
YOU AB 2827, WHICH PROTECTS OUR
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY. THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE THE STATE TO DETECT
AND ERADICATE INVASIVE SPECIES
THAT COULD HARM CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING ONE OF
ITS HIGHEST LEVELS OF EXOTIC
FRUIT FLY INFESTATIONS IN ITS
RECORDED HISTORY. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE, THIS
INVASIVE SPECIES CAN RESULT IN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOSSES
EVERY YEAR IF THEY BECOME
PERMANENTLY ESTABLISHED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN 2023, THERE WERE
OVER 900 FRUIT FLY DETECTIONS IN
15 COUNTIES IN COMPARISON, AN
AVERAGE YEAR WE'LL SEE ABOUT 75
FRUIT FLY DETECTIONS IN SEVEN
COUNTIES. HUNDREDS OF CROPS ARE
THREATENED BY INVASIVE FRUIT
FLIES, INCLUDING NUTS, CITRUS,
VEGETABLES AND BERRIES. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE BRING ATTENTION
TO THE IMPACTS INVASIVE SPECIES
HAVE ON OUR SHARED ENVIRONMENT
AND ENSURE WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
LONG TERM STRATEGIES TO PROTECT
OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES. WE MUST
PROTECT THE FOOD SOURCES OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS. AB 2827
SEEKS TO PRIORITIZE MITIGATION
EFFORTS AGAINST THE SERIOUS
THREAT OF INVASIVE PEST SPECIES
HERE TO TESTIFY IN, SUPPORT AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
OR TAYLOR ROSEN, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL AND
DANNY MERKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WINE GRAPE GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. YOU'LL
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PRESENT. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, TAYLOR
ROSEN, ON BEHALF OF CITRUS
MUTUAL. KI¾M IS AN AGRICULTURAL
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS PROMOTING AND
PROTECTING THE ICONIC AND
DELICIOUS CALIFORNIA GROWN
ORANGES, MANDARINS, LEMONS,
LIMES, GRAPEFRUITS, AND
KUMQUATS. CALIFORNIA CITRUS
INDUSTRY IS THE CORNERSTONE OF
NOT ONLY OUR STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY, BUT OUR
RURAL ECONOMIES AS WELL. WE
PRODUCE OVER 80% OF THE FRESH
CITRUS IN THE UNITED STATES,
GENERATING NEARLY $3.5 BILLION
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY EVERY YEAR,
SUPPORTING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS ACROSS THE STATE. BUT OUR
INDUSTRY FACES A SIGNIFICANT AND
GROWING THREAT FROM INVASIVE
SPECIES. WE'VE BEEN BATTLING THE
ASIAN CITRUS PSYLLID, WHICH
CARRIES THE DEADLY DISEASE
HUANGLONGBING, OR HLB, FOR
DECADES, WHICH HAS ALREADY
DEVASTATED CITRUS GROVES IN
FLORIDA AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD. IF LEFT UNCHECKED, IT
COULD DO THE SAME HERE, PUTTING
NOT ONLY OUR CITRUS CROPS AT
RISK, BUT THE LIVELIHOODS OF OUR
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS. I WANT
TO NOTE, THOUGH, THE IMPACTS
FROM PEST INFESTATION ARE NOT
JUST BORNE BY AGRICULTURE, BUT
ALSO OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, THERE ARE 3
MILLION CITRUS BACKYARD CITRUS
TREES. THAT'S ALMOST ONE FOR
EVERY PERSON IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. THE CITRUS INDUSTRY
SPENDS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR TO PROTECT BACKYARD CITRUS
FROM HBW AND EXOTIC PESTS.
FARMERS FUND SURVEILLANCE,
TRAPPING, AND TREATMENT
PROTOCOLS. AND WE'RE PROUD TO DO
THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE, BUT AN
INVESTMENT IN YOURS AS WELL.
CLIMACTIC EXTREMES, WEATHER
EVENTS, PEOPLE, MOVEMENT, GOODS
MOVEMENT AND LESS INVESTMENT IN
PEST PREVENTION OVER TIME. THAT
HAS MADE THIS JOB HARDER, AND IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE SO, AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED, THE
EXOTIC FRUIT FLY INFESTATION HAS
BEEN AN EXAMPLE OF SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE. SINCE MARCH OF THIS
YEAR, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROVED $50
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES TO REBUT, EXOTIC FRUIT
FLY. THE PROLIFERATING
PROLIFERATION OF EXOTIC SHOT
HOLE BORER, WHICH SENATOR LAIRD
MAY REMEMBER FROM HIS TIME FROM
RESOURCES, AGENCY AND SUDDEN OAK
DEATH LEAVES OUR LARGE FOREST
TREE CANOPIES DEAD AND DYING
THAT HAVE DIRECT CORRELATIONS TO
WILDFIRES. YELLOW STARTHISTLE
DISPLACES NATIVE VEGETATION AND
FEEDS ON LIMITED WATER SUPPLY.
ALGAE BLOOMS HARM OUR WATER
SYSTEMS, AND NUTRIA CHEW THROUGH
LEVEE SYSTEMS, DAMAGING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE BELIEVE AN
OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS WORTH A
DOSE OF CURE. AB 2027 IS A
CRITICAL STEP IN SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WORKING LANDS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A DEMONSTRATED
PATTERN OF SUCCESS, YOU SET A
GOAL, DETERMINE PATHWAYS,
DEDICATE RESOURCES, AND TRACK
PROGRESS. AB 2027 BUILDS UPON
THAT SUCCESS, AND WE REQUEST AN
I VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. DANNY MERKLEY WITH
THE GOCO GROUP REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS, MANY STATE
AGENCIES ARE CHARGED WITH,
INDIVIDUALLY CONTROLLING
INVASIVE SPECIES. DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AG, FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND MANY OTHERS. AB 2827 CHARGES
THESE ENTITIES TO COME TOGETHER
AND WORK TOGETHER, NOT,
INDIVIDUALLY IN THEIR SILOS. AB
2827 ESTABLISHES A STATEWIDE
GOAL WITHOUT A STATEWIDE GOAL.
TYPICALLY, IN STATE LAW, NO
RESOURCES ARE DEDICATED.
PREVENTION VERSUS ERADICATION.
IT'S LIKE TAKING CARE OF YOUR
BODY, WORKING OUT. IT'S NOT
EASY. BUT IT'S A LOT SMARTER IN
THE LONG RUN THAN HAVING SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS. SAME WITH YOUR
VEHICLE MAINTENANCE IS NOT NOT,
INEXPENSIVE, BUT IT'S A LOT
CHEAPER TO CHANGE YOUR OIL EVERY
5000 MILES THAN IT IS TO,
REPLACE YOUR ENGINE. SO A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THIS
YEAR, THE STATE WAS, FORCED TO,
DEDICATE $50 MILLION FOR,
ERADICATING THE EXOTIC FRUIT FLY
DURING THIS VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR, WITH THAT, WE ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM FOR ME TO TESTIMONY,
NAME, POSITION, AFFILIATION ON
THE MEASURE, NEGOTIATION
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. SORRY.
AND, NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ABIGAIL MOUNT, ON
BEHALF OF MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, DOUG JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM, I WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS, SENATOR LEAR, THANK
YOU, THE WITNESS MENTIONED
SOMETHING I MIGHT REMEMBER FROM
FROM RESOURCES, BUT THE THING I
REALLY REMEMBER IS BEING IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN MY DISTRICT WAS
TARGETED FOR THE LIGHT BROWN
APPLE MOTH, AND THERE WAS SUCH
AN OUTPOURING THAT I HAD TO
CHANGE THE OUTGOING MESSAGE IN
MY DISTRICT OFFICE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WAS ON THE PHONE 100%
OF THE TIME, AND WHAT CAME OUT
OF THAT WAS A BILL THAT
COMPLEMENTS THIS PERFECTLY,
BECAUSE IT WAS A PROGRAMMATIC
EIR ON WHAT MIGHT BE SPRAYED AT
ANY TIME, BECAUSE AT THAT TIME,
THE EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A
PHEROMONE, PEOPLE WERE MOVING
OUT OF TOWN. ALL THIS STUFF WAS
HAPPENING. IT WAS JUST COMPLETE
CRAZINESS. AND IF WE HAD A
PROGRAMMATIC EIR THAT SAID, THIS
IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT EACH OF
THESE, YOU'D HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION WAY IN ADVANCE AS
PREVENTION, TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT WITH ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE
SPRAYED. THIS BILL COMPLEMENTS
IT PERFECTLY BECAUSE IT IS SORT
OF PREVENTION IN ANOTHER WAY,
AND IT MAKES COMPLETE SENSE TO
HAVE IN THE CONTINUUM OF, OF
THINGS. AND IF WE EVER HAVE A
QUORUM, I WILL BE HAPPY TO MOVE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL TO MOVE IT AFTER WE
HAVE A QUORUM FROM SENATOR LAIRD
SENATOR DAHLE, REAL QUICK
QUESTION. WHAT IS THE WHAT IS
THE CURE? WHAT IS THE WHAT'S THE
PROCESS FOR THE CURE? WELL,
SENATOR DALY, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. AND I'M SORRY, WITH
THE CHAIR'S PERMISSION, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE, VARIOUS
AGENCIES, COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS OR OTHERS ARE
WORKING ON WHAT'S CALLED C3.
IT'S A COMPREHENSIVE PEST
PREVENTION STUDY. THAT STUDY
WILL IDENTIFY THE PATHWAYS FOR
INTRODUCTIONS OF NEW EXOTIC
PESTS AND DISEASES. AND IT WILL
ALSO IDENTIFY WHERE WE HAVE
VULNERABILITIES AND WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE INVESTMENTS AND
LOOK AT, SORT OF POLICY CHANGES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE SHORING THAT UP. THAT
COULD BE INVESTMENTS IN BORDER
PROTECTION STATIONS. IT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTING, REGION WIDE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS. OR IT
COULD BE HAVING EXACTLY LIKE
THAT PAYERS FOR ALTERNATIVE
PRODUCTS AS WELL. THANK YOU.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS
WELL. I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PLAN WAS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION. I OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR, EFFORT TO TRY
TO ADDRESS INVASIVE SPECIES, THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES RAISE
THE POTENTIAL CONCERN THAT THIS
IS DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
EFFORTS, INCLUDING THE INVASIVE
SPECIES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I GUESS I WAS INTERESTED IN
YOUR THOUGHTS OR YOUR WITNESSES
THOUGHTS ON WHY A SECONDARY
EFFORT WAS NECESSARY. WHY NOT
WORK THROUGH EXISTING PROGRAMS
RATHER THAN HAVE PROGRAM
OVERLAPS AND THE POTENTIAL
INEFFICIENCIES AND CONFUSION
THOSE CAN CAUSE? I YEAH, YOU CAN
GO AHEAD IF YOU'D LIKE. OKAY.
THANK YOU, I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION. I ALSO THINK
THAT OVER FIVE YEARS AGO, WHEN
THE INVASIVE SPECIES COUNCIL AND
CISAC'S WITH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WAS CREATED, WE WERE
OPERATING UNDER DIFFERENT
PARADIGM. LAST YEAR, WE HAD A
HURRICANE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE'VE GOT MAJOR
CLIMACTIC EXTREMES. WE ARE
SEEING NEW EXOTIC AND INVASIVES
IN CALIFORNIA AT A MORE RAPID
CLIP THAN WE HAD AT THAT TIME. I
THINK CISAC AND THE INVASIVE
SPECIES COUNCIL IS A
COMPLEMENTARY FUNCTION OF THIS
BILL, THE RECENT AMENDMENTS DO
CHARGE CDFA TO LEAD THAT CISAC
IS A PARTY ON ON THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AS WELL, AND THE
COUNCIL. BUT WE NEED TO BRING
MORE PEOPLE TO THE TO THE TABLE.
WE NEED THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. WE NEED THE
CONSERVATION CORPS. WE NEED
OTHERS THAN OUR TRADITIONAL
RESOURCE PARTNERS TO FIND THAT
OUT. AND I THINK HAVING A
STATEWIDE GOAL FACILITATES THAT.
I APPRECIATE THE ANSWER. I'LL
ALSO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES TO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
SO WHEN YOU DO HAVE A QUORUM, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TO RECESS. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER POTENTIAL
AUTHORS IN THE ROOM, WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A SHORT RECESS. AND GET
READY TO GO. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL RESUME. OKAY.
WE'RE IN 30. SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATERS WATER
COMMITTEE WILL RESUME IN 30S.
OKAY. SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER, ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON,
YOU'RE HERE. YOU CAN PRESENT,
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2091.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS BILL
AND ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE, AB 2091 IS A SIMPLE
BILL OF COURSE, THAT WOULD HELP
EXPEDITE PUBLIC ACCESS TO OPEN
SPACE IN CALIFORNIA UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT. KNOWN AS SEQUA, LOCAL
AGENCIES MUST CONDUCT
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS FOR PROJECTS THAT, THAT
IMPACT THE ENVIRONMENT, UNLESS
CATEGORICALLY EXEMPTED.
CURRENTLY, A CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTION EXISTS WHICH ALLOWS A
PARK DISTRICT TO ACQUIRE LAND
FOR OPEN SPACE PRESERVATION.
WITHOUT CEQA REVIEW, BUT NO
EXEMPTION EXISTS FOR CHANGING
THE USE OF SUCH LAND FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS. EVEN IF THE ACQUIRED
LAND ALREADY HAS EXISTING ROADS
AND TRAILS THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO
THE ACQUISITION. AB 2091 WILL
EXEMPT THE OPENING OF EXISTING
ROADS AND TRAILS FOR SPECIFIED
NON-MOTORIZED RECREATIONAL USES
TO THE PUBLIC ON OPEN SPACE
PROPERTIES OWNED AND OPERATED BY
A REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. THIS
LIMITED EXEMPTION APPLIES ONLY
WHERE ROADS AND DISTURBED AREAS
EXISTED PRIOR TO PUBLIC AGENCY
ACQUISITION, AND WHERE NO
SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
ARE REQUIRED FOR PUBLIC ACCESS.
IT IS ALSO NARROWED TO SPECIFIED
INDEPENDENT REGIONAL PARK OR
OPEN SPACE DISTRICTS. THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT ON EXISTING
LAND COVENANTS SUCH AS GRANT
AGREEMENTS, CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS, OR LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT PLANS. PARK DISTRICTS
WILL STILL BE ABLE WILL STILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING
MANAGEMENT POLICIES THAT PROTECT
SPECIES, HABITAT AND TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND
IMPORTANTLY, THIS BILL WILL ALSO
HELP SAVE PARK DISTRICT
RESOURCES AND EXPEDITE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO ACQUIRED LANDS AND I
DO BELIEVE WITH US TODAY IS
JENNIFER GALEHOUSE, REPRESENTING
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARKS. THROUGH
THE CHAIR. YOU HAVE JUST ONE
WITNESS TODAY. YES, GREAT. YOU
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES. IF
YOU'D LIKE. THANK YOU, MY NAME
IS JENNIFER GALEHOUSE. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT, AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THE HELP IN GETTING THE
AMENDMENTS, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
TIGHT TIMEFRAME WE WORKED ON.
THIS BILL IS NARROWLY DRAFTED,
TO ADDRESS THE APPLICABILITY OF
SEQUA. WHEN YOU HAVE A CHANGE IN
USE, IN THE SITUATION WITH THE
PARK DISTRICT, THE LOCALS PASSED
A LOCAL BOND FOR PARK
ACQUISITION. AND NOW THERE ARE
SITES THAT HAVE EXISTING ROADS
AND TRAILS THAT THE DISTRICT
LIKED TO OPEN UP TO THE PUBLIC,
BUT THEY'RE NOT QUITE READY. AND
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO FULLY
DEVELOP THE PARK. AND SO THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS BEFORE THEY'RE READY TO
DO FULL SEQUA, WHICH THEY PLAN
TO DO WHEN THEY PLAN TO CHANGE
THE PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT,
MEANING ADD BENCHES, CAMPGROUNDS
, BATHROOMS AS SUCH. SO WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO IS ALLOW
NON-MOTORIZED RECREATION ON
EXISTING TRAILS AND PARKS. WHEN
THE PARK IS FULLY DEVELOPED AND
OPENED UP TO THE PUBLIC FOR
OTHER KINDS OF RECREATION, A
FULL SEQUA WILL BE PERFORMED AT
THAT TIME. BEFORE IT'S OPENED UP
TO THE PUBLIC FOR THAT KIND OF
STUFF. SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OPPOSITION.
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONFUSION IN
WHETHER WE'RE CITING THE TRAILS.
THE TRAILS ARE ACTUALLY CITED
AND EXISTING. WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANYTHING. WE'RE NOT MOVING THE
TRAILS, WE'RE NOT CITING ANY
EXISTING TRAILS, EXPANDING THEM.
WE'RE NOT CHANGING ANY OF THE
GRADING ON THE ROADS. SO THIS
SIMPLY IS ALLOWING THE PUBLIC TO
ENJOY THE RESOURCE BEFORE THE
DISTRICT'S FULLY READY TO
DEVELOP THE PARK. AND ALLOW
OTHER KINDS OF RECREATION. SO
WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESS IN THE
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM? ME TWO
TESTIMONY. NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. ABIGAIL
SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ETHAN NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES, DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? ARE YOU
A LEAD WITNESS, SIR, IS IT JUST
THE ONE OF YOU TODAY, I BELIEVE
SO. OKAY. IF YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES, GOOD MORNING, SENATORS.
I HAVE MATTHEW BAKER, POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION, LIKE WE DID WITH
OUR SOME OF OUR PARTNERS
INITIALLY SUBMIT A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION, JUST OUT OF CONCERN
THAT WE DO FEEL THAT EVEN
NON-MOTORIZED ACCESS COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS, POTENTIALLY
VERY SIGNIFICANT. AND WE DO FEEL
THAT THAT WARRANTS REVIEW. BUT
WE ALSO PROMOTE, YOU KNOW,
BETTER, MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
PUBLIC LANDS AS WELL. AND
TALKING TO THE SPONSORS, WE
REALIZED THEY HAD GENUINE
OBSTRUCTIONS IN THIS AREA, AND
WE REALLY WORKED WITH THEM TO
TRY TO DEDICATE A LOT OF THOUGHT
TO HOW YOU WOULD SHAPE THIS
POLICY TO REALLY LIMIT IT TO THE
LAND MANAGERS THAT REALLY HAVE
THE PLANNING AND, AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT RESOURCES IN PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY, YOU
KNOW, HANDLE THOSE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS WITH THIS INCREASED
ACCESS. SO, YOU KNOW, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH, WITH THE AUTHOR,
WITH THE SPONSORS, AND WITH THE
COMMITTEES, AND WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS. WE THINK IT'S A
HUGE IMPROVEMENT. AND THIS IS
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION TO FULLY
RETRACT OUR OPPOSITION JUST YET,
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT
WE WOULD STILL LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHOR. AND,
BUT IF YOU DO PASS IT TODAY, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR, AND WE HOPE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS CONTINUED. COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH US. SO THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER, WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? ME TOO.
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK. I WOULD JUST SAY
I REALLY AWARE OF THE ORIGINAL
ISSUE YOU WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS
WITH THIS BILL. AND I APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT NARROW IT.
IN THE IDEAL WORLD, IT WOULD BE
NARROWED EVEN MORE BECAUSE I
HAVE A DISTRICT THAT GETS
DRAGGED INTO THIS, AND I WOULD
JUST AS SOON NOT SEE THEM
INVOLVED IN THIS. BUT I THINK,
IT'S IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
YOU'RE ADDRESSING A SERIOUS
PROBLEM, AND I'LL BE PREPARED TO
MOVE THE BILL WHENEVER WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. ANY ANYONE
ELSE ON THE DÍAS, SEEING NO ONE
ELSE, I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL. AND JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY, YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. THAT IS
CORRECT. GREAT. AND I DO SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORT TO OPEN UP OPEN
SPACE AREAS TO THE PUBLIC, AND
TRYING TO FAST TRACK SEQUA WITH
THAT, BUT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL TO CERTAIN REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICTS AND ADDING
SAFEGUARDS FOR LISTED SPECIES,
TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES, AND
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC INPUT, WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT, THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AND, COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE GREAT WORK AND WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, WE'LL TAKE THAT
UP AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM, ONE PERSON, WE
NEED ONE PERSON, OR WE NEED ONE
AUTHOR WAITING ON AUTHORS. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM READY TO
PRESENT GOING ONCE, GOING TWICE,
OR. ALL RIGHT, I GUESS WE'LL
TAKE ANOTHER RECESS UNTIL WE
FIND ANOTHER AUTHOR.
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER. WE HAVE OUR NEXT AUTHOR
IN THE ROOM, ASSEMBLYMAN
CONNELLY, WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
TO PRESENT, STAGE IS YOURS,
BILL. IT IS, THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 828. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR THEIR GREAT WORK AND INPUT
ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. THERE CAN BE NO
DOUBT AS TO THE INCREDIBLE
IMPACT THAT THE, SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT IS
HAVING ON ALL WATER USERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S OVERDRAFTED BASINS.
IT ALSO CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED
JUST HOW MUCH SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND NATURAL
CONSERVATION AREAS HAVE SUFFERED
BECAUSE OF DECADES OF
UNREGULATED OVERPUMPING. THERE
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT WORK DONE
BY GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES, LOCAL WATER USERS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT SIGMA. HOWEVER
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS
IN SOME CASES DID NOT DO A
THOROUGH JOB IDENTIFYING MANAGE
WETLANDS AND SMALL COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS IN THEIR BASINS
AND EXACTLY HOW GHSP MANAGEMENT
WILL ADVERSELY IMPACT THEM.
MANAGE WETLANDS ARE A CRITICAL
NATURAL RESOURCE FOR OUR STATE.
THEY PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT HABITAT
FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES,
MIGRATORY BIRDS OF THE PACIFIC
FLYWAY, AND MANY OTHER NATIVE
WILDLIFE AND FISH POPULATIONS
MANAGE WETLANDS, ALSO IMPROVE
LOCAL WATER QUALITY, AID IN
FLOOD PROTECTION, PROVIDE
RECREATION, AND OFFER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH. UNFORTUNATELY, ONLY 5%
OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
WETLANDS REMAIN. THESE IMPORTANT
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCES CONTINUE
TO FACE NUMEROUS THREATS,
INCLUDING WATER AVAILABILITY.
NEARLY 85% OF CALIFORNIANS
DEPEND IN WHOLE OR IN PART ON
GROUNDWATER FOR THEIR PUBLIC
WATER SUPPLY. THAT PERCENTAGE
INCREASES EVEN MORE FOR SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS, WHICH HAVE FEWER
THAN 3300 CONNECTIONS, AND
SERVICE COMMUNITIES WHOSE ACCESS
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER IS MOST
AT RISK. THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES USUALLY DEPEND ON A
SINGLE SOURCE FOR THEIR WATER
SUPPLY, LEAVING THEM VULNERABLE
TO DROUGHT OR OVERPUMPING BY
THEIR NEIGHBORS. THEY ALSO FACE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES AND
LACK THE LOCAL ECONOMY NEEDED TO
ADDRESS FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT OFTEN COME WHEN
RUNNING A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
THIS BILL OFFERS WHAT WE THINK
IS A MODEST AND REASONABLE STEP
TOWARD PROTECTING SAFE AND CLEAN
WATER ACCESSIBILITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL NOW ONLY
EXEMPTS WETLANDS AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES IN BASINS WHERE
THERE IS NO APPROVED GSP. THE
BILL ALSO STILL ONLY EXEMPTS THE
AVERAGE GROUNDWATER USAGE
ANNUALLY FROM 2015 TO 2020. ANY
INCREASE OVER THAT AVERAGE IS
SUBJECT TO REGULATION BY GSA'S.
GOING FORWARD, AB 828 WILL
REQUIRE GSPS TO INCLUDE THE
PLANS. IMPACTS ON WATER SUPPLIES
FOR WETLANDS AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THEIR
NEEDS ARE MET. SO WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS ELLEN WEIR,
GENERAL COUNSEL AT GRASSLAND
WATER DISTRICT AND JENNIFER
CLARY, STATE DIRECTOR AT CLEAN
WATER ACTION. WE HEAR FROM OUR
WITNESS. THANK YOU. YOU DUE TO
TIME CONSTRAINTS, WE'LL LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ELLEN WE'RE ALSO WITH THE EAST
GRASSLANDS WETLANDS ASSOCIATION.
SO I WORK ON WATER ISSUES THAT
AFFECT WETLANDS IN THE VALLEY.
ABA 828 ADDRESSES A FEW VERY
NARROW BUT UNINTENDED IMPACTS OF
SIGMA. SINCE THE BILL WAS
INTRODUCED, THOSE IMPACTS HAVE
COME INTO SHARPER FOCUS. SO I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE
EXAMPLES, FIRST, JUST LAST WEEK,
THE MERCED SUB-BASIN ADOPTED
SIGMA FEES THAT INCREASED THE
TAX RATE FOR CONSERVATION
EASEMENT LANDS BY 160, WHAT WAS
ONCE A $4,000 A YEAR TAX BILL IS
NOW ALMOST $10,000 A YEAR ON
EACH PARCEL, THOSE FEES AFFECT
2000 ACRES OF MANAGED WETLANDS
IN THE SAN LUIS WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT AREA, AND THE OWNERS
ARE UNSURE IF THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO MAINTAIN THOSE EASEMENTS. THE
WETLANDS PROVIDE ONLY 1% OF THE
LOCAL SIGMA BUDGET, BUT THEIR
LOSS WOULD REPRESENT A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THAT WOULD BE
FELT STATEWIDE. ANOTHER QUICK
EXAMPLE IN THE CURRENT SUB
BASIN, OVER 2000 ACRES OF
MANAGED WETLANDS RECEIVED A
GROUNDWATER ALLOCATION FROM THE
LOCAL AGENCY. THAT IS FAR LESS
THAN WHAT THEY NEED TO SUPPORT
THEIR EASEMENT HABITAT, AND THEY
DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY CREDIT FOR
THE RECHARGE AT THE NEARBY KERN
REFUGE. AGAIN, THESE WETLANDS
ARE LESS THAN 1% OF THE
IRRIGATED ACREAGE IN THE BASIN,
BUT GROUNDWATER ALLOCATIONS ARE
EFFECTIVELY PUTTING A
PROHIBITION ON THEIR ABILITY TO
BE MAINTAINED. THE PROTECTED
LANDS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THIS
BILL, ALL OF THE PROTECTED
WETLANDS THAT ARE LISTED IN THE
DEFINITION HAVE PERMANENT
RESTRICTIONS THAT REQUIRE THE
LAND BE MAINTAINED AS HABITAT,
SO THEY'RE NOT FOR PROFIT. THEY
CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN SIGMA
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS LIKE
VOLUNTARY FALLOWING PROGRAMS OR
THE TRADING AWAY OF THEIR WATER
ALLOCATIONS. AB 828 SEEKS TO
PROTECT SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE IN THESE LANDS AND
PERPETUATE WILDLIFE, CARBON,
WATER QUALITY, OTHER BENEFITS
THAT THE AUTHOR MENTIONED,
BRIEFLY, LEGALLY, A MULTIPLE
ATTORNEYS HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
SHIFTING A SMALL PORTION OF A
LOCAL FEE, FOR THIS PURPOSE DOES
NOT VIOLATE PROP EIGHT, 218, OR
PROP 26, REQUIRING AGENCIES TO
GIVE CONSIDERATIONS TO WETLANDS
PRESERVES OUR PUBLIC INVESTMENT
IN HABITAT, AND WE'LL HAVE ONLY
A NEGLIGIBLE. YOU CAN START TO
WRAP UP. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. I CAN
DO IT IN ONE AND A HALF. THERE
YOU GO. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER CLARY. I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION. OUR ORGANIZATION
HAS ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA. AND
LAST YEAR, THE WORK THAT WE DID
IN, IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY, AUDUBON AND
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
WAS PUBLISHED IN THE JOURNAL
NATURE. WHAT WE FOUND IN
REVIEWING EVERY PLAN IN THE
STATE IS THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER OR TOTALLY
UNREPRESENTED IN THESE PLANS,
AND THAT HAS A REAL IMPACT. I
MEAN, WE SEE AN IMPACT
ECONOMICALLY. IF YOU'RE CHARGED
HIGH FEES OR FINES FOR WATER
USAGE, BUT ALSO JUST BECAUSE OF
A LACK OF WATER. I MEAN, WE'VE
SEEN THOUSANDS OF WELLS GO DRY
DURING THE MOST RECENT DROUGHT.
SO TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD, HOW
DO WE EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD,
WHAT WE'D SUGGESTED WHEN WE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL WAS AN
EXEMPTION OF JUST EXEMPT THESE
COMMUNITIES FROM THESE FEES AND
FINES. THE LEGISLATURE DISAGREED
WITH US BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. SO WE CAN TAKE A
HINT. SO WHAT WE'VE DONE AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE STAFF WORKING
WITH US, IS WE'VE TRIED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN EVEN THE
PLAYING FIELD AND ADD A FEW MORE
GUARDRAILS SO THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR INTERESTS
ARE CONSIDERED. I MEAN, THAT'S
ACTUALLY AT THE LAW IN SIGMA IS
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO CONSIDER THE
BENEFIT ALL BENEFICIAL USES AND
USERS AND HOW WE MAKE THAT
HAPPEN IS WHAT WE ALL NEED TO
FIGURE OUT. SO WE'RE ADDING A
FEW MORE ITEMS TO WHAT GSA'S
HAVE TO DO. AND THEIR PLANS, AND
WHAT DWR HAS TO DO IN ITS REVIEW
OF THOSE PLANS. AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT WORKS. THANK YOU. IT
WAS A MINUTE AND A HALF. THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
ME TO TESTIMONY NAME,
AFFILIATION, POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. MIKE LINES, AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA. AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MEGAN
CLEVELAND WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES, TODAY REPRESENTING THE
TULARE BASIN WETLANDS
ASSOCIATION, THE BLACK BRANT
GROUP, CALIFORNIA. HOUSMAN FOR
CONSERVATION, THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION, CAL
OR WETLANDS AND WATERFOWL
COUNSEL, CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION, AND THE
CALIFORNIA HIKING CLUB, ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 828. THANK
YOU. MORNING, SARAH NOCITO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, TASHA NEWMAN
ON BEHALF OF SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CELESTE WICKS. WITH CLEAN
AIR FOR KIDS AND STRONG SUPPORT
ALSO IN SUPPORT. NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY, JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY AND CA
GRANDPARENTS ACTING TOGETHER
FACTS AND CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS. KIM
DELFINO ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU M.J. KUSHNER WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MATTHEW BECKER,
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? JUST
ONE. OH, YOU GOT TWO. OKAY YOU
EACH HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS, BOB REEB WITH
REEB GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY WATER
COALITION. WHILE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND EFFORT
THAT MR. JACOBS COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT HAS PROVIDED AND
WORKING WITH US, WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA IS A
COMPLEX, EXPENSIVE AND TIME
CONSUMING UNDERTAKING. PRIOR
EFFORTS TO MANAGE GROUNDWATER
FAILED IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO LACK
OF LOCAL AGENCY AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE FEES AND CHARGES TO PAY
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
PLANS. SIGMA CORRECTED THIS
FAILURE BY AUTHORIZING
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES TO IMPOSE REGULATORY
FEES PURSUANT TO PROPOSITION 26
AND PROPERTY RELATED FEES AND
CHARGES ON, BASED ON ACREAGE AND
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTION. PURSUANT
TO PROPOSITION 218. CURRENTLY
ALL LAND OWNERS AND GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTORS, SAVE FOR THOSE WHO
PUMP LESS THAN TWO ACRE FEET PER
YEAR, CONTRIBUTE TO THE COST OF
BOTH PREPARING AND IMPLEMENTING
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS. SIGMA CODIFIED THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
GSA'S WITH THE AUTHORITY AND THE
TECHNICAL AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY TO
SUSTAINABLY MANAGE GROUNDWATER,
AND TO MANAGE GROUNDWATER
BASINS. THROUGH ACTIONS OF GSA'S
, TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
FEASIBLE WHILE MINIMIZING STATE
INTERVENTION. CONTRARY TO THAT
INTENT, AB 828 WILL IMPEDE THE
WORK OF GSA'S BY EXEMPTING SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS AND MANAGED
WETLANDS FROM GROUNDWATER
REGULATION AND PAYING
GROUNDWATER PUMPING FEES. THIS
WILL MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE GROUNDWATER AND
SUSTAINABLE MANAGER MANAGED
MANNER. THIS WILL CREATE
LITIGATION RISK FOR GSA'S, WHO
MUST COMPLY WITH CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS RELATING TO
REGULATORY AND PROPERTY RELATED
FEES AND CHARGES, AND THIS WILL
SLOW IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA BY
REDUCING LOCALLY GENERATED
REVENUES. WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE HAVE A
SECOND WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. I
GUESS NOT. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL? ME TOO. TESTIMONY, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. DENNIS ALBIANI WITH
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATION, SEVERAL OTHER
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS, OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHRIS ANDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES.
APOLOGIES FOR THE LATE LETTER.
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
REVIEW THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, ALEX BARRON,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, BRENDA BASS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WESTERN GROWERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. DANNY
MERKLEY WITH THE GLAUCO GROUP,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS, KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT, MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
OPPOSITION AND THEN ALSO IN
OPPOSITION COULD NOT BE HERE,
CMA, THANK YOU, CLIFTON WILSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH SAN
JOAQUIN IRRIGATION DISTRICT, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS, ANY MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SENATOR DALY? WELL, FIRST, I
JUST WANT TO SAY SOMEBODY WHO'S
IN A, SO I HAVE WETLANDS, AND
JUST IN THE VALLEY WHERE I FARM,
WE HAVE A CREEK WILDLIFE AREA.
IT'S 14,000 ACRES OF PRESERVE,
AND WE ALSO HAVE A GSA. WE HAVE
A GROUNDWATER, WE HAVE SIGMA.
SO, AND I LOOKED AT THIS BILL
AND LOOKED AT MY DISTRICT, AND I
THINK IT WAS SUPPLIED SOME
INFORMATION FROM, SOME OF THE
WATERFOWL FOLKS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL ON HOW IT
WOULD AFFECT MY DISTRICT. AND
APPARENTLY THE AREAS WHERE, WE
HAVE ACTUALLY GROUNDWATER
PUMPING FOR THESE WILDLIFE
AREAS. THEY'RE PARTICIPATING IN
OUR GSA STUFF. SO IT'S GOOD, BUT
I WANT TO SAY, THE QUESTION IS,
IS THAT FOR ME IS IF YOU EXEMPT
SOMEBODY THAT'S IN, IT'S IN THE
BASIN OR IN THE, IN THE
GROUNDWATER AREA, SOMEBODY ELSE
HAS TO PAY FOR IT. AT THE END OF
THE DAY, YOU STILL HAVE TO DO
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO GET DONE,
AND SO IT JUST AS WE NARROW IT
DOWN TO EXEMPTING ALL THESE
FOLKS, SOMEBODY HAS TO STILL GET
THE WORK DONE AND, AND PAY FOR
THE REGULATIONS SO THAT MEANS
THAT IT'S COST SHIFTING TO THE
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T EXEMPTED. SO
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE FOR
ME SOME. AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION IS WHAT DOES THE STATE
WATER BOARD'S ROLE IN THIS AS
WELL? AND MAYBE ON THE LATTER
I'LL CALL ON OUR LEGAL EXPERT.
BUT, NØ GREAT QUESTION. I THINK
REALLY THE GOAL HERE IS IT'S NOT
LIKE A WHOLESALE, ATTEMPT TO
EXEMPT, IT'S REALLY RECOGNIZING
A FEW UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES,
NAMELY IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, SMALL AGENCIES,
EFFECTIVELY MAINTAINING THE
STATUS QUO, YOU'RE LOOKING AT
AVERAGE USAGE. YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWING FOR ADDITIONAL,
PUMPING. AND THE GOAL IS TO MOVE
FOLKS TOWARD ACTUALLY HAVING
PLANS. I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
WITH THAT. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT I
THINK EVEN Dð, I WOULD SAY A
BETTER JOB OF EFFECTUATING THAT
GOAL, WHILE I HAVE THE FLOOR, I
ALSO JUST WANTED TO, MENTION
SOMEWHAT OFF HOT OFF THE PRESS,
A RECENT OPINION BY THE OFFICE
OF LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL, WHICH
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THE
ILLEGALITY OF THE ISSUE OF THE
EXEMPTION FROM GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION FEES BEING PROPOSED
BY, 828 THAT, THOSE WOULD BE
LEGAL. AND. YEAH, WHY DON'T WE
JUST TO QUICKLY ADDRESS THE FEE
SHIFTING, WE'VE DONE AN ANALYSIS
OF BASINS SUCH AS THOSE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. AND OTHERS. AND IT
THERE IS NO EXAMPLE WHERE THESE
FEES ARE, ARE ANYWHERE OVER 1%
OF THE BUDGET. SO IT IS A SLIGHT
COST SHIFT. IT'S 1% OR LESS IN
THE KERN BASIN, IT'S 0.3% OF THE
IRRIGATED ACREAGE IN MERCED IT'S
1.3, WHETHER THESE GSA'S CAN
NEGOTIATE WITH THEIR WELL PAID
CONSULTANTS TO REDUCE THEIR
BUDGETS BY 1.3, SO AS NOT TO
SHIFT THAT COST ONTO GROWERS,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY. BUT WE THINK IT'S A
NEGLIGIBLE AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO IT'S A TRADE OFF,
RIGHT? 1% OF A LOCAL AGENCY'S
BUDGET IN ORDER TO PRESERVE THE
ONLY REMAINING WETLANDS WE HAVE
LEFT, ESPECIALLY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY, ON YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE STATE WATER BOARD,
EACH PLAN IS IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION. AND SO THE STATE BOARD
WILL BE REVIEWING THOSE PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN REJECTED BY DWR.
AND UNDER THIS BILL, THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CONSIDER IMPACTS TO
MANAGE WETLANDS AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES AS PART OF THEIR
REVIEW. SO THE REASON I ASKED
THE SECOND QUESTION WAS BECAUSE
OURS WAS REJECTED. AND I'M JUST
GOING TO SPEAK FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. WE DID A PLAN. WE
PAID FOR IT. OF COURSE WE HAVE
TO. AND THEN WE GOT REJECTED.
AND WE BELIEVED THAT WE WEREN'T,
IN A PRIORITY ROLE, THAT WE WERE
MANAGING OUR GROUNDWATER. WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR MANY YEARS,
EVEN BEFORE SIGMA AND THE STATE
BOARD CAME IN AND SAID NO. AND
SO BASICALLY FORCED IT ON US. SO
WE HAD TO UP THE RATE AGAIN AND
COMPLY WITH THEIR WE HAVE A THE
BATTLE IS THE LEGAL BATTLE
BETWEEN WHO'S RIGHT OR WRONG.
AND IT'S OVER A LONG TIME. IT'S
VERY HARD TO YOU CAN'T LOOK IN
THE GROUND AND SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON DOWN THERE. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. SO MY, MY WORRY THAT
IS LOOK, I KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A SMALL AMOUNT, BUT IF YOU
EXEMPT PEOPLE OUT THERE, NOT
PART OF THE PROCESS ANYMORE,
THEY'RE OUT. AND THEN THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL LEFT HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IF THAT IF YOU
HAVE A OVERDRAFTED GROUNDWATER
BASIN, WHICH YOU DO TYPICALLY IN
MOST PLACES, THEY HAVE TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. AND THAT MEANS THAT
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO LOSE WATER.
NOT NOT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXEMPTED ARE NOT GOING TO LOSE
THEIR WATER BECAUSE THEY'RE OUT
NOW. THEY'RE NOT AT THE TABLE
ANYMORE. AND NOW EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT'S LEFT HAS TO PAY FOR IT.
SO THAT'S THE REASON THAT I HAVE
SOME VERY BIG CHALLENGES. AND
IT'S THE FARMER THAT'S LEFT THAT
YOU GO AFTER. USUALLY IN THERE,
WE ALWAYS HAVE TO GIVE. WE'RE
THE LAST ONE. WE'RE THE LAST
ONES THAT LEFT. AND THEN AND
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT US. WE GOT
TO PAY. WE'RE WE'RE IN BUSINESS.
APPARENTLY WE'RE WEALTHY.
APPARENTLY I'M NOT. AND MY
NEIGHBORS AREN'T. WE'RE GETTING
HAMMERED BY SO MUCH REGULATION.
AND THEN WE'RE THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO PAY. AND EVERYBODY ELSE
GETS A FREE RIDE. THAT SO I'M
NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. I WANT TO BRING UP
THESE THINGS. THESE ARE THESE
ARE LONG TERM ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED. AND THE FAMILY
FARMER, IN MY CASE, IT'S THE
FAMILY FARMERS. WE'RE NOT
CORPORATIONS, GIANT CORPORATIONS
. IT'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF FAMILY
FARMERS THAT ARE HAVING TO PAY A
LOT OF MONEY. WHEN WE BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE BEEN MANAGING IT WELL
FOR A LONG TIME. AND SO THIS IS
GOING TO IMPACT THOSE
COMMUNITIES, AND WE'RE ALL POOR.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE CAN'T
STAY IN CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU
FOR TRYING TO GET IT RIGHT. BUT
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE AT THE
TABLE. IF YOU'RE USING WATER AND
YOU'RE IN AND YOU'RE IN A
OVERDRAFTED GROUNDWATER, YOU'VE
GOT TO BE AT THE TABLE. I DON'T
CARE IF YOU'RE POOR, I DON'T
CARE WHAT EVERYBODY'S GOT TO BE
IN BECAUSE YOU'RE OVERDRAFTING,
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALLI.
SENATOR LAIRD, I HAVE A COMMENT
AFTER YOU ESTABLISH A QUORUM, I
MEAN, WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM AFTER THIS. OKAY? IF
SOMEBODY LEAVES, I'M GOING TO
CHASE YOU. THE LIKE MY ODDS IN
THAT RACE. YEAH ALL I CAN SAY IS
THERE'S A LOT OF MIN BILLS WE
HAVEN'T VOTED ON YET, I STARTED
OUT ON THIS BILL IN A IN A
SIMILAR PLACE AS SENATOR
DONNELLY. BECAUSE I THOUGHT, WHY
ARE WE MAKING ANY EXEMPTIONS
FROM SIGMA WHEN WE ARE STILL 15
YEARS FROM THE TIME THAT THAT IT
GOES INTO EFFECT AND LET'S LET
THIS PROCESS PLAY OUT BECAUSE
IT'S DIFFICULT THAN IT NEEDS TO
BE ESTABLISHED OVER TIME. I CAME
TO ANOTHER POINT OF VIEW, WHICH
IS THAT, WHEN I HAVE A JOB THAT
I CANNOT NAME BECAUSE SENATOR
GROVE, IT DRIVES HER CRAZY. WHEN
WE HAD A FOUR YEAR DROUGHT, ONE
OF THE HARDEST THINGS WE HAD TO
DO IN ALLOCATING THE WATER WAS
ALLOCATING THE WATER FOR
WETLANDS, BECAUSE THERE WAS A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF STAKEHOLDERS
THAT DID NOT ADVOCATE IN A WAY
THAT IT STRUCTURALLY WAS HARD TO
GET IT DONE AND GET THAT
PROTECTION DONE. AND THEN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS, IT IS REALLY
1% OR LESS OF THE ENTIRE AMOUNT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO IT
IS A DE MINIMIS IMPACT ON WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN ANYWHERE. SO IT IS
AS MUCH AS I WISH WE WEREN'T
DOING ANY EXEMPTIONS OF ANY KIND
UNTIL THIS WAS PLAYING OUT AND
GETTING CLOSER, THERE IS AN
UNEVEN BALANCE HERE, AND IT IS
SO SMALL THAT IT'S DE MINIMIS
COMPARED TO THE PAYMENTS AND
WHAT HAPPENS. SO, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD, ANYONE ELSE ON
THE DICE? OKAY. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU. THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
A CONCERN. THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE WITH PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES
AND MANAGED WETLANDS. BUT I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU,
RATHER THAN PURSUE EXEMPTIONS
FOR THESE USERS, WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR STAFF TO FIND A
FIX WITHIN SIGMA. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS AND JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM YOU ARE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. ABSOLUTELY
FANTASTIC. AND WITH THAT, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH. AND
REALLY JUST TO CHANNEL SENATOR
LAIRD, WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT A NARROW ISSUE HERE AROUND
MANAGED WETLANDS, SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
IN ENSURE THAT THAT THE
GROUNDWATER NEEDS OF THESE
VULNERABLE USERS ARE BETTER
ACCOUNTED FOR IN GSPS. SO WITH
THAT, WE ALL LOOK FORWARD TO
ROBUST IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA
AND THAT IT'S FURTHER IMPROVED
ALONG THE WAY AS WELL. AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMAN, WELL, BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO VOTE, WE'LL ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS. MIN. HERE
MIN HERE. SARDO ALAN. DALLI.
DALLI HERE. EGGMAN. GROVE.
GROVE. HERE HURTADO. LAIRD.
LAIRD. HERE LIMÓN. LIMÓN. HERE.
PADILLA. STERN HERE. STERN. HERE
OKAY. AND WITH THAT, DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON AB 828? ALL RIGHT. A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD, A
SILENT MOTION. LET'S, ATTACKED
MY MOTIONS. I DIDN'T ATTACK YOUR
MOTION, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FILE, ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 828. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR. MIN
MIN. AYE. SATO. ALAN DALLI.
DALLI. NO. EGGMAN GROVE. NO
HURTADO. Ó. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN
AYE. PADILLA STERN. STERN AYE.
OKAY. THAT BILL IS, VOTE. THE
VOTE COUNT IS AT FOUR TWO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL, WE'LL MOVE ON
NEXT TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON PROPOSED
CONSENT FILE. ITEM NUMBER TWO,
AB 2968 BY ASSEMBLYMAN CONNELLY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 1828
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON, FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB 1937 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. FILE
ITEM NUMBER 11, AB 2538 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. FILE
ITEM NUMBER 13, AB 2469 FROM THE
ASSEMBLY EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE. FILE ITEM NUMBER 19,
AB 2939 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RENDON AND FILE ITEM NUMBER 20,
AB 2983 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ, SINCE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED, WE WILL VOTE ON
THIS ITEM OR THIS CALENDAR
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HOW ABOUT A MOTION? I'M SORRY.
DO WE NEED, DO YOU NEED. DO WE
NEED A MOTION? MOTION? THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN. SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU'RE HAVING A ROUGH. SENATOR.
MEN CHASING THE. I MEAN, I
CARILLO ALAN DALLI. DALLI. AYE.
EGGMAN GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE. PADILLA.
STERN. STERN AYE. OKAY THAT VOTE
COUNT IS SIX ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON. CALL TO CATCH UP ON THE
BILLS. I WAS ABOUT TO MOVE TO
YOUR CHASING ME TO. WE'LL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2091
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAIRD. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EXCUSE ME, MR. CHAIR, JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION, YOU ARE ARGUING
WITH THE FORMER SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. I AM NOT
ARGUING. OKAY? I JUST THOUGHT
I'D POINT THAT OUT SINCE HE
DIDN'T SAY IT EARLIER.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MIN, HERE, I MEAN. AYE.
SATO ELLEN. DELI DELI. AYE.
EGGMAN GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. YEAH HE DID. HE TOOK THE
MINUTES. LIMÓN NO. PADILLA.
STERN. NO, I DON'T THINK SO, CAN
WE ASK THAT? YOU CAN ROLL
THROUGH THE MINUTES. YOU TOOK
THE MINUTES? DID THEY MOVE? THEY
DID. THEY REMOVE OPPOSITION?
THERE WAS A QUESTION. I THINK
THE ANSWER'S NO. THERE WAS STILL
OPPOSITION. OKAY WE'LL COME BACK
TO THIS. OKAY, SO IT'S, FOR ON
GOLF, THAT VOTE COUNT IS FOUR
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT FILE
ITEM. FILE ITEM NUMBER 18 AB
2827. DO WE HAVE A MOTION? WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIR.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MIN I,
MIN AYE. SELLADO ALLEN. DALLI.
DALLI I EGGMAN. GROVE. GROVE I
HURTADO. LAIRD I LAIRD I LIMON.
LIMON I PADILLA. STERN I STERN I
. THAT VOTE COUNT IS SIX ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON. CALL AND WITH
THAT, WE'LL RETURN TO OUR
PRESENTATIONS. WE HAVE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN IN THE ROOM TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM NUMBER 12, AB
2330. PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. ASSEMBLYMAN OKAY? OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU THIS MORNING.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2330. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE, OUR SPONSOR, AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO THIS BILL. IT IS
THROUGH THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT
I BELIEVE THE BILL AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED, WILL CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND MOVE THE
OPPOSITION TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
. MEMBERS, AS IT'S BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. SEVEN OF THE 20 MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA RECORDED HISTORY HAVE
OCCURRED IN 2020 AND 2021. THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS
DELIBERATED, SUPPORTED AND VOTED
ON MEASURES THAT TRY TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION, AS VOTING MEMBERS.
IN MANY INSTANCES, WE LOOK TO
THE EXPERTISE OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, WHO ARE OFTEN THE
FRONTLINES OF WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS. UNFORTUNATELY,
MANY OF OUR LOCAL ENTITIES HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT LONG
DELAYS AND LACK OF GUIDANCE ARE
PREVENTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
FROM BEING ABLE TO CONDUCT
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES
ON LANDS LOCATED IN FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES THAT ARE ADJACENT
TO URBAN AREAS. AB 2330 SEEKS TO
PROVIDE A CLEAR PROCESS TO
ACCELERATE WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES AND LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS TO ENSURE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS ARE
MET AND PUBLIC SAFETY IS UPHELD
BY ONE ALLOWING LOCAL AGENCIES
TO SUBMIT A WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS PLAN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WILDFIRE. FISH AND
WILDLIFE FOR REVIEW WITHIN 90
DAYS. TO INQUIRE IF AN
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT OR OTHER
PERMITS ARE NEEDED. ONCE A
COMPLETED ITP APPLICATION IS
SUBMITTED, FISH AND WILDLIFE
MUST PROCESS THEM WITHIN 45
DAYS. TWO HAVING APPROVED
APPLICATIONS, RECEIVE A FIVE
YEAR PERMIT FOR WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES TO OCCUR
WITHIN THE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES, AND THREE AND FINALLY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO POST A SUMMARY
OF THESE EFFORTS ON THEIR WEB
PAGE. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS WITH ME
TO TESTIFY THIS MORNING IS
CHRIS, THE FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY OF LAVERNE, AND MELISSA
SPARKS KRANTZ WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE, THANK YOU. TWO WITNESSES.
YOU EACH HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
TO PRESENT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, MELISSA SPARKS
KRANZ WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN AS THE SPONSORS OF
AB 2330. THE SIZE AND SEVERITY
OF WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA IS
INCREASING DUE TO CLIMATE
EXTREMES IN CALIFORNIA'S
RECORDED HISTORY. THE TOP EIGHT
LARGEST WILDFIRES, THE TOP TWO
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES
OCCURRED IN THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS, AND THE MOST DEADLIEST
WILDFIRE OCCURRED JUST SIX YEARS
AGO. ALREADY THIS YEAR, CAL FIRE
HAS REPORTED THAT OVER 95,000
ACRES HAVE BURNED IN FIRES FROM
THE SITES FIRE IN COLUSA, THE
POST FIRE IN LOS ANGELES ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO THE BORDER, 58 FIRE
IN SAN DIEGO. CITIES, COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FIRE MANAGEMENT
AND LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREAS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS, AND
HAVE IDENTIFIED FIRE HAZARD
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE. LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE FACED DIFFICULTY
DISCERNING IF ENVIRONMENTAL TAKE
PERMITS ARE NEEDED FOR PLANNED
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES, AND THEN NAVIGATING
THE PERMITTING PROCESS IN A
TIMELY MANNER TO ENSURE
VEGETATIVE MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
CAN OCCUR AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. TO IMPROVE THIS
COMMUNICATION AND TO EXPEDITE
THE PERMITTING WHILE MAINTAINING
THE STANDARDS OF THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT, THE BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
SUBMIT THEIR PROJECTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THROUGH A PRE-CONSULTATION
PROCESS THAT'S DEFINED IN THE
BILL TO INTENDED TO AVOID,
MINIMIZE, AND FULLY MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS TO WILDLIFE AND TO
STREAMLINE THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO RECEIVE A PERMIT IF
NECESSARY. AND TO CONDUCT THE
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AGAIN,
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHILE PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL AGENCIES.
TO MAXIMIZE THIS STREAMLINED
PATHWAY. WE BELIEVE THE BILL
WILL PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY
FROM THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE
WITHOUT COMPROMISING WILDLIFE
BENEFITS AND UPHOLDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING PROCESS
AT THE DEPARTMENT. WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND
THE WORK ON THIS BILL, AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN MANN, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CHRIS NAIG. I'M THE FIRE
CHIEF OF THE CITY OF LAVERNE,
WHICH IS LOCATED IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY AREA OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I AM BOTH A
MEMBER OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES, AND CURRENTLY
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES FIRE CHIEFS
SECTION. I ALSO SERVE ON THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION, AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE LA AREA FOOTHILL FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION, PRESIDENT OF
THE LA AREA FIRE CHIEFS REGIONAL
TRAINING GROUP, JPA, AND PRIOR
TO MY FIRE CHIEF APPOINTMENT,
SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE MARSHALS. AS
NOTED, IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR MUNICIPAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REDUCE THE
PUBLIC'S VULNERABILITY TO THE
DESTRUCTIVE FORCES OF
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHO MAKE UP THE STATE'S WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE. ACCORDINGLY WE
ARE REQUIRED TO EITHER ENFORCE
OR CONDUCT FUEL MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES IN THE NAME OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. AS
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS, WE
ARE TRAINED IN PREDICTING HOW A
WILDFIRE WILL TURN AND TRAVEL
BASED ON TOPOGRAPHY AND DIURNAL
WEATHER PATTERNS. HOWEVER AS
WILDFIRE IMPACTS HAVE
EXACERBATED IN THE RECENT YEARS,
IT HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY CLEAR
THAT THESE FIRES ARE NOT AS
EASILY EXTINGUISHED AS THEY ONCE
WERE. LARGE SCALE CONFLAGRATIONS
HAVE BECOME ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
KEEP UP WITH WHEN CONDITIONS
ALIGN. FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES
ARE FINITE, AND ALTHOUGH THESE
RESOURCES ARE EXTRAORDINARY AT
WHAT THEY DO, THEY CAN'T BE
EVERYWHERE ALL AT ONCE. RESEARCH
AND DATA CONTINUE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE BENEFITS OF PROVIDING A
MINIMUM OF 100FT OF DEFENSIBLE
SPACE BETWEEN STRUCTURE AND FUEL
BED CONTINUITY. IN FACT, IT IS
FOR THOSE REASONS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CODE NOW
REQUIRES IT. THAT SAID,
PROFESSIONAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE ARE CHARGED
WITH ENSURING WILDFIRE
VULNERABLE LANDS ADJACENT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE PROACTIVELY
CLEARED IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRE TO LIFE AND
PROPERTY. AB 2330 WOULD HELP OUR
JURISDICTIONS BY BETTER DEFINING
THE PROCESS OF OBTAINING THE
NECESSARY PERMITS THAT WE MAY
NEED TO MOVE OUR FUEL MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS FORWARD. WE BELIEVE THE
BILL BALANCES IMPROVING OUR
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE,
WHILE PROVIDING THE DEFINED
TIMELINE, PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPARENCY, AND WITH THE
RECENTLY ADDED AMENDMENTS, STILL
BE CONSIDERATE OF SEQUA AND CSA
REQUIREMENTS, I CAN ASSURE YOU.
WRAP UP, THE FIRE SERVICE
REMAINS BOTH HIGHLY RESPECTFUL
AND EAGER TO ENSURE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
ENVIRONMENT. ULTIMATELY, BOTH
MISSIONS CAN BE ACHIEVED
SIMULTANEOUSLY, COLLABORATING
COLLABORATIVELY, AND THAT IS
WHAT WE AIM TO ACHIEVE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU, DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? ME TOO. TESTIMONY. NAME,
AFFILIATION, POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. GOOD MORNING. KIARA
ROSS. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. ABIGAIL SMITH. ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT AND THANK YOU, CHRIS
ANDERSON, ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS. ERIC
O'DONNELL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF SANTA BARBARA, CHINO
HILLS AND PLEASANTON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, RICHARD
VILLEGAS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NO OTHER SEEING ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? WE HAVE MOTION. WE
HAVE A QUESTION OR COMMENT FROM
SENATOR GROVE. GO AHEAD, JUST A
PERSONAL SITUATION, DEALING WITH
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND SOMEBODY
WANTING TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THEY WAITED TWO AND A
HALF YEARS FOR A PERMIT. SO IF
YOU CAN GET THIS BILL OUT AND
GET THEM A PERMIT SO THEY CAN
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WHICH
WE DESPERATELY NEED IN THIS
STATE, I'M ALL IN. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BE A COAUTHOR. THANK
YOU. SENATOR HOLDEN, I JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT YOU WILL
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENT.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. CORRECT.
FANTASTIC AND I APPRECIATE THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL. THERE IS AN
EXISTING PROGRAMMATIC APPROACH
AND STREAMLINED PERMITTING
AVAILABLE FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS, BUT
THERE'S NO SUCH APPROACH FOR
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREAS. SO I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL,
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND MY
STAFF TO TRY TO REACH AGREEMENT
TO RESOLVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. AND I BELIEVE THAT WITH
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION OR NO STATED
OPPOSITION. SO I WILL BE IN EYE
ON THIS BILL AS AMENDED. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN? I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR, COMMITTEE SUPPORT
AND YOURSELF WEIGHING IN ON THIS
AS WELL AS BRINGING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. I THINK
IT'S A SMART OUTCOME, AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING IT ON TO
THE NEXT STAGE. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL FROM SENATOR
LIMÓN, ON FILE ITEM 12 AB 2330.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MIN. I MEAN, I CELADO
ALLEN DALLI. DALLI. I EGGMAN
GROVE. GROVE I HURTADO. LAIRD.
LIMÓN LIMON I PADILLA. STERN
STERN I. FIVE, THE VOTE COUNT ON
THAT BILL IS FIVE ZERO. WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALL. AND SEEING NO
AUTHORS IN THE ROOM RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER
SHORT RECESS. ADDIS.
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK FROM
RECESS. WE HAVE, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA HERE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB
2060. WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WHEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
READY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS AND
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THEIR
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL,
AB 2060 SEEKS TO STREAMLINE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS IN SUPPORT OF
THE FLOOD MANAGED AQUIFER
RECHARGE, OR KNOWN AS FLOOD-MAR
ACTIVITIES. WHEN DIVERTING LOCAL
FLOOD WATER INTO REGIONAL
GROUNDWATER BASINS. FLOOD MÀ IS
AN INTEGRATED AND VOLUNTARY
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT STRATEGY
THAT USES FLOOD WATER RESULTING
FROM OR IN ANTICIPATION OF
RAINFALL AND SNOWMELT FOR
MANAGED FOR RECHARGE ON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND WORKING
LANDSCAPES, INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO REFUGE, FLOODPLAINS
AND FLOOD BYPASSES. IN RESPONSE
TO EXCESSIVE RAINS AND FLOODING.
LAST YEAR, THE LEGISLATURE DID
PASS SB 122, WHICH CONTAINED
PROVISIONS STREAMLINING
PERMITTING PROCEDURES FOR
FLOOD-MAR PROJECTS IN CASE OF
EMERGENCY FLOODING. THIS BILL
SOUGHT TO BALANCE THE NEED FOR
SWIFT ACTION IN RESPONSE TO
SUDDEN FLOOD EVENTS, WITH A NEED
TO ENSURE THE MITIGATION OF THE
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF SUCH A DIVERSION OF
THE STEPS THAT WAS EXEMPTED TO
ENSURE TIMELY COMPLETION OF
PROJECTS WAS ENGAGING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO CREATE A LAKE AND STREAM BED
ALTERATION AGREEMENT. HOWEVER,
LAST MINUTE SINGLE USE PERMITS
ISSUED SHORTLY BEFORE A FLOOD
EVENT ARE NOT THE ONLY KINDS OF
PERMITS THAT CAN BENEFIT FROM
THIS STREAMLINING. TEMPORARY
URGENCY PERMITS ARE ANOTHER
MECHANISM BY WHICH A WATER
AGENCY OR OTHER ENTITY MAY BE
PERMITTED TO DIVERT FLOWS FOR
FLOOD-MAR PROJECTS. THESE
PERMITS DO NOT OAN DO NOT ENJOY
THE SAME MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS OF SB 122 EMERGENCY
PERMITS, BUT CAN BE USED FOR UP
TO 180 DAYS, WHICH CAN HELP
COVER MULTIPLE FLOOD EVENTS FROM
THE SAME WEATHER SYSTEM.
HOWEVER, THEY ARE STILL SUBJECT
TO THE NEGOTIATIONS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO CREATE LAKE AND STREAM BED
ALTERATION AGREEMENTS, WHICH CAN
DELAY THEM LONG ENOUGH THAT THEY
MAY FAIL TO ACTUALLY SERVE THE
PURPOSE INTENDED BY AB 2060
UPDATES. THE TEMPORARY URGENCY
PERMIT PROCESSES PROCESS TO
ALLOW FOR BYPASSING OF THE LSR
PROCESS WHEN PROJECTS IN
QUESTION MEET THE SAME LEVEL OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
REQUIRED UNDER SB 122, THE
EMERGENCY PERMIT PROCESS. THIS
WILL IMPROVE THE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO OUR WATER AGENCIES TO HELP
MANAGE FLOOD WATERS. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY RECHARGING OUR
AQUIFERS, AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE,
AS LAST YEAR I HAD TO DEAL WITH
THE FLOODING THAT HAPPENED IN
PLANADA WHERE WE HAD TO EVACUATE
4000 INDIVIDUALS FROM THAT
COMMUNITY. AND I THINK THAT BY
CHANGING SOME OF THE POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE, WE COULD
PREVENT FUTURE FLOODING, SUCH AS
THE IMPACTS THAT WE SAW IN THIS
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY. SIMILAR TO
WHAT WAS EXPERIENCED ALSO IN
PAJARO VALLEY. SO, TODAY WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS AB
26 FOR 2060. IS BRAD SAMUELSON
ON BEHALF OF MERCED IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. HI. GOOD EVENING. OR
GOOD? GOOD MORNING, JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I THINK
THIS WOULD VARY, MUCH STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS TO DIVERT WATERS AND
FLOOD TIMES IN THE MERCED AREA.
WE WE'VE EXPERIENCED FLOODING IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS. MANY TIMES
BEFORE THAT, IN ORDER TO GET
READY, WE'VE HAD TO GO THROUGH
THE LSA PROCESS, WHICH, BY
DESIGN IS A ONE OFF PERMIT. THAT
TAKES TIME AND SURVEYS AND SUCH.
THIS STREAMLINES THAT PROCESS,
LETS US DIVERT WATER AND FLOOD
TIMES AND PUT IT TO USE IN THE
UNDERGROUND. THANK YOU, DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE? JUST COME
FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME,
POSITION AND AFFILIATION. HI,
TYLER MUNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. BRENDA BASS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHRIS ANDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. SENATORS ROSANNA
CARVACHO ELLIOTT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI, ALEX BEARING,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. TAYLOR
MOTION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COTTON GROWERS AND
PROCESSORS IN CALIFORNIA.
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION AND OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. TRICIA GEHRINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GEORGE,
KEVIN, ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOND
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS. MEMBERS?
ANY COMMENTS? MOVE THE BILL.
REHAB A MOTION BY SENATOR DOLLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT, WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
NUMBER NINE, AB 2060. THE
MEASURE THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MIN SATO ALAN. DALLY.
DALLY I EGGMAN. GROVE. GROVE I.
HURTADO LAIRD. LIMÓN. LIMÓN I
PADILLA. STERN OKAY. THANK ALL
RIGHT. THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES
AND WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, SO WE ARE
STILL LOOKING FOR AUTHORS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME TO SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING
TO COME BACK FROM RECESS. WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASHKAR
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASHKAR HAS
TWO FILE ITEMS. AB 15 81, FILE
ITEM THREE AND AB 2509, FILE
ITEM FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARL
KALRA WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM THREE, WHICH IS
AB 1581? SURE THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
I'LL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. AB 1581 CODIFIES AND
EXPANDS THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE RESTORATION
MANAGEMENT PERMIT ORDINANCE,
ALSO KNOWN AS THE RMP. AS OF
2015, WE HAVE LOST 90% OF OUR
STATE'S CRITICAL WETLAND HABITAT
AND PLACED NEARLY 300 NATIVE
SPECIES ON THE THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED LIST. OUR EFFORT TO
SAVE OUR STATE'S BIODIVERSITY
HINGES ON PROTECTING, RESTORING
AND MAINTAINING THE SENSITIVE
NATURAL HABITATS THAT HOLD OUR
ECOSYSTEMS TOGETHER.
UNFORTUNATELY LONG, DUPLICATIVE
PERMITTING PROCESSES OFTEN
HINDER THE EFFICIENT APPROVAL OF
IMPORTANT HABITAT RESTORATION
PROJECTS. IN RESPONSE, SOME
STATE ENTITIES HAVE BEGUN
STREAMLINING CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THE PROJECT APPROVAL PROCESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE CREATED THE
RMP TO CONSOLIDATE CERTAIN
SPECIES. TAKE AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
VOLUNTEERING, RESTORATION,
VOLUNTARY RESTORATION PROJECTS.
WITHOUT THE RMP, THESE PROJECTS
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH ARDUOUS
AND DUPLICATIVE PROCESS OF
OBTAINING EACH AUTHORIZATION
SEPARATELY. HOWEVER, THE RMP IS
NOT CODIFIED AND IS NOT
CONSOLIDATED. ALL THE SPECIES
TAKE AUTHORIZATIONS NEEDED BY
MANY RESTORATION PROJECTS. IT
ALSO DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
ADDITIONAL AUTHORIZATIONS THAT
ARE NEEDED BY PROJECTS THAT
RESTORE RIVER, LAKE, OR STREAM
BED HABITATS. THIS MEANS THAT
THIS MEANS THAT THESE PROJECTS
MUST ALSO REQUIRE A LAKE AND
STREAM BED ALTERATION AGREEMENT,
WHICH CAN DUPLICATE OR CONFLICT
WITH THE RMP. WORKING WITH DFW,
WE HAVE AMENDED AB 1581 TO
CODIFY AND EXPAND THE RMP SO
THAT IT CONSOLIDATES ALL THE
SPECIES TAKE AND LAKE AND STREAM
BED AUTHORIZATION AGREEMENT
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT QUALIFIED
RESTORATION PROJECTS MAY NEED.
THESE NEW PROVISIONS WOULD
CONSTITUTE A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD SUNSET IN 2035. I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD EXPLICITLY ADDRESS
MITIGATION PROJECTS. ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE RMP, AB 1581 WILL
EXPEDITE CRITICAL HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS WHILE
PRESERVING DF'S ABILITY TO
EVALUATE PROPOSED PROJECTS BASED
ON THEIR POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS CHARLES
DELGADO, POLICY DIRECTOR OF
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION. GOOD
MORNING, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CHARLES
DELGADO, POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION. WE'RE
AN ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL RESOURCE
CHALLENGES. I'M HERE TODAY AS
SPONSOR OF AB 1581, A BILL
CODIFYING THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE'S RESTORATION
MANAGEMENT PERMIT AND
INCORPORATING LAKE AND STREAM
BED ALTERATION AGREEMENTS INTO
THE RMP. THANKS TO HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT, MAMMAL, BIRD AND
AMPHIBIAN SPECIES HAVE LOST 18%
OF THEIR NATURAL HABITAT ON
AVERAGE OVER THE LAST 300 YEARS.
16% OF THESE SPECIES HAVE LOST
MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR NATURAL
RANGE. WE CAN AND MUST REVERSE
THESE TRENDS. CALIFORNIA IS
LEADING THE WAY THROUGH OUR
PIONEERING 30 BY 30 MOVEMENT IN
ORDER TO MEET THE GOALS OF 30 BY
30, WE MUST MOVE QUICKLY TO
RESTORE DEGRADED HABITAT BACK TO
A HEALTHY STATE. ONE BARRIER TO
ACHIEVING TIMELY HABITAT
RESTORATION IS THE REGULATORY
PROCESS, WHICH CAN BE SLOW,
REDUNDANT AND HAVE CONFLICTING
REQUIREMENTS ISSUED BY THE
MULTIPLE STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES THAT OVERSEE
PERMITTING. THIS DYNAMIC CAN
LEAD TO AN EXCESS OF SEVERE
DELAYS, STALLED PROJECTS, AND
WASTED STATE AGENCY RESOURCES.
FORTUNATELY, CALIFORNIA HAS
RECOGNIZED THIS ISSUE AND IS
COMMITTED TO CUTTING GREEN TAPE
TO CREATE EFFICIENT PERMITTING
PROCESSES FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION APPLICATIONS. THIS
BILL, ÁP 1581, ADDS TO THE
STATE'S CUTTING GREEN TAPE
EFFORTS TO ACCELERATE HABITAT
RESTORATION. BY CODIFYING THE
RMP, DFW ESTABLISHED THE RMP
UNDER EXISTING AUTHORITY IN THE
FISH AND GAME CODE, WHICH
COMBINES SOME OF THE EXISTING
RESTORATION PERMITS, BUT NOT ALL
. AB 1581 WOULD EXPAND DFW
IMPORTANT WORK IN OVERSEEING THE
RMP BY CONSOLIDATING THE
REMAINING RESTORATION PERMITS,
INCLUDING LAKE AND STREAM BED
ALTERATION AGREEMENTS, INTO ONE
EFFICIENT PROCESS. THIS EXPANDED
RMP WILL ENABLE DFW TO MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY EVALUATE
THE POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF RESTORATION PROJECTS,
WHILE PRESERVING NECESSARY STATE
OVERSIGHT. IMPORTANTLY, DFW WILL
RETAIN THE RIGHT TO DENY
APPLICATIONS THAT IT DOES NOT
DEEM ELIGIBLE OR ADEQUATE. WE
HAVE MET WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, THE
RESTORATION COMMUNITY, AS WELL
AS ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS, AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS
PROTECTIVE, AS WELL AS EFFICIENT
WITH MEASURES SUCH AS AB 1581 AS
WELL AS OTHER CUTTING GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVES. WE WILL MEET THE
STATE'S GOALS AND QUICKLY
RESPONDING TO THE THREATS POSED
TO HABITATS BY CLIMATE CHANGE
WHILE MAKING THE MOST EFFICIENT
USE POSSIBLE OF PUBLIC FUNDING
AND AGENCY RESOURCES. I THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN CARRYING THIS
BILL, AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, POSITION AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MARK FENSTERMAKER, FOR THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY, THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS, AND THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. ABIGAIL, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT, THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, RICHARD FERGUS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DOUG JOHNSON,
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANKS.
THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING. KIM DELFINO,
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE. WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION. WE DID FILE A LETTER
OF CONCERN AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR HIS
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES WE'VE RAISED. WE THINK
THAT THE HABITAT RESTORATION
PERMIT IS ACTUALLY AN EXCELLENT
IDEA. LONG IN COMING. HOWEVER,
THE WAY IT'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN
IS VERY, VERY GENERAL. AND
BECAUSE WE'RE DECOUPLING, FROM
UNDERLYING REGULATIONS OR
STATUTES THAT WE'VE USED BEFORE,
LIKE THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
AND THE LAKE AND STREAM BED
ALTERATION ACT AND THE NATIVE
PLANT PROTECTION ACT AND THE
FULLY PROTECTED SPECIES ACT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT A
QUALIFYING RESTORATION PROJECT
IS, WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL, CLARIFICATIONS ABOUT
WHAT LEVEL OF BENEFIT IS BEING
CREATED, HOW IMPACTS ARE GOING
TO BE ANALYZED, AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESTORATION WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING WILL REMAIN IN PERPETUITY,
OR AT LEAST FOR AT LEAST SOME
PERIOD OF TIME. WE DON'T JUST DO
IT AND WALK AWAY AND THEN
INVASIVE SPECIES TAKE IT OVER.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT IF THIS IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION,
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL THE PARTIES AND
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING
UP AND SUPPORTING THE BILL
WHOLEHEARTEDLY, ONCE WE GET TO
AGREEMENT. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
SENATORS MATTHEW BAKER WITH
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE. YOU KNOW, SIMILAR TO THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY KIM, WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THE BILL. WE SUPPORT
THE INTENT AND WANT TO BE ABLE
TO ACCELERATE GOOD RESTORATION
PROJECTS. WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE RIGHT
SAFEGUARDS AND OVERSIGHT ARE IN
PLACE. AND, WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
TO THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE, AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO DO SO
AS WE FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RIGHT
POLICY IS HERE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? SENATOR STERN? YEAH.
THANK YOU, THANKS FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. MAYBE YOU COULD
JUST. WOULD YOU MIND,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, JUST COMMENTING
ON THE COMMENTS RAISED THERE,
NOT THE OPPOSITION, BUT THE
CONCERNS AND SORT OF WHERE THE
BILL STANDS RIGHT NOW, HOW YOU
SEE IT EVOLVING WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS. YEAH, I THINK
THERE'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN
THAT, THAT SOME OF THESE
MITIGATIONS THAT SOME OF THESE
MITIGATION PROJECTS MAY MISUSE
THE PROCESS AND NOT ACTUALLY
HAVE LONG TERM RESTORATION. AND
SO I THINK THERE'S, THERE'S I
THINK THAT WE HAVE A PATH
FORWARD TO TRY TO CONTINUE TO
HONE THE LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S MEANINGFUL RESTORATION
PROJECTS THAT, MOVE FORWARD. AND
IT'S NOT JUST SOME TEMPORARY
ACTION THAT ON THE SURFACE IS
IMPLIES RESTORATION, JUST IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE A PERMITTING
PROCESS. BUT IN ACTUALITY IS
JUST BEING DONE TO GET THAT
EXPEDITED PERMIT. SO I THINK
THERE'S, THERE'S WAYS WE CAN GET
THERE. I APPRECIATE THE, THE
CONCERNED PARTIES WHO I WORK
WITH QUITE OFTEN. AND I THINK
WE'LL BE ABLE TO FIND A PATH TO
CONTINUE TO. WE'VE BEEN HONING
THE LANGUAGE. I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT. DO YOU MIND IF I, MADAM
CHAIR, IF I ASK THE JUST WHAT
KINDS OF RESTORATION PROJECTS
THOSE ARE THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT? JUST SO WE KIND OF HAVE A
LITTLE SENSE OF WHERE THIS MAY
HEAD, IF YOU DON'T MIND. OH NO
PROBLEM, SO THERE ARE EXAMPLES,
PARTICULARLY IN THE WETLANDS
SETTING WHERE WETLANDS
RESTORATION, WHERE THEY'RE
RECREATE OR THEY'RE CREATING
WETLANDS. AND THE STATE WATER
BOARD SEVERAL YEARS AGO DID A
REVIEW OF RESTORATION PROJECTS
THAT WERE REQUIRED UNDER, CLEAN
WATER ACT AND FOUND THAT MORE
THAN HALF, ACTUALLY DIDN'T
PRODUCE THE BENEFIT THAT WAS
ANTICIPATED. IT IS THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE WITH ASSUMING WE CAN
RECREATE, WE CAN ENGINEER,
NATURE, WHICH IS WHY THE BEAVER
BILL IS SUCH A GREAT IDEA.
RIGHT. BECAUSE WE'VE GOT BEAVERS
THAT CAN ACTUALLY DO IT. HUMANS.
WE'RE NOT SO GOOD AT IT. SO I
THINK WHAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT SAYING WE SHOULDN'T
TRY TO DO RESTORATION. WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS, IS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
SO THAT WE'RE MONITORING WHAT
WE'VE BUILT AND THAT WE'RE
ENSURING THAT THE BENEFITS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE ARE
ACTUALLY BEING PRODUCED. SO IT'S
COMPLICATED, BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH THIS AND
THE SPONSORS WITH THIS BILL.
YEAH. THANK YOU. I, I'M
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING AND I'M, I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE
PLENTY OF THESE PROJECTS WE WANT
TO GET DONE. I JUST I WANTED TO
GET A SENSE OF WHAT THOSE JUST
CONCRETELY WHAT THOSE PROJECTS
WERE LIKE. WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE
THE WHAT ARE THE OUTLIER
EXAMPLES THAT WE'RE, WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT HERE, A
RESTORATION PROJECT THAT THAT
HASN'T DELIVERED. WHAT KIND OF
PROJECT IS THAT? IS THAT LIKE A
BERM THAT DIDN'T, YOU KNOW, END
UP HAVING HABITAT BENEFITS OR
LIKE, CAN YOU JUST BE SPECIFIC?
SURE YEAH. SO AN EXAMPLE WOULD
BE, WHERE WE'VE HAD ISSUES IS
THERE'S A RESTORATION PROJECT
THAT HAS GONE IN, IN SAY, THE
BAY LANDS AND IT WASN'T
ADEQUATELY MONITORED. AND
SPARTINA CAME IN AND COMPLETELY
OVERRAN IT, AND THEY HAD TO
LITERALLY RESTART THE
RESTORATION PROJECT ALL OVER
AGAIN OR WHERE THEY'VE GONE IN
AND TAKEN ONE TYPE OF WETLAND
AND CONVERTED IT TO ANOTHER. AND
BECAUSE THE HYDROLOGY DOESN'T
WORK LIKE IN A, IN A WHERE THE
HARDPAN IS THERE AND IT'S NOT
DRAINING THE WAY IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO, THE HYDROLOGY IS DIFFICULT.
IT'S NOT PRODUCING THE KIND OF
WETLAND BENEFITS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR, THOSE ARE GENERALLY
WHERE ENGINEERING OR INVASIVE
SPECIES IN PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE MADE THE
RESTORATION AND THE MANAGEMENT
AND THE MAINTENANCE ENDS UP
BEING REALLY. YEAH. THERE,
THERE. AND THEN CAL TROUT
ACTUALLY ALSO GAVE SOME EXAMPLES
OF WHERE, SOMETHING WAS CALLED A
RESTORATION PROJECT WHERE THEY
TOOK OUT A CULVERT, BUT THEN
THEY PUT SOMETHING ELSE IN AND
IT ACTUALLY WASN'T PRODUCING THE
RESULT FOR FISH. I'M NOT THE
TROUT. I DON'T, I DON'T REMEMBER
EXACTLY. BUT SO THERE ARE
EXAMPLES. AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO DO IS DRAFT
LANGUAGE TO TRY TO KEEP THE GOOD
STUFF IN. AND PUT SIDEBOARDS SO
WE DON'T HAVE THE BAD THINGS
HAPPENING. UNDERSTOOD. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THANKS FOR INDULGING
AND, VERY SUPPORTIVE OF HOWEVER
THAT EFFORT TRANSPIRES. I KNOW
TRUST YOU COMPLETELY AS AN
AUTHOR HERE. SO I'LL MOVE THE
BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR Ó, SENATOR LAIRD?
YEAH, JUST ONE COMMENT AND, I
THINK THE COLLOQUY AND TESTIMONY
EXPLAINED THE DIFFICULT
BALANCING THAT'S GOING ON HERE.
AND THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
STREAMLINE, AND YET THERE'S
ALWAYS THE POSSIBILITY THAT WE
CAN STREAMLINE IT BY SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE COMING IN. MY
ONE CONCERN WAS THE AMENDMENT
WITH REGARD TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
AND THAT COULD WELL ADD AN
ADDITIONAL BARRIER. AND I'M
AWARE THAT WITH THE ADVANCED
MITIGATION AND REGIONAL
CONSERVATION INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES, THEY HAD AN
EXEMPTION. AND SO THERE WAS A AS
LONG AS THERE WAS A COMMITMENT
TO A PUBLIC PROCESS, IN A WAY
THAT EVERYBODY THOUGHT WAS
TRANSPARENT, THEN THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO DO. AND, AND I
THINK THIS JUST IS ANOTHER THING
IN THE BALANCING. AND YOU KNOW,
THE LAST THING WE WANT IS TO ASK
FOR AN AMENDMENT AND THEN APPEAR
TO HAVE A JAIL BREAK. BUT IF
THERE IS BALANCING GOING ON FOR
THE STREAMLINING AND THE PUBLIC
PROCESS, THAT TIES DOWN SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP, I WOULD
HOPE WE WOULD BE FLEXIBLE ON
THAT IF THAT TURNS OUT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT HELP
EXPEDITE IT. BUT I TOO WILL,
SUPPORT THE BILL AND GIVE THE
AUTHOR THE CHANCE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THESE GREAT. THANK YOU.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY,
SENATOR STERN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRA?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, JUST
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
WILL ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
SURE WE FIND THAT RIGHT BALANCE
AND I APPRECIATE I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT, WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL FOR
THAT. THIS IS FOR FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 1581. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MIN
SEYARTO ALLEN. DALLI DALLI I
EGGMAN. GROVE. GROVE I LAIRD I
LAIRD I LIMON I LIMON I PADILLA.
STERN. STERN I ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL HAS FIVE ZERO. IT WILL BE
ON CALL. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRA, YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL.
FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2509. THANK
YOU, AB AB 2509 WOULD CODIFY
DEFINITIONS OF INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT AND INVASIVE SPECIES
AND REQUIRE THE INVASIVE,
INVASIVE SPECIES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA TO PRIORITIZE
PRINCIPLES OF INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT IN ALL OF ITS
ACTIVITIES. INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT, ALSO KNOWN AS IPM,
IS A PEST MANAGEMENT STRATEGY
THAT SEEKS TO MAXIMIZE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PEST MANAGEMENT
REMEDIES. WHILE MINIMIZING HARM
TO PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY MOVING
AWAY FROM TRADITIONAL CHEMICAL
ONLY TREATMENTS IN FAVOR OF
NUANCED SOLUTIONS THAT UTILIZE
VARIOUS PEST MANAGEMENT METHODS,
INCLUDING NON-CHEMICAL
BIOLOGICAL, PHYSICAL, AND
CULTURAL TECHNIQUES. IPM STATUS
IS AN EFFECTIVE, ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY APPROACH TO PEST
MANAGEMENT HAS CAUSED IT TO
BECOME AN INCREASINGLY POPULAR
SUBJECT OF LEGISLATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS NO
CODIFIED DEFINITION OF IPM,
LEAVING EACH PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO CREATE ITS OWN.
THIS CAN LEAD TO CONFUSION,
DELAYS IN BILL IMPLEMENTATION,
AND CONFLICTING ENFORCEMENT
ACTION. AB 2509 ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY CODIFYING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IPM
PROGRAM'S DEFINITION OF IPM.
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS CAME
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DEFINITION BALANCES IMPORTANT
HUMAN HEALTH, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION, AND PEST MANAGEMENT
NEEDS. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH CDFA TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL IS COMPATIBLE WITH THE
EXISTING INVASIVE SPECIES. EARLY
DETECTION PRACTICES, AND THE
GREATER FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL
CODE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY ARE DOUG
JOHNSON, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL, AND CODY FUENTES,
WINTER SENIOR RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT SPECIALIST OF THE
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GOOD MORNING, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M DOUG JOHNSON,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL. WE'RE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING THE STATE'S
COMMUNITY OF ECOLOGISTS, LAND
STEWARDS, AND VOLUNTEERS WHO
WORK IN OUR PARKS AND LAND
TRUSTS, CONSERVANCY'S OPEN
SPACES AND OTHER NATURAL AREAS
AND WORKING LANDS. THIS BILL
DEFINES TWO TERMS THAT ARE KEY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WORK INVASIVE
SPECIES AND INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT. INVASIVE SPECIES ARE
A MAJOR THREAT GLOBALLY AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONTROLLING
THEM IN THE ROADMAP TO 30 BY 30.
THE NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS,
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY AND THE
STATE WILDLIFE ACTION PLAN. THE
DEFINITION OF INVASIVE SPECIES
IN THE BILL IS BASED ON AN
EXISTING DESCRIPTION ALREADY IN
STATUTE, AND IT ALIGNS WITH THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION. THE SECOND
TERM IS INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT, OR IPM. THE
DEFINITION OF IPM PROPOSED IS
ONE THAT HAS BEEN ACCEPTED BY A
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS OVER
DECADES, WAS DEVELOPED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, WHICH
PROVIDES A LOT OF RESOURCES ON
IPM. AND IT'S THE SAME
DEFINITION THAT WAS AGREED TO BY
ALL THE STAKEHOLDER
REPRESENTATIVES WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE STATE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT WORKGROUP. FIRST
PRIORITY IS ALWAYS PREVENTION
AND WHAT CAN BE DONE TO STOP THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW INVASIVE
SPECIES. HOWEVER, WHEN AN
INVASIVE SPECIES IS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED, AN ACTION NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN TO REDUCE ITS IMPACTS.
AN INTEGRATED APPROACH COMBINING
VARIOUS METHODS IS NEEDED. IPM
EMPHASIZES THE USE OF
NON-CHEMICAL METHODS WHEREVER
POSSIBLE, AND FOR INVASIVE
PLANTS, THIS MEANS CUTTING THEM
DOWN, DIGGING THEM UP, MOWING,
GRAZING, BURNING, MULCHING,
TARPING THOSE KIND OF
ACTIVITIES. AND IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THESE APPROACHES DON'T
WORK ON THEIR OWN, AND HERBICIDE
MAY ALSO BE USED AS PART OF THE
INTEGRATED APPROACH. THE GROUPS
WE WORK WITH ACROSS THE STATE
ARE CHARGED WITH PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY, INCLUDING
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES, AS WELL AS PROVIDING
SAFE PUBLIC ACCESS AND REDUCING
THE RISK OF WILDFIRE AND
FLOODING. THEY ARE DEVOTED TO
FINDING THE SAFEST, MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO CONTROL
INVASIVE SPECIES AND THE
DEFINITIONS IN THIS BILL PROVIDE
A SOLID FOUNDATION FOR THIS
WORK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. AND
NOW WE WILL TAKE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. ARE YOU JUST HERE
FOR, I'M CODY SIFUENTES WINTER,
SENIOR RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
SPECIALIST. TWO MINUTES, TWO
MINUTES. EXCUSE ME, I AM CODY
SIFUENTES, WINTER. I AM THE
SENIOR RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
SPECIALIST. ALSO A SUPERVISORY
VEGETATION ECOLOGIST. MIDPEN
OWNS AND MANAGES 70,000 ACRES OF
LAND IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
FOR RECREATION, PROTECTION OF
NATURAL RESOURCES AND
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. BY 1900, AT
LEAST 34 NON-NATIVE PLANTS WERE
INTRODUCED INTO CALIFORNIA,
LARGELY AS ORNAMENTALS, BUT ALSO
AS EROSION CONTROL, AND JUST
INADVERTENTLY, THEY ARE. THOSE
34 SPECIES ARE NOW LISTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE SPECIES
COUNCIL AS BEING MODERATE TO
HIGH IMPACTS TO WILDLAND AREAS.
NEARLY 85% OF ALL RECOVERY PLANS
FOR THREATENED OR ENDANGERED
BUTTERFLY SPECIES SITE CONTROL
INVASIVE SPECIES AS PRIORITY.
THESE INCLUDE FOR THE MISSION,
BLUE BUTTERFLIES AND EVEN
MONARCHS. NON-NATIVE SPECIES
LARGELY DO NOT PROVIDE THE SAME
RESOURCES OR CONNECTIVITY TO THE
ECOSYSTEM AS THEIR NATIVE
COUNTERPARTS. THE SMALL NUMBER
OF INVASIVE SPECIES CAN HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THE ECOSYSTEM. AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF STEWARDING
LANDS IS WORKING TO CONTROL
INVASIVE SPECIES SUCH AS FRENCH
BROOM, SLENDER FALSE BROME AND
YELLOW STAR THISTLE. THESE
SPECIES AND OTHERS ARE KNOWN TO
CAUSE GREAT ECOLOGICAL AND
ECONOMICAL DAMAGE. IN 2014,
MIDPEN BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ADOPTED AN IPM PROGRAM WITH THE
GOALS OF MANAGING PESTS THROUGH
CONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION OF IPM
PRINCIPLES, PROTECTING AND
RESTORING THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT, AND PROVIDING FOR
HUMAN SAFETY AND ENJOYMENT WHILE
VISITING AND WORKING IN MIDPEN
LANDS. OUR IPM PROGRAM FOCUSES
ON THE MANAGEMENT OF INVASIVE
PLANTS AND PROTECTION OF NATIVE
BIODIVERSITY THROUGH THE
PREFERENTIAL USE OF NON-CHEMICAL
METHODS. WHENEVER POSSIBLE,
RESERVING THE ABILITY TO USE
CHEMICAL METHODS ONLY WHEN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. SHARED
LANGUAGE IS A SHARED VISION. AB
2509 ESTABLISHES A FIRM
FOUNDATION FOR ONGOING WORK TO
PROTECT THE STATE'S ENVIRONMENT
AND ECONOMY FROM INVASIVE
SPECIES BY PROVIDING CLEAR
DEFINITIONS OF INVASIVE SPECIES
AND INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
IN STATUTE. CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVES AROUND PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY, INCLUDING 30 BY 30
THE NATURAL WORKING LANDS,
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY AND THE
STATE WILDLIFE ACTION PLAN, ALL
STRESSED THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
ADDRESSING INVASIVE SPECIES, AND
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP TO
CREATE A FIRM STATUTORY
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE
GUIDELINES. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN FURTHER ESTABLISHING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
INVASIVE SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CLARITY AND COMMITMENT OF IPM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME,
POSITION AND AFFILIATION. THANK
YOU. KIM. KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING, CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FOR THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT. ABIGAIL SMET FOR
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS. SENATOR STERN,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YEAH. I
REALLY APPLAUD YOU FOR BEING
ABLE TO PULL THIS TOGETHER A LOT
OF YEARS COMING, AND I THINK
THE, YOU KNOW, AT THE HIGH LEVEL
HERE, WE'RE GOING TO SEE BETTER
ECOLOGY BASED PRACTICES, BETTER
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS TO OUR
PROBLEMS, THAN IF THIS BILL
WEREN'T WEREN'T MOVING AND IT'S
HARD BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO STEP
IN AND, THIS ISN'T A BAND, BILL,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE SEEN, AT
LEAST IN PRACTICE, AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE UK'S EXPERTISE
HERE AS WELL. IS THE, YOU KNOW,
IS A WILLINGNESS TO, TO SORT OF
TO, TO START TO INNOVATE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT NEW
PRACTICES ARE COMING UP DAILY,
SO I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT WE MAY HAVE MORE DOLLARS
COMING FOR ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE MOVE A
WATER FIRE NATURE BOND HERE,
THIS COULD BE A VERY EXCITING
NEW ERA ERA FOR INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT. I DID WANT TO ASK. I
DON'T KNOW WHO, THE SPONSORS OR
THE SET, THE èC OR THE INVASIVE
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL. JUST A
SPECIFIC KIND OF INSTANCE THAT
I'M PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN,
WHEN IT COMES TO CERTAIN PESTS,
MOSQUITOES IN PARTICULAR, I
DON'T KNOW, WHO MIGHT BE ABLE TO
COMMENT AMONGST YOU, BUT, IF
IT'S ALL RIGHT, MADAM CHAIR,
WITH THE AUTHOR JUST IN TERMS OF
HOW IPM WOULD LOOK IN CERTAIN
VECTOR CONTROL AREAS. SO, YOU
KNOW, THE OBVIOUS ONES WE KNOW
ABOUT ARE, YOU KNOW, CERTAIN
INVASIVE SPECIES, YOU KNOW,
RATS, WHATEVER. LIKE, THOSE ARE
THE BIG MAINSTREAM ONES. BUT
ALSO WE HAVE VECTOR CONTROL
DISTRICTS THAT DEAL WITH
MOSQUITO MANAGEMENT. AND OFTEN
THE ANSWER HAS BEEN, SPRAYING OR
WATER MANAGEMENT AS THE SORT OF
MAIN SOLUTIONS. BUT WHAT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN IS THE LOSS OF THESE
BIOLOGICAL CONTROLS, BATS AND
DRAGONFLIES EAT MOSQUITO LARVAE
AND THEY EAT A LOT OF THEM. BUT
THE CRAYFISH HAVE BEEN COMING IN
AND EATING UP ALL THE DRAGONFLY
LARVAE, AND WE DON'T HAVE UNDER,
YOU KNOW, IN OUR, IN OUR, URBAN
LANDSCAPES WHERE WE'RE SEEING
NOW DENGUE AND WEST NILE VIRUS
POPPING UP. WE DON'T THE BAT
POPULATION HAS ALSO BEEN
DIMINISHED. SO JUST AT A HIGH
LEVEL ARE THOSE KINDS OF,
BIOLOGICAL CONTROLS TO SAY,
REMOVE CRAYFISH SO THE DRAGONFLY
SPECIES CAN COME BACK AND GO AT
THE MOSQUITOES OR, OR, YOU KNOW,
BAT BOXES AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
STARTING TO BRING THEM BACK SO
WE CAN START, ESPECIALLY IN
THESE AREAS WHERE THERE'S SORT
OF HIGH RISK OF VECTOR CONTROL.
BUT LIMITED ABILITY IN VERY
HIGHLY DENSIFIED URBAN
LANDSCAPES TO GO SPRAY, AND, YOU
KNOW, DOES THAT IS THAT THE KIND
OF THING THAT IPM COULD ADDRESS
POTENTIALLY. YEAH. YEAH. SO I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU MENTIONED NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS, BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IS THE AREA OF INNOVATION.
OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS ON
INVASIVE PLANTS PRIMARILY, SO
I'M NOT VERY FAMILIAR WITH
MOSQUITO VECTOR CONTROL, BUT THE
IDEA OF BIOLOGICAL CONTROLS IS
DEFINITELY AN IMPORTANT ONE. IT
CAN BE VERY EXPENSIVE FOR THE
USDA. WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONE OF
THE FEW QUARANTINE LABS IN
ALBANY, CALIFORNIA, WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI TO RESEARCH BIO
CONTROLS AND FOR INSTANCE, FOR
INVASIVE PLANTS. THEY'RE
RESEARCHING BIO CONTROLS THAT
CAN CONTROL AQUATIC PLANTS IN
THE DELTA, SO I THINK THOSE KIND
OF SOLUTIONS, THE BEAVER BILL
WAS MENTIONED, USING NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS IS REALLY AN
AREA OF INNOVATION FOR SURE.
GREAT. WELL, LOOK OUT FOR WE GOT
A BAT SPILL AND A DRAGONFLY
SPILL TOO. SO EXCELLENT. BUT
IT'LL ALL WORK UNDER THIS
FRAMEWORK. THAT'S WHAT I'M
EXCITED ABOUT, IS THAT YOU BUILT
AN UMBRELLA HERE THAT WE CAN ALL
HOPEFULLY NEST UNDER, AND
ANYWAY, I APPRECIATE IT. HAPPY
TO, MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY. THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M JUST HAPPY
THAT SOMEONE ELSE IS AS EXCITED
ABOUT INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
AS I AM RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR.
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU, WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. YES, A
MOTION FROM SENATOR STERN, FOR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, THE MOTION AB
2509, THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR. MIN A
MIN. I SEE ALLEN DELHI. EGGMAN.
SENATOR EGGMAN, THIS IS AB 2509
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. I,
SENATOR EGGMAN, I GROVE GROVE I
HURTADO. LAIRD. LAIRD I LIMÓN
LIMÓN I PADILLA. STERN, STERN I,
THE VOTE COUNT ON THAT IS SIX
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL, DO
WE HAVE ANY AUTHORS IN THE ROOM?
WE HAD A FEW AUTHORS I KNOW
COMING IN AND OUT. BRIAN WAS
HERE, APPARENTLY, THIS IS NOT
THE PARTY. I GUESS. NOT THE
PLACE TO BE. OKAY WELL, I THINK
WE GOT TEXT FROM ADDISON.
FRIEDMAN AND BRIAN WAS JUST
HERE. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT. AND I
SAW ALVAREZ ON THE WAY OUT. IF
WE'RE RECORDING AUTHORS. BUT I
WILL TAKE A BRIEF. WE'LL TAKE A
BRIEF RECESS, THEN, WHILE WE
WAIT FOR OUR NEXT AUTHOR.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE BACK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE, HERE TO PRESENT TWO
BILLS. FIVE ITEMS, SIX AND
SEVEN. WE'LL START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 1889,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU ARE FREE TO
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AB 1889 REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER AND
MINIMIZE IMPACTS TO WILDLIFE
MOVEMENT AND HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY AS PART OF THE
CONSERVATION ELEMENT OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN, IN CONSULTATION
WITH STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES,
STARTING WITH THE NEXT GENERAL
PLAN UPDATE AFTER JANUARY 1ST,
2028, YOU ALL KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF OUR RICHEST
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS IN THE
NATION, AND HOW IMPORTANT THAT
PRESERVATION OF THAT WILDLIFE
IS. WE ALSO KNOW THAT HAVING
WILDLIFE ENCOUNTER HUMANS IS
OFTEN DANGEROUS FOR BOTH THE
HUMANS AND THE WILDLIFE. I
REPRESENT PART OF THE PART OF
LOS ANGELES WHERE WE HAD BEARS
AIRLIFTED OUT OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE CERTAINLY HAVE
WILDLIFE LIKE COYOTES CONSTANTLY
INTERACTING WITH PEOPLE. IT'S A
REAL CONCERN FOR A LOT OF OUR
OUR RESIDENTS AND THEIR PETS.
AND IN ADDITION, WE SEE MULTIPLE
COLLISIONS WITH WILDLIFE ON OUR
HIGHWAYS. JUST I THINK A WEEK
AND A HALF AGO, ANOTHER BIG CAT
WAS KILLED ON THE 101 FREEWAY.
THIS LEADS TO A REALLY DANGEROUS
SITUATION FOR HUMAN DRIVERS, AND
IT'S ALSO DEVASTATING FOR
MIGRATING ANIMALS. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES FUNDAMENTALLY IS IT
TELLS COMMUNITIES IF YOU HAVE
MIGRATING ANIMALS IN YOUR IN
YOUR AREA AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PLANNING FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT,
PLAN FOR A WAY FOR THAT WILDLIFE
TO MAYBE GET THROUGH THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WITHOUT
ENCOUNTERING PEOPLE. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
PRODUCTIVE AND HELPFUL TO
DEVELOPERS, BECAUSE THE LAST
THING YOU WANT AS A DEVELOPER IS
TO THINK YOU CAN DEVELOP THIS
BIG PIECE OF LAND, AND THE WAY
THAT YOU WANT, AND TO HAVE
SOMEONE HIT YOU WITH AN EIR
ABOUT MIGRATING ANIMALS AND HAVE
TO REDESIGN. THIS DOES NOT STOP
DEVELOPMENT. IT JUST MAY SAY IN
A CERTAIN CASE, HEY, WHY DON'T
YOU PUT A FENCE HERE OR PUT A
CANAL? IT MAKES THOSE
SUGGESTIONS GOING IN, OR EVEN
PLANS FOR A CORRIDOR THROUGH AN
EXISTING COMMUNITY SO THAT YOU
CAN NOW HAVE UNHINDERED
DEVELOPMENT AROUND THAT. SO
NOTHING IN THIS BILL IS MEANT TO
STOP DEVELOPMENT. IT'S ACTUALLY
MEANT TO DO THAT LEGWORK UP
FRONT TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
BUILDERS LATER ON, IT ALSO GIVES
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE HELP TO
DO THIS PLANNING, BECAUSE THEY
DO NOW HAVE STATE AGENCIES
AVAILABLE TO THEM. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1889 IS FORMER
VENTURA COUNTY SUPERVISOR LINDA
PARKS. ANN-MARIE GALLOWAY,
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH
WILDLANDS NETWORK. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
AM PROUD TO SAY, AND I WOULD
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. CHAIRMAN, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, IT'S DELIGHTFUL TO BE
HERE TODAY. AND THANK YOU TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
THIS BILL. I'M LINDA PARKS,
FORMER VENTURA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. AND DURING THE TIME
I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, WE DID ADOPT AND
IMPLEMENT VENTURA COUNTY'S
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR ORDINANCE. AND
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT AB
1889 IS NEEDED AND VERY
FEASIBLE, LIKE VENTURA COUNTY'S
ORDINANCE AB 1889 DOESN'T STOP
DEVELOPMENT. RATHER, IT CALLS
FOR WILDLIFE FRIENDLY FENCING,
LIGHTING, LANDSCAPING, DON'T
PLANT INVASIVE PLANTS AND WHERE
FEASIBLE, CLUSTER DEVELOPMENT
PLANNERS CAN USE EXISTING
RESOURCES LIKE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S HABITAT CONNECTIVITY
DATA AND DEVELOPERS WILL KNOW
EARLY IN THE PROCESS WHAT'S
EXPECTED OF THEM. THIS WILL
MINIMIZE THE NEED FOR COSTLY
PROJECT CHANGES LATER IN THE
PROCESS, AND IT SAVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND DEVELOPERS TIME
AND MONEY HAVING FOUNDATIONAL
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION. ALL
TOGETHER IN ONE PLACE IN THE IN
THE CONSERVATION ELEMENT OF THE
GENERAL PLAN IS BOTH EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT. IMPORTANTLY, THE
ROOM TO ROAM ACT WILL AVOID THE
UNNECESSARY EXTINCTION OF SOME
OF OUR MOST ICONIC WILDLIFE
SPECIES, INCLUDING MOUNTAIN
LIONS. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE ALSO, AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
PASSING FUNDS FOR WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS AND BECAUSE OF INTER
COUNTY'S WILDLIFE CORRIDOR
ORDINANCE. WILDLIFE USING THOSE
CROSSINGS WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
OPEN SPACE ON THE OTHER SIDE
WHEN THEY REACH THE OTHER SIDE,
LIKE WITH THE WALLIS ANNENBERG
BRIDGE THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
BUILT IN AGOURA, WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS ARE CRITICAL FOR
SURVIVAL OF WILDLIFE, AND
SOMETHING AB 1889 CAN
ECONOMICALLY ACCOMPLISH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TO GIVE WILDLIFE ROOM TO ROAM.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, NEXT
WITNESS. YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB 1889, THE
ROOM TO ROAM ACT. MY NAME IS
MARY GALLOWAY, AND I DIRECT
WILDLANDS NETWORKS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM, WHERE I COLLABORATE
WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
THE STATE TO PROMOTE WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY. AB 1889 IS
CRITICAL TO PROMOTE LOCAL
PLANNING TO PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S BIODIVERSITY.
THOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS MANY
PROTECTED AREAS, WE'RE LEARNING
THAT WILDLIFE STILL NEED ROOM TO
ROAM BETWEEN THESE AREAS TO FIND
FOOD, SHELTER, UNRELATED MATES
AND ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
BOTH THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL
ON CLIMATE CHANGE, AS WELL AS
STATE AND FEDERAL 30 BY 30
INITIATIVES, RECOGNIZED THAT
PRESERVING AND RECONNECTING
FRAGMENTED HABITATS IS A
FOUNDATIONAL STRATEGY TO COMBAT
THE CLIMATE AND BIODIVERSITY
CRISIS. IN ADDITION, IN
ADDITION, AB 1889 FACILITATES
LONG TERM PLANNING FOR
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS THAT
MINIMIZE CONFLICTS WITH WILDLIFE
. CURRENT POLICY DEFERS
CONSIDERATION OF WILDLIFE
MOVEMENT UNTIL THE END OF THE
PROCESS, UNNECESSARILY SETTING
UP CONFLICTS AND EVEN LITIGATION
BETWEEN CITIES DEVELOPERS AND
COMMUNITIES. AB 1889 ALSO GIVES
CITIES TOOLS TO MAKE DEVELOPMENT
SAFER FOR WILDLIFE WHEN THEY ARE
NEAR CORRIDORS SUCH AS THE
WILDLIFE FRIENDLY FENCING,
LIGHTING AND CLUSTERING
DEVELOPMENT THAT LINDA
MENTIONED. BY CONSIDERING
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY EARLY,
DEVELOPERS CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS, LEADING TO SAFER
ENVIRONMENTS FOR BOTH HUMANS AND
WILDLIFE. AB 1889 IS FEASIBLE
WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS EXTENDING
THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE FROM
2026 TO 2028 AND REMOVING
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT A NEW
ELEMENT. THEIR GENERAL PLAN TO
EASE IMPLEMENTATION. FINALLY, AB
1889 ADVANCES EXISTING STATE
POLICIES. THE SAFE ROADS AND
WILDLIFE PROTECTION ACT REQUIRES
CALTRANS TO INCLUDE WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS WHERE APPROPRIATE, ON
NEW OR EXPANDED ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS. THIS POLICY WILL HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COORDINATE
WITH CALTRANS AND OTHER ENTITIES
TO ENSURE THAT PLANNING
CROSSINGS DON'T BECOME UNUSABLE.
I WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOR THEIR INVALUABLE
INVESTMENTS IN POLICIES TO
CONNECT CALIFORNIA'S LANDSCAPES
THROUGH PROTECTING WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AND BUILDING
CROSSINGS. PLEASE PROTECT AND
ENHANCE THE VALUES OF THESE
SUCCESSES, AND PLEASE VOTE AYE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF AB 1889. ME TOO. TESTIMONY.
NAME AFFILIATION, POSITION ON
THE MEASURE, JULIE ANDERSON,
WILDLIFE PROGRAM LEAD AT
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO,
NICHOLAS. SECOND, ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
AND COURTESY FOR ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, DOUG JOHNSON, CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KIM DELFINO,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY, CALIFORNIA TROUT
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE, SONOMA
LAND TRUST AND MOJAVE DESERT
LANDS TRUST IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LARA DIÆN STATE DIRECTOR
FOR ENVIRONMENT, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. JENNIFER
FEARING, ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MATTHEW BAKER, PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FOR THE WILDLANDS
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JOSH GALLAGHER, ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, GABRIELLA
FAZIO WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CELESTE WICKS WITH CLEAN
AIR FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT. ALSO IN
SUPPORT. NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
AND CA GRANDPARENTS ACTING
TOGETHER FACTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTION VOTERS. THANK YOU LISA
OWENS VIANEY. RAPTORS ARE THE
SOLUTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REBECCA GULLY,
CONSERVATION SCIENTIST AT UC
DAVIS IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JANET CHÁVEZ, A RESIDENT OF
DAVIS, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
? SO JUST YOU. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING. I'LL BE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES, AUDREY RATAJCZAK FROM
CRUZ STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US, WE WORKED
THROUGH THE LAST COMMITTEE, AND
THEN WE HAVE TWO FINAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE REQUESTING
ON ADDING THE WORD FEASIBLE OR
FEASIBILITY, IN THE BILL. AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY. SO WE JUST WANT
TO CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS TO
MAKE SURE IT MIRRORS THE GENERAL
PLAN ELEMENTS FROM THE OTHER
PARTS OF THAT CODE SECTION. SO
THANK YOU, ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION OR IN MAYBE A TWEENER
POSITION? SEEING NONE, I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS. DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, SENATOR GROVE, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. WE OBVIOUSLY NEED TO BUILD
HOUSING, AND WE ARE RUNNING INTO
THE SITUATION WHERE WE DO IN IN
YOU KNOW, ENCOUNTER WILDLIFE IN
MY DISTRICT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. WE'RE NOT
TELEPORTING, YOU KNOW, BEARS OUT
OF OUR COMMUNITY. BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE DO HAVE WOLVES THAT MIGRATE
DOWN THROUGH OUR RANCHING
COMMUNITY AND DURING CALVING
SEASON, THEY STAY FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME BECAUSE FOOD IS
PLENTIFUL. AS SOON AS A CALF
DROPS ON THE GROUND, THEY'LL EAT
IT, WHICH DESTROYS THE
LIVELIHOOD OF OUR RANCHING
FAMILIES, BUT ALSO THE LIFE OF
THE BABY CALF THAT WAS JUST
BORN. COWS DON'T USUALLY HAVE A
MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT
OFF, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN CHARGE
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT THE
WOLVES ARE PRETTY AGGRESSIVE. WE
ALSO PUT UP FENCING THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS OUR MOJAVE
DESERT TO, QUOTE UNQUOTE,
PROTECT THE TORTOISE. AND THE
TORTOISES CAN'T NAVIGATE THIS
FENCING. THEY TEND TO, YOU KNOW,
THEY ANIMALS MIGRATE FOR
BREEDING, FOR FOOD, FOR WATER,
BUT THEY CAN'T NAVIGATE THE
FENCING. SO THEY'LL LIKE PACE
BACK AND FORTH ON A HOT
PAVEMENT, AND THEN THEY'LL JUST
DIE BECAUSE THE HEAT HAS
ESCALATED. THERE'S SEVERAL
ARTICLES, USGS, NATURE
CONSERVANCY'S, MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THAT ARE
HIGHLIGHTING THE ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF DEATH HAPPENING TO
CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC TORTOISE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T NAVIGATE THE
FENCING AND THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO GET AROUND IT TO THE WATER
SOURCE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
ACCESSING FOR 30 PLUS YEARS, SO
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO. I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS, JUST PUT UP
A FENCE, THAT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY
FOR, YOU KNOW, ANIMALS TO
NAVIGATE. SOME OF THEM CAN, BUT
SOME OF THEM CAN'T. AND WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE REALITIES IN MY
DISTRICT THAT BILLS LIKE THIS
ARE, HURTING YOU KNOW, LIKE I
SAID, OUR CALVING INDUSTRY AND
THEN ALSO KILLING THE ICONIC
TORTOISE. SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY, BUT I, I SEE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING, WHERE YOU LIVE. I
WOULDN'T WANT BEARS, YOU KNOW,
COMING IN CONTACT WITH KIDS ON
THE STREET EITHER, IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED, BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS IS A SOLUTION. SO I
APOLOGIZE, BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR STERN JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD. I FEEL, A
LITTLE MELANCHOLY WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE I JUST I'M SO GRATEFUL
TO THIS AUTHOR AND YOUR
PERSISTENCE ON THESE AND SO MANY
OTHER ISSUES AND SO I'M LIKE,
WHO ELSE IS GOING TO BE THIS
CHAMPION WHEN YOU ARE GONE? BUT
FOR NOW, LET'S JUST GET AS MUCH
DONE AS WE POSSIBLY CAN. AND I
SO APPRECIATE, MY FORMER
SUPERVISOR FOR SHOWING UP HERE
TO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S IT WAS IT
WAS HARD FOUGHT TO FIGURE THAT
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR OUT THROUGH
VENTURA COUNTY. BUT PROOF'S IN
THE PUDDING. WE'VE BEEN MAKING
IT WORK, AND WE'RE STILL A MAJOR
AG PRODUCING REGION. YOU KNOW,
THE LEMONS AND THE AVOCADOS AND
TANGERINES ARE STILL MOVING. THE
FLOWERS ARE GROWING. WE'RE DOING
THE WORK, BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND THAT COEXISTENCE. SO
ANYWAY, I LOVE TO SIGN ON
COAUTHOR AND MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
AND NOW IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I THINK, UNLESS WE HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
OF COURSE. WE'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU
AS A COAUTHOR. AND JUST TO
RESPOND TO SENATOR GROVE, I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM, NOT TRYING TO
CONVINCE YOU ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER. I JUST DO WANT TO POINT
OUT, FOR ANYONE LISTENING, THE
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY NEW
PROGRAMS. IT DOES NO ENFORCEMENT
. IT DOESN'T REQUIRE ANYONE TO
PUT A FENCE UP, AND ESPECIALLY
NOT A BAD FENCE, ESPECIALLY NOT
A FENCE THAT'S, YOU KNOW, DOING
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT IT WAS
ENTITLED EXPECTED TO DO. BUT IF
THAT FENCE IS A RESULT OF
SOMEBODY SUING, LET'S SAY OVER A
ROAD OR A DEVELOPMENT, THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
TRYING TO STOP WHAT THE BILL IS
SAYING IS COMMUNITY. IF YOU HAVE
MIGRATING ANIMALS AND YOU'RE
UPDATING YOUR GENERAL PLAN, AND
LET'S SAY YOU'RE PLANNING SOME
NEW DEVELOPMENT, THAT'S THE TIME
TO STUDY WHETHER OR NOT YOU
THINK YOU NEED THE WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR, WHATEVER YOU MIGHT
NEED FOR TO MAKE SURE THOSE
ANIMALS LATER ON DON'T END UP IN
A NEIGHBORHOOD, OR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEIGHBORS, FOR
INSTANCE, DON'T SUE THAT NEW
DEVELOPER SAYING, HEY, YOU'RE
NOT PROTECTING THE ANIMALS. DO
YOUR PLANNING. WHEN YOU DO THE
GENERAL PLAN TO SAY, HEY, WE'RE
ABOUT TO HAVE SOME NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS AREA. WE
KNOW WE HAVE DEER COMING
THROUGH. LET'S FIGURE OUT A PATH
FOR THOSE DEER SO THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP AROUND IT. THAT'S ALL
THE BILL IS TRYING TO DO. IT'S
NOT PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO, BUT WHAT
IT'S MAKING AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMUNITIES NOW IS SAYING, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE FISH AND WILDLIFE
NOW. CONSULT WITH YOU. SO SMALL
TOWN, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. WE'RE MAKING FISH AND
WILDLIFE AVAILABLE. THEY'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU SOME OPTIONS.
AND YOU GUYS JUST INCORPORATE
WHATEVER YOU DECIDED TO YOUR
GENERAL PLAN. SO NO ENFORCEMENT,
NOTHING PRESCRIPTIVE, NO FORCE
FENCING, JUST LET'S IN ADVANCE
OF BUILDING. LET'S PLAN FOR THE
ANIMALS THAT MIGHT BE THERE. SO
WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. AND THANKS AGAIN FOR
BRINGING UP THE CONCERNS. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FROM SENATOR STERN, FILE ITEM AB
OH SIX, AB 1889. ASSISTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR.
MIN. MIN AYE. SEYARTO ALLEN.
DALLY EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GROVE.
HURTADO LAIRD. LAIRD I LIMÓN.
LIMON I PADILLA. STERN I STERN I
, THAT VOTE COUNT IS FIVE ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL, AND
WE'RE GOING ON TO OUR NEXT BILL,
WHICH IS ALSO ASSEMBLYWOMAN
FRIEDMAN, IF I LET HIM SEVEN AB
2552. THANK YOU. WITH YOUR
PERMISSION, I'D LIKE TO BRING
SOME PHOTOS UP TO JUST BE PASSED
DOWN THE DAIS. PERMISSION OKAY.
YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
IS TAKING SOME PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE, WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL
REMOVE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY. EXPOSURE
TO ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES,
WHICH IS RAT POISON, A CERTAIN
TYPE OF RAT POISON CAN RESULT IN
BOTH LETHAL AND SUBLETHAL
EFFECTS ON NON-TARGET WILDLIFE,
INCLUDING SEVERE SKIN DISEASE
AND DECREASED IMMUNE SYSTEM
RESPONSE. THE PHOTOS THAT I'M
PASSING AROUND ARE DEAD ANIMALS
THAT HAVE BEEN POISONED BY
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES,
UNINTENTIONALLY, WHICH, BY THE
WAY, IS VERY COMMON IN A LOT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY IN
MINE, WHERE PEOPLE ALL THE TIME
ARE SHARING PHOTOS ON NEXTDOOR
AND OTHER APPS OF COYOTES THAT
LOOK LIKE THEY HAVE MANGE BUT
ARE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN POISONED
BY THIS ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE. THESE
ANTICOAGULANTS ALSO CONTINUE TO
RESULT IN UNREASONABLE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INCIDENTS, WITH
OVER 3000 HUMAN POISONINGS IN
2021 ALONE, AT LEAST 2300 OF
THESE INVOLVING CHILDREN UNDER
SIX YEARS, ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF POISON
CONTROL CENTERS. AB 2005 52 ADDS
THE TWO REMAINING FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES, KNOWN AS FCRS
CHLOROACETOPHENONE AND WARFARIN,
TO THE EXISTING RODENTICIDE
MORATORIUM TO BETTER PROTECT
WILDLIFE FROM UNINTENTIONAL
POISONINGS. WHILE MAINTAINING
EXEMPTIONS FOR ITS USE TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH WATER
SUPPLIES. AND I KNOW IMPORTANT
FOR MANY OF YOU AGRICULTURE. IT
ALSO REQUIRES THAT DPR, THAT
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ENACT STRONGER
PERMANENT RESTRICTIONS ON FCRS
TO LIMIT UNINTENDED WILDLIFE
POISONINGS WHILE MAKING
CHLOROACETOPHENONE AND WARFARIN
A RESTRICTED MATERIAL SO THAT
YOUR AVERAGE JOE CAN'T JUST BUY
THIS AT HOME DEPOT AND
UNINTENTIONALLY POISON THE
NEIGHBOR'S CATS AND YES, THE US
EPA IS UNDERGOING ITS PERIODIC
REVIEW OF RODENTICIDES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ALL KNOW HOW
SLOW AND BEHIND THAT PROCESS IS.
THIS IS ABOUT ACTION NOW AND NOT
LATER, BECAUSE THESE
RODENTICIDES ARE UNFORTUNATELY
PROVING TO BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
TO RODENT CONTROL BY POISONING
AND KILLING OUR NATURAL
PREDATORS, THE HAWKS, THE OWLS,
THE BOBCATS THAT WOULD NORMALLY
HELP TO REGULATE RODENT
POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND AS THE LA TIMES RECENTLY
HIGHLIGHTED IN THEIR VERY
SUPPORTIVE OP ED ABOUT THIS
BILL, A NEW MOUNTAIN LION WAS
JUST FOUND IN GRIFFITH PARK. WE
WELCOME HIM OR HER AND WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE THEM A
BETTER LIFE THAN THEIR
PREDECESSOR, P-22, WHO WAS VERY
FAMOUSLY PHOTOGRAPHED SUFFERING
FROM RODENTICIDE POISONING MUCH
TO THE DISMAY OF MOST OF LOS
ANGELES. THERE ARE WIDER AND
THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF SAFER
AND MORE SUSTAINABLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES TO THESE
MOST DANGEROUS RODENTICIDES
AVAILABLE FOR USE TODAY THAT
DON'T THREATEN CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE AND FAMILIES. NOW, I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY
CONFIRMING THAT SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD TODAY, WE WILL BE
MOVING THE 2500 SQUARE FOOT
BUFFER ZONE AS LAID OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, SO ALL
AGRICULTURE WILL NOW BE EXEMPT
FROM THE BILL, ALTHOUGH WE DO
BELIEVE WITH THE COMMITTEE, WE
DO AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT POINTS OUT THAT
THE BUFFER ZONE SHOULD BE SEEN
AS AN INTEGRAL COMPONENT TO THE
PROTECTION, CONSERVATION AND
MANAGEMENT OF A PROTECTED
WILDLIFE HABITAT. WE HAVE
DESIGNATED AREAS IN THE STATE AS
STATE WILDLIFE HABITAT ZONES,
AND YET WE ARE ALLOWING THIS
VERY TOXIC AND DEADLY MATERIAL
TO BE USED RIGHT UP TO THE
BORDER OF THAT ZONE, KNOWING
THAT THE POISON RODENTS ARE
GOING TO STUMBLE OUT INTO THE
FOREST AND POISON THE NON-TARGET
WILDLIFE WHEN THERE ARE OVER 100
NON RODENTICIDE NON
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES
AVAILABLE. AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING FOR A FUTURE
LEGISLATURE. I HOPE TO TAKE ON.
BUT FOR NOW WE WILL NOT BE
INCLUDING THOSE BUFFERS IN THE
BILL. TESTIFYING AND SUPPORT
THIS MORNING IS LISA OWENS
DIRECTOR OF RAPTORS OF SOLUTION
AND DOCTOR REBECCA GULLEY, A
SMITH FELLOW AND POSTDOC AT UC
DAVIS, AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WITH THIS
VERY HEAVILY AMENDED
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. TWO WITNESSES.
YOU EACH HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES.
YOU CAN START WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LISA OWENS, AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF BEHALF OF
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION. A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2552, I
FOUNDED THIS NONPROFIT IN 2011
WITH A RAPTOR BIOLOGIST AFTER A
FAMILY OF COOPER'S HAWKS BLED TO
DEATH ON THE STREET IN MY BAY
AREA NEIGHBORHOOD, MUCH TO THE
CHAGRIN OF LITTLE KIDS AND
FAMILIES AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE WATCHING THE HAWKS RAISE
THEIR BABIES, IT WAS VERY
TRAUMATIC. SINCE THAT TIME, MY
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
ANTICOAGULANTS AND ON BETTER
WAYS TO MORE SUSTAINABLY CONTROL
RODENTS. THE POISON POISONING OF
THIS FAMILY OF HAWKS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS HARDLY AN
ANOMALY. BIRDS OF PREY AND
NUMEROUS OTHER WILDLIFE HAVE
BEEN POISONED IN EVERY ALMOST
EVERY OTHER COUNTY IN THE STATE.
ANTICOAGULANTS HAVE A UNIQUE
MODE OF TOXICITY THAT MAKES THEM
PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS. THEY
BUILD UP IN AN ANIMAL'S BODY.
THEY BIOACCUMULATE IN UPPER
LEVEL PREDATORS LIKE HAWKS,
OWLS, MOUNTAIN LIONS, BOBCATS,
AND FOXES, AND THEY INFILTRATE
THE ENTIRE FOOD WEB FROM
EARTHWORMS TO EAGLES. WHEN ADDED
ON ONE ON TOP OF THE OTHER, THEY
HAVE EVEN MORE DEADLY IMPACT,
MUCH LIKE DDT DID IN THE 1950S.
LET'S NOT LET THIS BECOME OUR
NEW DDT. A MORE HUMANE AND
STRATEGIC PEST CONTROL CAN WORK
IN CONCERT WITH OUR WILDLIFE
PREDATORS, NOT AGAINST THEM. A
PILOT STUDY MY ORGANIZATION DID
IN SEATTLE IN 2022, USING
FERTILITY CONTROL, REDUCED RAT
NUMBERS BY OVER 90% IN JUST
THREE MONTHS. CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS NEW YORK,
BOSTON AND OTHERS ARE NOW USING
FERTILITY CONTROL, WHERE IT IS
PROVING HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING RAT NUMBERS. TODAY, WE
HAVE MANY PEST CONTROL COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA. I HAVE USED THEM
MYSELF, WHOSE BUSINESS MODEL
INVOLVES CONTROLLING RODENTS
WITH EXCLUSION AND SANITATION,
FINDING OUT WHERE RODENTS ARE
GETTING INTO BUILDINGS AND WHY
THEY ARE COMING TO A PROPERTY,
SEALING UP HOLES AND PREVENTING
REENTRY, AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT HOMES
AND BUSINESS OWNERS CAN DO TO
CLEAN UP THEIR PROPERTIES. TO
AVOID ATTRACTING RATS, RATHER
THAN JUST PUTTING OUT POISON
BAIT BOXES, WHICH ACTUALLY LURE
RATS INTO A PROPERTY, YOU'RE
INCREASING THE RAT POPULATION BY
USING THESE ANTICOAGULANT
POISONS. THESE COMPANIES ARE
PROVING THEY CAN DO A THRIVING
BUSINESS WITHOUT HARMING
NON-TARGET WILDLIFE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE TWO MINUTES AND
YOU CAN START WHENEVER YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR REBECCA GULLY. I'M A
CONSERVATION SCIENTIST
INVESTIGATING THE IMPACTS OF
RODENTICIDES IN CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE. NECROPSIES PERFORMED
BY CDFW IN 2023 SHOWED ONGOING,
WIDESPREAD WILDLIFE POISONING TO
ALL ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES.
OVER 73% OF WILDLIFE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANTS, AND OVER 57%
TESTED POSITIVE FOR FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS,
INCLUDING CLOFAZIMINE AND
WARFARIN. THE POISONS ADDRESSED
IN THIS BILL. THESE TWO
ANTICOAGULANTS ALONE HAVE BEEN
FOUND IN NUMEROUS CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE, INCLUDING BALD EAGLES,
BARN OWLS, BOBCATS, COYOTES,
GOLDEN EAGLES, GRAY FOXES, GREAT
HORNED OWLS, MOUNTAIN LIONS, RED
SHOULDERED HAWKS, RED TAILED
HAWKS, AND SAN JOAQUIN KIT FOXES
. RODENTICIDES ARE NONSELECTIVE
CHEMICALS THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO HARM ALL WILDLIFE.
WHEN THESE POISONS DON'T
DIRECTLY KILL INDIVIDUALS, THEY
MAKE THEM SICK AND WEAK.
SUBLETHAL DOSES OF
ANTICOAGULANTS HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH LOWER IMMUNE
FUNCTION, INCREASED PARASITE AND
PATHOGEN LOAD, LOWERED EGG
HATCHING, LOWERED FLEDGING
SUCCESS, REDUCED COORDINATION
CAN LEAD TO CHRONIC ANEMIA,
INCREASED STRESS HORMONE
PRODUCTION, AND WE NOW EVEN HAVE
EVIDENCE OF NEONATAL TRANSFER TO
YOUNG. THE USE OF ANTICOAGULANTS
ALSO POSE A PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN. IN A 2021 STUDY BY
MURRAY AND SANCHEZ, IT WAS FOUND
THAT POISONED RATS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO BE
INFECTED WITH LEPTOSPIRA THAN
NON POISONED RATS, AND THIS IS
WHEN IT SPILLS OVER TO HUMANS.
RODENT FERTILITY CONTROLS
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCES RODENT
POPULATIONS, BUT IT DOES NOT
DISRUPT THEIR IMMUNE SYSTEM LIKE
POISONS DO. FERTILITY PRODUCTS
SUCH AS CONTRAPEST AND EVOLV ARE
READILY AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ARE CATEGORIZED AS MINIMUM
RISK PESTICIDES THAT POSE LITTLE
RISK TO PEOPLE, PETS, AND
PREDATORS. THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES, AND OUR WILDLIFE
NEIGHBORS NEED OUR PROTECTION
NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2552 ME TWO
TESTIMONY. NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES,
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
ABIGAIL SMART, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
NICHOLAS HACKETT, ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION. AND TODAY, ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MARK FENSTERMAKER,
FOR THE WILDLANDS CONSERVANCY
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, KAREN
AMICONE, ON BEHALF OF VOICE FOR
CHOICE ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT,
GOOD MORNING, KYLE FARRAR AND,
REPRESENTING FRACTRACKER
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. HELLO, LARA
DIÆN, A STATE DIRECTOR FOR
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. CELESTE WICKS WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS AND SUPPORT. ALSO IN
SUPPORT ARE NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY,
PEEPS, NCCA GRANDPARENTS, ACTING
TOGETHER, FACTS BEYOND
PESTICIDES SONOMA SAFE AG SAFE
SCHOOLS. NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES.
YARD SMART MARIN MOMS ADVOCATING
SUSTAINABILITY ACTIVIST SAN
DIEGO AND CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS. THANK YOU.
JANET KROVOZA, RESIDENT OF DAVIS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KIM
DELFINO, ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE, MOJAVE DESERT LAND
TRUST AND AUDUBON CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JENNIFER
FEARING FOR SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DOUG JOHNSON, CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM, WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION,
JUST, YOU KNOW, THERE'S ANOTHER.
OH, THERE'S TWO OF YOU. A TWO
MINUTES EACH. AND YOU CAN
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY,
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TAYLOR OCEAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE RODENTICIDE TASK FORCE
AND A SERIES OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS AND OPPOSITION TO
2552, WE BELIEVE BECAUSE WE HAVE
ROBUST ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
FOR ILLEGAL SALE USE AND
POSSESSION OF PESTICIDES, WE
BELIEVE BELIEVE IMPOSING AN
ADDITIONAL CIVIL PENALTY AND
ALLOWING CITY ATTORNEYS, RATHER
THAN STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
TO ENFORCE THE LAW IS
UNNECESSARY. WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE REINSTATEMENT OF THE
AGRICULTURAL EXEMPTION, WE
OBJECT TO THE BILL AS AN
ABDICATION OF THE PROCESS IN
PLACE TO REGULATE PESTICIDES.
ALL PESTICIDES ARE AUTOMATICALLY
BANNED FOR USE IN CALIFORNIA
UNTIL THEY'RE REGISTERED BY US
EPA AND THEN AGAIN BY DPR, DPR
ANNUALLY REVIEWS AND RE
REGISTERS THESE PRODUCTS BASED
ON THEIR SAFETY, AND AT ANY TIME
IN THIS PROCESS, A PERSON CAN
BRING DATA TO DPR, AFTER WHICH
THEY ARE OBLIGATED TO ACT AND
RATHER THAN PRESENT A BILL THAT
REQUIRES DPR TO REVIEW THE
SCIENCE THEMSELF AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION. AB 2552 BANS THE
PRODUCTS OUTRIGHT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS JUST NOW
BROKERED A DEAL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, WITH FARMERS,
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES, WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND COMMERCIAL USERS TO
IMPOSE AN ADDITIONAL $40 MILLION
TAX ANNUALLY TO FUND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION TO DO THIS KIND OF
WORK. AND IN THAT NEGOTIATION,
THERE WAS NO CRITIQUE OF DPR
SCIENTIFIC PROCESS AND WHILE WE
BELIEVE OUR AGENCIES AND THAT
ARE NOW FULL OF SCIENTISTS, 40%
BUDGET RICHER, ARE BETTER SUITED
TO REVIEW THE SCIENCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE TO DO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO TOUCH ON THE ARGUMENT
THAT ALTERNATIVES EXIST. THE
NON-CHEMICAL APPROACHES
SUGGESTED BY THE SPONSOR, LIKE
RAT FERTILITY IN NEW YORK CITY,
HAS ACTUALLY BEEN STOPPED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE,
OTHER ALTERNATIVES, LIKE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF RAPTORS EXCLUSION
SANITATION STANDARDS ARE ALL
GREAT TOOLS, BUT THEY'RE A TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX AND IS NOT THE
PANACEA OF SOLUTIONS IPM
DICTATES. WE LOOK AT THE TOOLS
WE HAVE, THE CONDITIONS THAT WE
HAVE, AND THEN WE SELECT THE
RIGHT TOOL AT THE RIGHT TIME,
REMOVING TOOLS IS NOT IPM. WHILE
THE SPONSORS HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
ALTERNATIVES, WE DID THE
RESEARCH AND WE DON'T AGREE.
THERE ARE FOUR ACTIVE
RODENTICIDE INGREDIENTS
REGISTERED FOR USE IN CALIFORNIA
AND 69 PRODUCTS WHILE THEY'RE
REGISTERED. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR
USE IN SALE IN CALIFORNIA, AMONG
THOSE 69, 52 AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR
USE IN AGRICULTURE, 57 OF THE 69
AREN'T ELIGIBLE TO CONTROL FOR
GOPHERS, AND NONE OF THE 69
PRODUCTS WORK TO PROTECT
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES FROM
ALL FORMS OF. YES, OF COURSE, WE
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD STOP
REMOVING ACTIVE INGREDIENTS ONE
AT A TIME. AND FOR THAT REASON,
WE REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
NEXT WITNESS, YOU HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES, AND YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS AND CHAIR, MY NAME
IS BLAIR SMITH. I'M THE
TECHNICAL DIRECTOR WITH CLARK
PEST CONTROL AND PROUDLY
REPRESENTING THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA. TODAY,
I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU. AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
TO THE ORIGINAL BILL OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS. HOWEVER, I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS HOW THIS BILL
STILL POSES A RISK TO THE FOOD
SUPPLY OF CALIFORNIANS NOW,
PREVIOUS ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE BILLS AB 1788 AND
1322 ALLOWED FOR EXEMPTIONS IN
THE NAME OF FOOD SAFETY, WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON PRODUCTION
AGRICULTURE. THESE EXEMPTIONS
COVER THE FARM END OF THE FOOD
SUPPLY, BUT DO NOT REACH DOWN TO
THE FORK. MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS
PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS INVOLVED IN FOOD
HANDLING, PREPARATION AND
STORAGE, DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES, GROCERY STORES AND
RESTAURANTS ARE ALL NOT EXEMPT
UNDER PREVIOUS BILLS WOULD NOT
BE EXEMPT IN THIS CASE, WHICH
CONTINUES TO LEAVE OUR FOOD
SUPPLY AT RISK NOW. NON-CHEMICAL
METHODS VIA PHYSICAL EXCLUSION,
AS MENTIONED BY THE SUPPORT,
ARE, OF COURSE, THE SUPERIOR
MEANS OF CONTROL. IT CAN BE
UNATTAINABLE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
DUE TO THE HIGHER COST. AND I'LL
ALSO MENTION THAT OUR COMPANY IN
PARTICULAR HAS AN ESCALATION
PROCESS TO JUSTIFY THE USE OF A
RODENT. AN ACTIVE RODENTICIDE IN
THE BAIT STATION NOW LOSING
ADDITIONAL MATERIALS FOR RODENT
MANAGEMENT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS THOSE WHO CANNOT INVEST
IN STRUCTURAL SOLUTIONS, LEAVING
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AT RISK IN THE
PLACES WHERE THEY LIVE, WORK,
AND PLAY. ONE LAST NOTE IS THAT
THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF THIS
DISCUSSION OFTEN FOCUSES ON BOTH
RATS AND MICE, WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR CUSTOMERS FOR
BURROWING RODENTS SUCH AS
GOPHERS AND SQUIRRELS. AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THIS
BILL WILL BE THE INCREASED USE
OF MATERIALS THAT ARE LEFT,
WHICH ARE ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
RESTRICTED MATERIALS STRYCHNINE
AND ZINC PHOSPHIDE. SO WITH
THAT, I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM? ME TOO. TESTIMONY.
NAME, AFFILIATION, POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. DENNIS ALBIANI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA GRAIN
AND FEED CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATIONS, WE APPRECIATE THE
BUFFER LANGUAGE. EXCUSE ME.
WE'RE HAVING CALLS WITH OUR
CLIENTS RIGHT NOW TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT OUT. STILL, THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT PRECEDENCE ISSUE,
BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED, BUT CONTINGENT UPON THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE GOING INTO PRINT, WE
WOULD HOPE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MARGIE
LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS, JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF TRICIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, GEORGE, ON
BEHALF OF THE ALMOND ALLIANCE,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU,
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS, SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I I'M
GLAD. I'M GLAD YOU TOOK THE
AMENDMENT. I YOU KNOW, MY
DISTRICT IS A LOT OF AG, SO I
WILL, I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY,
BUT IF, IF THE OPPOSITION
DOESN'T COME OFF, THEN THEN I
MAY CHANGE MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS. BILL AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE OF,
PROTECTING ANIMALS, AS YOUR BILL
MAKES CLEAR, IS I THINK YOUR
PICTURE IS MADE CLEAR.
RODENTICIDES, PARTICULARLY THE
KINDS THAT YOUR BILL IS TRYING
TO ADDRESS, CAN HAVE HORRIFIC
IMPACTS ON NON-TARGET SPECIES,
SUCH AS OUR BELOVED MOUNTAIN
LIONS. AND I SUPPORT YOUR EFFORT
TO TRY TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE FROM THE HARMS
PRESENTED BY RODENTICIDES. AT
THE SAME TIME, I HAVE HAD DID
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL AND THE 2500 FOOT
BUFFER ZONES AND WHAT THAT MIGHT
MEAN FOR CALIFORNIA WRIT LARGE
AND WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MOVING WITH THE RIGHT BALANCE
TOWARDS PROTECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND SO, AS OUR ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT, THE PARTICULAR ISSUE
OF DETERMINING THE SCOPE OF
BUFFER ZONES AROUND WILDLIFE
HABITAT AREAS IS NOT SOMETHING
THE STATE HAS DONE YET. AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE INFORMED BY SCIENCE BASED
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS HERE AND
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD. WITH
THAT, I WILL BE VOTING AYE
TODAY, AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE.
THANK YOU. WELL, I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT, BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT I SAID IT IN MY
OPENING, THAT THIS IS A
MORATORIUM UNTIL THE REVIEW CAN
BE DONE BY OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES. IT'S ADDING TWO
PESTICIDES TO THE LIST OF
ANTI-COAGULANTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RESTRICTED. IT IS A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTING TO ME WHEN
WE HAVE REMOVED ALL AGRICULTURE
FROM THIS BILL, SO THAT THERE'S
NO MORE BUFFER ZONES, EVEN
THOUGH THEY, YOU KNOW, THESE
WERE BUFFER ZONES NEXT TO THE
SMALL AMOUNT OF WILDLIFE
HABITATS THAT WE HAD WHERE
AGRICULTURE BUTTED UP TO
WILDLIFE HABITATS. WE'VE REMOVED
THOSE BUFFER ZONES AND TO STILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES OF OPPOSITION
FROM GROUPS THAT ARE NO LONGER
AFFECTED BY THE BILL IS
DISAPPOINTING TO ME. I DO HOPE
THAT THEY'LL, YOU KNOW, REVIEW
THE AMENDMENTS AND REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION FORMALLY GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF THE HUGE CARE CUT THAT
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED IN THIS
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT, I
WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL? SO MOVED,
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR LEMON IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M SORRY TO. IS
THAT RIGHT TO APPROPRIATIONS?
CORRECT? I'M SORRY, SENATOR
DELLA, DO YOU HAVE A I. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MIN, A MIN. AYE. SEYARTO
ALLEN. DALLY A DALLY AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. LAIRD A.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE.
PADILLA. STERN THANK YOU. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN, THE VOTE COUNT IS
SIX ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL, WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS IN THE ROOM TO PRESENT HER
BILL. AND THAT IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 14 AND 15. I'M SORRY. 14,
AB 2537, YOU CAN PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. SHE WANTS
TO PRESENT 15. I'M GOOD WITH
THAT, WELL, THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF AND SUPPORTERS OF THIS
BILL. WE HAVE ALL SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL. SO IT'S GOOD NEWS. AS
I STAND HERE, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 2537, THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IN OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY ACT. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE NUMEROUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR
MONTHS IN AN EFFORT TO GET IT
RIGHT. AND I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AS YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA HAS ESTABLISHED
CRITICAL, CLEAN ENERGY GOALS,
AND OUR PROGRESS TOWARDS THESE
GOALS BENEFITS NOT ONLY HUMAN
COMMUNITIES, BUT FRAGILE,
FRAGILE ECOSYSTEMS AND VITAL
BIODIVERSITY ON THE LAND, IN THE
AIR AND IN THE OCEAN. AMONG
THESE GOALS IS THE REQUIREMENT
TO TRANSITION TO 100% RENEWABLE
AND ZERO CARBON ENERGY RESOURCES
BY 2045, WITH 25GW, OR ENOUGH
POWER FOR ABOUT 25 MILLION HOMES
COMING FROM OFFSHORE WIND.
ENERGY PLANNING FOR OFFSHORE
WIND ENERGY IS WELL UNDERWAY IN
CALIFORNIA, STARTING AS FAR BACK
AS 2016, AND LEASEHOLDERS ARE
CURRENTLY MOVING INTO THE
SURVEYING, PLANNING AND
PERMITTING STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT. AS OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY MOVES FORWARD IN WATERS
ALONG THE NORTH AND CENTRAL
COASTS. AND IN MY DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY, EXTENSIVE INPUT
FROM AN INTERNATIONAL
INTERACTION WITH LOCAL TRIBES
AND COMMUNITIES AS NEEDED. WE
KNOW THAT HISTORICALLY,
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HOSTED
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
WERE BURDENED WITH HARMFUL
IMPACTS, AND TODAY WE ALL LOOK
TO DO BETTER. I HAVE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM LOCAL COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS SMALL TRIBES AND CITIES,
THAT THERE IS A GAP IN RESOURCES
PREVENTING THEM FROM ADEQUATELY
PARTICIPATING IN OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY PLANNING AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY BENEFITS
CONVERSATIONS. AND AS WE ALL
KNOW, TRUE ENGAGEMENT IN NEW
TOPICS OFTEN NECESSITATES
POSSESSING IN DEPTH KNOWLEDGE,
INFORMATION, AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE. SO, AB 2537, THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY ACT CREATES
A SOLUTION BY ESTABLISHING AN
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY COMMUNITY
CAPACITY FUNDING GRANT ACCOUNT
THAT WILL PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL TRIBES AND COMMUNITIES.
THESE GRANTS WILL ENHANCE THE
ABILITY TO ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE
IN THE PLANNING PROCESSES, SO
THAT LOCAL TRIBES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE SECURE IN
THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD AND TO COME TO FAIR
AGREEMENTS WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS ALEXIS SUDERMAN FROM
BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE. THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M ALEXIS SUDERMAN
WITH BRIGHTLINE DEFENSE. WE'RE
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT, AND WE SEE OFFSHORE
WIND AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
SUPPORT A CLEANER, HEALTHIER AND
MORE RELIABLE GRID AND
IMPORTANTLY, TO LIFT THE
POLLUTION BURDEN OFF OF LOW
INCOME AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. IN OUR WORK, WE
HAVE HEARD DIRECTLY FROM
COMMUNITY AND TRIBAL LEADERS
LIVING NEAR PROPOSED OFFSHORE
WIND PROJECTS THAT THEY ARE
CURIOUS, EXCITED AND INTERESTED
IN SUPPORTING AND SHAPING
DEVELOPMENT, BUT ALSO THAT THEY
LACK THE RESOURCES AND THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO
MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE. THIS IS A
HUGE PROBLEM THAT ENERGY
COMMISSIONS. 5 TO 5 OFFSHORE
WIND STRATEGIC PLAN HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THAT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WILL BE CRITICAL FOR
THE SUCCESS OF OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT. ABSENT HAVING
RESOURCES FOR MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT, CALIFORNIA RUNS THE
RISK OF ENCOUNTERING PROJECT OR
ENCOUNTERING ISSUES, DELAYS OR
OTHERWISE IRRESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT WITH OFFSHORE WIND
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS THIS, AB
2537 WOULD UNLOCK MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND TRIBES TO MEANINGFULLY
ENGAGE IN OFFSHORE WIND PROJECT
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. FOR
EXAMPLE, A COMMUNITY MEMBER
COULD USE THESE RESOURCES TO
ATTEND A WORKSHOP OR A MEETING,
RESPOND TO A TECHNICAL COMMENT,
OPPORTUNITY, AND PARTICIPATE IN
KEY DECISION MAKING PROCESSES
AND VENUES. THIS FUNDING WOULD
COME FROM A FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTION FROM CALIFORNIA
OFFSHORE WIND LEASE HOLDERS FOR
THREE YEARS. AFTER THE LEASES
ARE SIGNED. IT'S WORTH NOTING
THAT LEASE LEASEHOLDERS
THEMSELVES ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS REQUIRED CONTRIBUTION,
WHICH REFLECTS HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO HAVE A COMMUNITY LED AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCED PROCESS FOR
THE SUCCESS OF OFFSHORE WIND. IN
SOME, AB 25, 37 WOULD WOULD PUT
CALIFORNIA A MAJOR STEP AHEAD ON
EQUITABLE AND JUST CLEAN ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT. THEREFORE, WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO WELCOME, ANY OPPOSITION
I'M SORRY. ANY ANY FOLKS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AND POSITION. YES. THANK
YOU. VICTORIA ROEHM WITH NRDC IN
SUPPORT. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. EXCUSE ME.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
ERIC O'DONNELL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF MORRO BAY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JENNIFER FEARING FROM
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM. THANK YOU
. LARA DIÆN, STATE DIRECTOR FOR
ENVIRONMENT, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MICHELLE
CANELA, UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, KIM DELFINO FOR AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, JORDAN CURLEY, ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, BRIAN WHITE FOR OFFSHORE
WIND, CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SUSAN
JORDAN, CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, GABRIELLA FAZIO WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO LEAD
WITNESSES ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LAIRD. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
DALLI, I JUST WANT TO GO ON
RECORD. I MET WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE ELEVATOR THIS MORNING, AND I
SAW THE BILL YESTERDAY AND
ENERGY. BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT THAT, I THINK WE'RE
REALLY GOING DOWN THE WRONG PATH
ON JUST MARCHING FORWARD WITH
OFFSHORE WIND IN CALIFORNIA,
SAYING, HEY, WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS. THIS IS NOT BEEN LED BY
PRIVATE INDUSTRY. IT'S BEEN LED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
IT'S GOING TO DRIVE UP RATES. I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MAJOR
IMPACTS AT NORTH AT THE HUMBOLDT
BAY AND IN SAN DIEGO, AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIREMENTS.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK AT, OVER
2500, WINDMILLS ON OUR OCEAN.
AND IT'S GOT THE CONTINENTAL
SHELF. IT'S DEEP. IT'S NOT LIKE,
THE EAST COAST WHERE WE HAVE WE
CAN TETHER THEM REAL EASY. SO I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
THIS BILL BASICALLY SAYS WE'RE
GOING TO PAY TO GET THE
COMMUNITY INVOLVED SO THAT
THEY'RE INVOLVED, WHICH IS NOT
HOW WE NORMALLY DO IT. NORMALLY
IT WOULD BE SOMEBODY WOULD COME
FORWARD WITH A PROJECT. PEOPLE
WOULD OPPOSE IT. IF YOU CAN'T
MITIGATE YOU, THEN THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE SEQUA. SO THIS IS JUST AN
AWKWARD PROCESS. I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE MEMBER IS TRYING TO DO,
TRYING TO GET MAKE SURE THAT
THESE, CONFLICTS ARE DEALT WITH
AND ESPECIALLY FROM HER
COMMUNITY. SHE TOLD ME THIS
MORNING SHE HAS 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S SHORELINE. AND I
WOULD BE WORRIED, TOO, IF I WAS
ON THE SHORELINE. YOU'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT WINDMILLS OUT
THERE, AND THERE'S GOING TO BE
LOTS OF LINES GOING THROUGH THE
WATER, AND I THINK IT'S REALLY A
WRONG APPROACH. SO I'M
PHILOSOPHICALLY OPPOSED TO JUST
MARCHING FORWARD WITH OFFSHORE
WIND. AND WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR
IT AT THE END OF THE DAY WILL BE
RATEPAYERS. THE CALIFORNIA
RATEPAYERS WILL PAY AT THE END
OF THE DAY. AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL FOR OFFSHORE WIND UNTIL WE
HAVE A BETTER PLAN. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR GROVE, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I SOMEWHAT,
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE IN HIS
COMMENTS THAT HE'S MADE, AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU REPRESENTING
THIS PORTION OF THE STATE, YOU
WOULD DEFINITELY WANT, YOU KNOW,
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, TRIBAL COMMUNITIES,
POORER PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PROCESS IN WHICH
IT IS. I WISH THIS BILL WAS IN
PLACE WHEN WE HAD HIGH SPEED
RAIL, WHERE THEY JUST RAN OVER
OUR SMALL FARMERS. AND THIS
MAJOR, HUGE MULTI-TON PROJECT
BEING BUILT ON A SINKING VALLEY
WHERE WE HAVE SEQUA NOW AND WE
CAN'T WITHDRAW WATER FROM THE
BASIN BECAUSE THE VALLEY
SINKING. BUT YET WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD THIS MONSTROSITY ON IT AT
THE EXPENSE OF TAXPAYERS, AND
IT'S A BUILT ON THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IS BUILT
ON A SINKING VALLEY. I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A FEDERAL AND A STATE
PROJECT, AND EVERYBODY'S GOING
OVER AND AFTER OFFSHORE WIND,
BUT THIS IS ANOTHER HUGE MEGA
PROJECT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE TAKING
ON. AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN FINISHED
ONE PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY YET THAT HAS GONE WELL
PAST WHAT WAS PROMISED ON THE
BALLOT MEASURE. SO I AGREE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE THAT IT'S KIND OF
BACKWARDS BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
NORMALLY A PROJECT WE BROUGHT
FORTH AND PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE, BUT
I AGREE WITH THE CONCEPT OF YOUR
BILL, SO I'M KIND OF STRUGGLING
BECAUSE I AGREE, I DISAGREE WITH
THE PROJECT, AND I DISAGREE WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON, AND I DISAGREE
THAT WE CONTINUALLY BITE OFF
MORE THAN WE CAN CHEW WHEN WE
HAVE ECONOMICALLY SOUND ENERGY.
WE COULD GET RIGHT HERE INSTEAD
OF IMPORTING IT AND BUILDING
THESE HORRIFIC PROJECTS. BUT,
BUT I AGREE WITH YOUR BILL THAT,
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE
A SEAT AT THE TABLE. EVERYBODY,
NOT JUST LABOR, NOT JUST WEALTHY
PEOPLE, BUT EVERYBODY SHOULD
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE. BUT I
FUNDAMENTALLY AGREE WITH THE
ENTIRE PROJECT, AND I HOPE THAT
WE COME TO OUR SENSES BEFORE
THEN. SO I'M GOING TO LAY OFF
YOUR BILL. AND, YOU KNOW, BUT I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR LAIRD, DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT? YES NOW THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY HAVING A DISCUSSION ON
THE BILL, I THOUGHT I WOULD JOIN
IT. AND, SINCE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARDIS SAID THAT SHE REPRESENTS
20% OF THE COAST, SHE IS FULLY
NESTED IN MY SENATE DISTRICT. SO
I CLEARLY REPRESENT 20% PLUS OF
THE COAST IN SOME WAY. AND ALL
THE COMMUNITIES THAT SHE WAS
REPRESENTING. AND IT WAS SAID
THAT THAT IT'S TOO BAD PRIVATE
INDUSTRY ISN'T LEADING, BUT
PRIVATE INDUSTRY CAN'T LEAD
UNDER OUR SYSTEM BY ITSELF. IT
IS A FEDERAL LEASE. THERE ARE
PUBLIC PORTS AND WE HAVE TO
INTERVENE TO STITCH THEM ALL
TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS WORK. AND
I WOULD REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE
ADOPTED AB 525 IN 2021 THAT
PRIORITIZED OFFSHORE WIND, AND
THAT IF, IN FACT, WE ARE GOING
TO PHASE OUT SOME OTHER THINGS
IN FACT, WE'RE GOING TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. THIS IS INTEGRAL
TO IT, AND THIS HAS TO HAPPEN.
AND IT IS UNIQUE BECAUSE SOME OF
THE COMMUNITIES AND THE
COMMUNITY THAT THE AUTHOR IS
FROM. I DID A TOWN HALL MEETING
WITH 150 PEOPLE IN HER COMMUNITY
IN OFFSHORE WIND, AND IT
REMINDED ME OF BEING MAYOR OF
SANTA CRUZ AND HAVING
TUMULTUOUS, HEARINGS. AND SO
THERE IS NOT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE FOR THE COMMUNITIES TO,
IN FACT, ENGAGE IN A WAY,
BECAUSE THE LEASES HAVE BEEN
DONE, THE LESSEES HAVE BEEN
DECIDED. THE PORT DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE, AND THEY'RE SO
COMPLEX THAT THE COMMUNITIES
NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS IN A
WAY THAT IS MEANINGFUL AND WHAT
IS REALLY HAPPENING HERE IS
TAKING. AND I HAD A MOMENT IN
THAT HEARING, WHERE WHERE I WAS
INTERRUPTED BY A MEMBER OF THE
AUDIENCE BECAUSE I WAS POINTING
OUT, CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE NEED
FOR DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO,
AND SOMEBODY SHOUTS THAT THE
FIRE THAT WAS TO THE NORTH IN
BIG SUR WAS STARTED BY ARSON.
THIS WAS IRRELEVANT. AND I HAD
TO ARGUE FOR WHY A FIRE
CONDITIONS ARE DIFFERENT IN
CLIMATE CHANGE NOW. WE ARE STILL
ARGUING THOSE THINGS AT THE
GRASSROOTS LEVEL. SO THIS BILL
IS A GOOD DIRECTION IN TRYING TO
STITCH TOGETHER SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO DO, TO BE
READY AND TO MOVE AHEAD IN
OFFSHORE WIND. AND SO I WAS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT. AND, MR.
CHAIR, DO WE HAVE A MOTION? YES,
I MADE IT ALREADY. YEAH. YOU DID
MAKE THE MOTION. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT, I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO COAUTHOR THIS BILL AND
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL, LOOK, THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM IS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
HAPPENING FASTER AND MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVELY THAN WE HAD
ANTICIPATED. AND IF YOU'VE GOT
KIDS WHO WILL BE SOMEONE IN YOUR
LIFE. I'M SORRY, SENATOR, DID
YOU HAVE A COMMENT? NO. I SAID,
IN YOUR OPINION, NO. IN THE
OPINION OF SCIENTISTS, I THINK
IT'S WELL PROVEN. CLIMATE CHANGE
IS A REAL PHENOMENON, AND I HOPE
THAT'S NOT A MATTER OF DISPUTE
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO IS THAT YOU LOVE
WHO'S GOING TO BE ALIVE IN 2050,
20, 75, WE Ó IT BASED ON THE
SCIENCE, BASED ON THE UNANIMOUS
CONSENSUS VIEW OF SCIENTISTS TO
ACT WITH URGENCY, AND THAT MEANS
DECARBONIZING OUR ECONOMY. NOW
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY OF PROVIDING SUBSIDIES
FOR ENERGY. WE HAVE PROVIDED
PROBABLY BILLIONS, MAYBE
TRILLIONS IN INCENTIVES FOR OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT OVER THIS
COUNTRY'S HISTORY. I THINK A
SMALL THUMB ON THE SCALE HERE IN
FAVOR OF OFFSHORE WIND, WHICH IS
GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR MIX OF RENEWABLE ENERGIES,
IS IMPORTANT. WE KNOW THERE'S
CHALLENGES WITH TRANSMISSION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A COAUTHOR AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. WITH THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? WELL, I JUST WANT TO
THANK EACH OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WANT TO APPRECIATE
HOW MUCH EACH OF YOU CARES FOR
YOUR COMMUNITIES. IT'S APPARENT
TO ME EVERY TIME I COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
ROBUST DISCUSSION. HAPPY TO ADD
YOU AS A COAUTHOR. MR. CHAIR,
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIR. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATE, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY.
SENATOR. MIN. AYE. MIN AYE.
SATO. NO. CIARDO. NO. ALLEN
DALLY. NO. DALLY. NO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GROVE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LAIRD I. LOWMAN LOWMAN I
PADILLA. STERN I STERN I. KNOW
HE'S GOING TO EXPLAIN THAT. VOTE
COUNT IS FIVE TWO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO RIGHT NOW IS WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN UP THE CALL, AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE A RECESS, BECAUSE WE HAVE
THREE MORE BILLS TO BE
PRESENTED, MAYBE FOUR FOR BILLS
TO BE THREE BILLS TO BE
PRESENTED. BUT WE HAVE TO
ADJOURN RIGHT NOW. WE'LL PICK UP
AROUND 1:30 P.M, AND IT WILL BE
IN THIS ROOM. ALL RIGHT,
ASSISTANT, LET'S GO OVER THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, SO WE'LL OPEN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BACK UP.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY, SENATOR CIARDO. HI.
SIERRA. I ALLEN. EGGMAN. EGGMAN,
I HURTADO PADILLA. OKAY.
12345678. THAT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 828 BY ASSEMBLYMAN
CONNELLY. DO PASS THE MOTION IS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR TWO. SENATOR KADO. KADO NO.
ALLEN. EGGMAN HURTADO. PADILLA.
OKAY, SO NOW IS FOUR THREE, THAT
VOTE COUNT IS FOUR THREE. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB
1581 BY ASSEMBLYMAN KALRA. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. SENATOR. MIN
AYE. MIN I SATO. NO. SORRY, I NO
TO I OKAY. SENATOR SIERRA. AYE.
SENATOR. ALLEN SENATOR EGGMAN.
1581 CALL MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HURTADO. PADILLA OKAY, SEVEN.
THAT VOTE COUNT IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2509
BY ASSEMBLYMAN KALRA. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
SENATOR. CIERTO CIERTO. AYE.
ALLEN DALLI. DALLI. AYE. HURTADO
PADILLA. EIGHT ZERO. THAT VOTE
COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT
TO FILE ITEM SIX AB 1889 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL. THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO.
SENATOR. CIERTO. CIERTO NO.
ALLEN. DALLI. DALLI NO. HURTADO.
PADILLA SO NOW IS FIVE TWO. THAT
VOTE COUNT IS FIVE TWO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON
NEXT TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB 2552
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO. SENATOR KADO, NO.
KADO. NO. ALLEN HURTADO.
PADILLA. STERN SORRY. FRIEDMAN.
YES STERN. AYE OKAY. SEVEN ONE.
NOW VOKOUN IS SEVEN ONE. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON
NEXT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE,
AB 26 2060 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SORIA. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS. ALL
RIGHT. VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
SENATOR. MIN MIN AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO AYE. ALLEN EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. PADILLA. STERN
STERN. AYE YEAH. OKAY, THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO. NOW VOTE COUNT IS
EIGHT ZERO. WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2091 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. SENATOR SATO.
SATO. AYE. ALLEN. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
AYE. HURTADO. LIMÓN PADILLA.
STERN OKAY. NUMBER TEN. ALL
RIGHT. ONE. TWO. THREE. FOUR.
FIVE. SIX. THAT VOTE COUNT IS
SIX ZERO. LEAVE IT ON CALL.
WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT TO FILE ITEM
12 AB 2330 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO.
SENATOR. CIERTO. CIERTO AYE.
ALLEN. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
HURTADO LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. 678. THAT VOTE
COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 14. I'M
SORRY, WE DON'T NEED TO DO THAT.
WE JUST DID THAT. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 2827
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES, THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OKAY. NÓ. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
SENATOR KADO. AYE. SIERRA DE AYE
. ALLEN. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
HURTADO. PADILLA. EIGHT. THAT
VOTE COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. AND WITH THAT,
WE WILL TAKE A RECESS. AND WE
WILL RESUME HERE IN THIS SAME
ROOM AT 1:30 P.M.
OKAY, WE ARE
RESUMING. I GUESS I JUST NOTE AT
THIS POINT THAT THIS IS THE LAST
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE BILL HEARING OF
THIS SESSION. WE. IT'S POSSIBLE
WE MAY HAVE A CONCURRENCE
HEARING OR TWO IN AUGUST, BUT,
THIS WILL BE MY LAST, PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR BILLS AS
CHAIR. SO A LITTLE TEAR FROM ME,
BUT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES, THE ONES THAT ARE
HERE FOR BEING HERE, FOR THEIR
ROBUST DEBATE AND CONTRIBUTIONS,
AS WELL AS TO OUR CONSULTANTS,
SANDRA SANDERS, CATHERINE
BAXTER, PAUL JACOBS, WHO STEPPED
IN FOR GENEVIEVE MOORE WHILE
SHE'S ON MATERNITY LEAVE DOING
YEOMAN'S WORK HERE, CATHERINE
MOORE AS YOU ALL KNOW, THESE
PEOPLE, THEY'VE BEEN DOING
AMAZING WORK ON OUR BEHALF, ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE, FOR THE
MANY COMPETING INTERESTS THAT
COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. AND
I WANT TO THANK SANDRA FOR
MAKING SURE I ALWAYS KIND OF
USUALLY SAY THE RIGHT THINGS AND
GET THE MOTIONS CORRECT. I WANT
TO THANK THE SERGEANTS FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
THANK THE REPUBLICAN, THE
MINORITY CONSULTANT, TODD
MOFFATT, FOR HIS WORK HERE, AND
IT'S BEEN AMAZING. AND I'M
BLESSED TO HAVE, LIKE SO MANY
GREAT STAFFERS AND COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE, BUT WITH
THAT, LET'S MOVE TO OUR NEXT
BILLS. WE HAVE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ IN THE AUDIENCE. SO HE
HAS TWO BILLS, I BELIEVE, TO
PRESENT, AND WE WILL START WITH,
I THINK, THE SLIGHTLY MORE
CONTROVERSIAL ONE, AB 2565 ITEM
15. ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALVAREZ, YOU
CAN PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. I ALMOST SAID GOOD
MORNING. GOOD AFTERNOON, THANK
YOU, MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2560
TODAY. AND I GENUINELY SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT, AS I EXPECT THIS, TO BE
A GOOD DIALOG ON THIS, ON THIS
ISSUE TODAY. SO, I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
REALITY THAT UNCERTAIN OF WHAT
THE OUTCOME OF MY BILL WILL BE
HERE TODAY, AND I'M OKAY WITH
THAT. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE AS TO WHAT
CONCERNS THEY MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
WHAT OUR BILL MAY
UNINTENTIONALLY DO. OUR BILL IS
VERY SIMPLE. WE ARE HOPING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S COAST PARTICIPATES
IN SOLVING OUR HOUSING CRISIS,
AND THAT LAWS THAT MAKE SENSE
AND THAT HAVE WORKED IN PLACES
LIKE MY HOME IN SAN DIEGO, WHERE
WE ADOPTED SIMILAR POLICIES WHEN
I WAS STILL ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
AND TO THIS DAY HAVE PROVIDED,
AND PROVEN TO HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE COAST,
WHICH FOR THE MOST PART IN
CALIFORNIA IS QUITE EXCLUSIVE TO
THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD A VERY,
VERY EXPENSIVE HOMES AND USUALLY
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. SO THAT IS
MY INTENT. AND SO I HOPE THAT
THROUGH YOUR QUESTIONS THAT I
EXPECT AND I HOPE TO HEAR FROM
YOU, WE CAN HAVE MORE OF A
DIALOG ABOUT HOW WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE ACHIEVE THAT GOAL OF
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OUR COAST. WHILE CERTAINLY
PRIORITIZING COASTAL RESOURCES
AND ACCESS. AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO ME. I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT GETS LOST
IN THIS CONVERSATION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IN WHAT SOME
FOLKS SAY, IS I'M A SAN DIEGAN,
BORN AND RAISED, OBVIOUSLY A
CALIFORNIAN, AND I'LL JUST TELL
YOU, ACCESS TO THE COAST HAS NOT
BEEN SOMETHING I HAD BEEN, ABLE
TO ENJOY GROWING UP IN A VERY
POOR PART OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
COMMUNITY OF BARRIO LOGAN, WHERE
OUR COAST ACCESS IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE BAY. BUT IT'S BEEN,
COMPLETELY TAKEN OVER BY
MARITIME INDUSTRIAL USES. SO
ACCESS TO THE BAY IS VERY
LIMITED. IT TOOK A LAWSUIT IN
ORDER TO GET ACCESS TO THE BAY
THROUGH A ONE ACRE PARK KNOWN AS
CESAR CHAVEZ PARK. TODAY, IN THE
1980S, I ACTUALLY NEVER WENT.
I'M A SAN DIEGAN. I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO SWIM, I ACTUALLY DIDN'T
GO TO THE BEACH FOR THE FIRST
TIME UNTIL I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BECAUSE, ACCESS TO THE BAY, EVEN
FOR, FOR POOR FAMILIES IN SAN
DIEGO CAN BE A CHALLENGE. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE SAME THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO ESTABLISH THAT ACCESS TO THE
BAY IS SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT
TO ME. AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
THE PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT WHO
HAVE UNEQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE
BAY, INCLUDING IN IMPERIAL
BEACH. I HAVE TO MENTION THEM
OVER 1000 DAYS OF CLOSURES OF
THEIR BEACH. NOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THE ONLY BEACH IN
CALIFORNIA WHO SUFFERS FROM
THIS. IN MY DISTRICT. SO I
WANTED TO POINT OUT A FEW
THINGS, THE SINCE THE BEGINNING
AND IN ALL BILLS THAT I PRESENT,
I, I AIM IN, I STRIVE TO ACHIEVE
A POINT OF HAVING A
RECOMMENDATION OF SUPPORTING MY
BILL WITH AMENDMENTS THAT, WOULD
FURTHER MY, MY GOALS IN MY BILL,
IN THIS CASE, AGAIN, THE GOAL IS
TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON THE COAST AND TO PRIORITIZE
COASTAL RESOURCES. AND ALWAYS
PROTECT ACCESS, THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY ARE
THERE'S TWO SETS OF AMENDMENTS
OR TWO DIFFERENT AMENDMENTS. THE
FIRST ONE OF WHICH, I BELIEVE IS
APPROPRIATE. I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENT ONE. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS ON ON PAGE 11, BECAUSE
I THINK ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT IDEAL,
IT REALLY IS INTENDING TO MOVE
THE BALL FORWARD WHEN IT COMES
TO ACCESS. RESOURCES, PROTECTION
AND HOUSING, UNFORTUNATELY, I
CANNOT SAY WITH THAT SAME
CERTAINTY THAT AMENDMENT TWO
DOES THE SAME THING. EVEN WITH
THAT, I WILL BE ACCEPTING BOTH
AMENDMENTS. AND THIS IS WHERE
I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS WITH YOU AND
SHARE WITH YOU WHY I'M NOT
CERTAIN THAT AMENDMENT NUMBER
TWO ACTUALLY FURTHERS THE GOAL
OF WHAT I AM HOPING TO REACH.
AND I'LL JUST SAY AT THE
BEGINNING HERE, NOW THAT IF
UNDER FURTHER ANALYSIS, WE
IDENTIFY THAT THESE AMENDMENTS,
IN FACT, DO NOT FURTHER,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ON THE COAST AND CONTINUE TO
PROTECT COASTAL ACCESS AND
RESOURCES, THEN IT'S A BILL I
DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE. I DON'T WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD HOUSING IF WHAT IS IN THE
BILL IN ITS AMENDMENTS DOES NOT
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN. AND THIS
IS THESE ARE THE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH THAT
AMENDMENT, WHICH I HOPE WE GET
INTO SOME BACK AND FORTH AND GET
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON ITS FACE,
REQUIRING THAT LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS, TO UPDATE THE CHANGES
THAT WE ARE MAKING SEEMS
REASONABLE TO ENSURE IT IS
IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY. HOWEVER,
THE AMENDMENT ALSO DELETES THE
PROVISION THAT PROHIBITS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LOCAL
COASTAL PROGRAM INCLUDE HOUSING
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS. THIS IS,
ON PAGE 12. IT'S THE VERY TOP OF
PAGE 12, AS YOU CAN SEE, IT IS
STRICKEN. SECTION 3,500.1 IS
STRICKEN FROM. I'M SORRY, SOME
NUMBER. SO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR. WE'RE NOT HERE TO AND WE
HAVE A POLICY IN THE SENATE THIS
YEAR THAT I THINK WAS ALSO THE
POLICY IN PREVIOUS YEARS. WE
DON'T NEGOTIATE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE DAIS. SO I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THE HISTORY OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL ON FRIDAY, YOUR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR TOLD MY
STAFF YOU WERE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WEEKS NOW, MAYBE
EVEN A MONTH PLUS, AND IT WAS
THIS MORNING THAT YOU TOLD ME
YOU WERE REJECTING THE
AMENDMENTS. AND THEN LATER THIS
MORNING, YOU TOLD ME YOU WERE
ACCEPTING THEM. THAT'S CORRECT.
AND SO WE ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSING THIS OFFLINE, BUT I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE, NOR IS IT IN THE
INTERESTS OF OUR TIME TO BE
NEGOTIATING AND DISCUSSING
PARTICULAR PROVISIONS, FROM THE
DAIS. AND SO I'M JUST GOING TO
ASK YOU TO PRESENT YOUR BILL AND
LET ME KNOW IF YOU'RE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS OR NOT. WE ARE. I
DEFINITELY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. AND I DON'T EXPECT
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE WITNESSES
AS WELL? YES. OKAY. YEAH. AND I
HOPE YOU ASKED SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE WHY WE HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS. BUT ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS, NOT EXPECTING YOU TO
CHANGE THE AMENDMENTS AT ALL.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR,
LIKE WE WERE HAPPY TO DISCUSS
LIKE A WEEK AGO OR EVEN THREE
DAYS AGO, CHANGING THE
PARTICULAR PROVISIONS AND HAVING
THE DIALOG. BUT I JUST THIS IS
NOT THE APPROPRIATE FORUM, I
THINK, TO LIKE, DISCUSS THE
CHANGES THAT WE COULD HAVE
DISCUSSED THREE DAYS AGO. WELL,
AGAIN, IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THAT THAT'S THAT HAPPENED. I
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT,
THAT, LACK OF TIMING HAS EXISTED
AS A RESULT OF SOME
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH, YOU KNOW,
WE, EXCHANGED WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND SO I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT, IF I MAY
CONTINUE TO JUST EXPRESS SOME OF
THE, YOU MAY, BUT THIS IS NOT I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR. THIS IS
NOT GOING TO BE A DIALOG AROUND
PARTICULAR PROVISIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS. ABSOLUTELY I
UNDERSTAND, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO, IT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IT'S
DIFFICULT, IT SEEMS LIKE IT IS A
THE CHANGES. I WILL BE VERY
HONEST WITH YOU. I'M NOT
ENTIRELY CERTAIN IN THIS SECTION
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
THE ANALYSIS WILL DO. AND
THAT'S, THAT'S THE HONEST TRUTH.
I WAS ABLE TO ANALYZE THE FIRST
AMENDMENTS WE RESPONDED TO, TO
THOSE, THE FIRST AMENDMENTS,
WHICH ARE, WHICH ARE ON PAGE 11,
THE ONES ON PAGE 12. I AM LESS
CERTAIN ABOUT WHAT THEY MEAN.
AND THAT'S WHY I HAVE I HAVE
THOSE CONCERNS AND I WANT TO
FURTHER MOVE THIS ALONG TO TRY
AND UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THE
OUTCOME AND WHAT THE RESULT OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL BE. AS WE
DO TAKE THEM AND MOVE FORWARD.
SO, WITHOUT INCLUDING OTHER
STATUTORY GUIDELINES OF THE
COASTAL ACT FOR HOW THESE
HOUSING POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
SHOULD LOOK, WHAT GUARDRAILS
COULD, SHOULD BE INCLUDED OR HOW
THEY SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED, I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT, AGAIN, WHAT
COULD BE OPENING UP OTHER ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN THE
FUTURE AS IT RELATES TO THESE
AMENDMENTS. SO I THINK I'LL END
WITH THAT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE UP MORE TIME. I'VE
EXPRESSED, THE REASONS WHY I'M
VERY OPEN WITH YOU ABOUT WHY I'M
CONCERNED, BECAUSE I REALLY,
HONESTLY AM NOT CERTAIN WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS WILL DO. AND LIKE I
SAID EARLIER, IF THE AMENDMENTS
AFTER FURTHER ANALYZING, FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE, MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THE COAST, THEN WE
WILL NOT BE PURSUING THIS BILL
ONCE IT MOVES BEYOND THIS
COMMITTEE. SO AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
AT LEAST HAVE THE HEARING. AND I
WANT TO ASK OUR WITNESSES TO
PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY. OF COURSE. AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE ALLOW EVERY
AUTHOR THAT IS OUR POLICY AS
WELL TO HAVE THEIR BILLS HEARD.
THANK YOU. I KNOW I DO. YOU HAVE
TWO WITNESSES OR ONE WITNESS
OKAY. AND SO EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. YOU CAN BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER PETERSON.
I'M A FORMER CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. I
SUPPORT AB 2560, INCLUDING WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT NUMBER ONE.
CURRENT LAW IS AMBIGUOUS AND
ALLOWS FOR LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS OR LSPS, TO BE USED TO
DELAY OR RESTRICT DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS, EVEN WHEN THEY DO NOT
RAISE SIGNIFICANT COASTAL ACT
CONCERNS. COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
NUMBER ONE WOULD FIX THOSE
PROBLEMS. I UNDERSTAND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ IS ACCEPTED,
AMENDMENT NUMBER TWO, BUT I DO
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT IT.
CURRENTLY, THE COASTAL ACT
PROHIBITS THE COASTAL COMMISSION
FROM REQUIRING LCPS TO INCLUDE
HOUSING POLICIES. THAT'S BECAUSE
THE ACT ITSELF DOES NOT INCLUDE
HOUSING POLICIES TO REPEAL THE
PROHIBITION ON REQUIRING HOUSING
POLICIES SUGGESTS THAT GOING
FORWARD, HOUSING POLICIES COULD
BE REQUIRED IN LPS, BUT NEITHER
CURRENT LAW NOR AB 2560 PROVIDES
ANY STATUTORY DIRECTION ABOUT
WHAT THE CONTENT OF THOSE
POLICIES SHOULD BE. THE
APPROPRIATE CONTEXT FOR
REPEALING THE CURRENT
PROHIBITION WOULD BE AS PART OF
LEGISLATION THAT ALSO
REINTRODUCES HOUSING POLICIES
BACK INTO THE COASTAL ACT THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS POLICY ISSUES, SUCH AS
THE EXTENT OF THE COMMISSION'S
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS. THOSE ISSUES ARE
WELL OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF AB
2560. FINALLY, THE LANGUAGE OF
AMENDMENT NUMBER TWO REGARDING
DENSITY BONUS, LCP AMENDMENTS
CONFLICTS WITH AMENDMENT NUMBER
ONE, AMENDMENT ONE REFERS TO
CHAPTER THREE OF THE COASTAL ACT
AS A STANDARD FOR EVALUATING IF
A DENSITY BONUS WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT ADVERSE IMPACTS.
AMENDMENT TWO INSTEAD REFERS TO
LCP AS A STANDARD THAT WOULD
REINTRODUCE CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
STANDARD TO APPLY TO DENSITY
BONUSES IN THE COASTAL ZONE.
ALSO, GIVEN THAT LCP ROUTINE
START TO WRAP UP, YES, JUST ONE
MORE POINT ROUTINELY INCLUDE
PROVISIONS THAT GO BEYOND
COASTAL ACT REQUIREMENTS,
AMENDMENT TWO RAISES THE
POSSIBILITY OF LCP BEING USED TO
RESTRICT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND JUST TO CONCLUDE, ARE YOU
SUPPORTING THE BILL OR NOT? WITH
THE TWO AMENDMENTS, I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL, BUT I DO
HAVE THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE IT. YOU'RE
WELCOME. NEXT WITNESS. YOU HAVE
UP TO TWO MINUTES AS WELL, AND
YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY, MR. CHAIR. EXCUSE ME, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, MY NAME IS
LUIS MORANTE. I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT AB 2005 60, AS AMENDED,
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL. OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE FOR
PROFIT NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS,
AMONG A HOST OF OTHER EMPLOYERS.
ABOUT 350 OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS IN THE BAY AREA. OUR
MEMBERS INCLUDE, FOR EXAMPLE,
MID-PEN HOUSING, WHICH HAS DONE
A SIGNIFICANT WORK IN BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE COAST.
AND THE THING THAT BRINGS ME TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY IS THE
AUTHOR'S GOAL TO INCREASE THE
DEVELOPMENT, CERTAINTY AND
CLARITY AROUND HOW THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW APPLIES IN THE COAST
TO MAKE THOSE IMPORTANT PROJECTS
EASIER, LIKE THE AUTHOR, I SHARE
THE VIEW THAT BUILDING MORE
HOUSING, ESPECIALLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THE COAST, INCREASES
COASTAL ACCESS THAT MAKES OUR
COAST BETTER, AND THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
DENSITY. BONUS LAW TO, AS THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE SAY, HARMONIZE
THE GOALS OF THE COASTAL ACT AND
DENSITY BONUS LAW. NOTHING ABOUT
THIS BILL OR ANY VERSION THAT WE
PROPOSED INTENDED TO BUILD
UNRESTRICTED ON WETLANDS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. THIS BILL IS
HAS BEEN INTENDED TO, CREATE
MORE DEVELOPMENT CERTAINTY FOR
PEOPLE IN INFILL LOCATIONS AND
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT GOAL, I
THINK, THAT ADVANCES THE GOAL OF
THE COASTAL ACT. THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR A SPECIFIC PROJECT
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING, ACTUALLY
AT CITY COUNCIL TOMORROW IN THE
CITY OF HALF MOON BAY, THIS VERY
BILL WOULD HAVE SOLVED AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN THE CORE ISSUE FOR
AN IMPORTANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT BROUGHT FORWARD BY FARM
WORKERS IN THAT COMMUNITY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MUTUAL HOUSING.
THAT BUILDING, WHICH IS ABOUT 90
UNITS, IS BEING DEBATED BY THE
CITY COUNCIL. IN THE FOURTH
MEETING THAT THAT JURISDICTION
HAS HAD ON THIS PROJECT, BECAUSE
HOW TO APPLY THE DENSITY BONUS
LAW TO THAT PROJECT IS UNCLEAR.
THAT IS A CENTRAL ISSUE THAT THE
PLANNING COMMISSION IN THAT CITY
SPEND THREE MEETINGS ON, AND
THAT THE CITY COUNCIL WILL MEET
ON TOMORROW. THAT'S A SHAME,
BECAUSE IT SENDS A STRONG SIGNAL
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND OTHER DEVELOPERS THAT THE
COASTAL ZONE IS A PLACE THAT IS
UNWELCOME FOR THEIR BUSINESS AND
THAT, I THINK, SERIOUSLY DETERS
OR HARMS RATHER THE GOALS, THE
STATED GOALS AND THE AND THE
IMPORTANT COASTAL ACCESS GOALS
OF THE COASTAL ACT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM? IF YOU
COULD STAY ME TO TESTIMONY,
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. ANDREW DAWSON,
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT CATHERINE CHARLES ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MOYAMOYA ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO, IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON. CASSIE
MANCINI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, JORDAN GRIMES, ON
BEHALF OF THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS ANNIE LAWLER, ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT, THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT IN THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DANNY KURT IN
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS IN SUPPORT OF A
MEASURED BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SEEING NO OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM, DO YOU
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? DO WE JUST
HAVE ONE. TWO. OKAY, YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. YOU CAN
COMMENCE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I'M LINDA ESCALANTE,
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. FIRST, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. DESPITE THE
RHETORIC, THE COASTAL ZONE
ACTUALLY HAS A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF RINA COMPLIANT JURISDICTIONS
THAN THE REST OF THE STATE, AND
13% OF COASTAL CITIES HAVE
RECEIVED THE STATE'S COVETED PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION, COMPARED
WITH ONLY 8% OF INLAND
COMMUNITIES. SEVERAL OF THESE
HAVE TAKEN THE VOLUNTARY STEP OF
AMENDING THEIR LCP TO HARMONIZE
DENSITY BONUS LAWS WITH COASTAL
ACT POLICIES. WE SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE REST OF THE COASTAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO DO THE
SAME WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THE COMMISSION IS
PREPARED TO DROP ITS OPPOSITION.
CLEARLY, THIS IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET AND MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE. I AM A MEMBER OF THE MOST
DIVERSE COMMISSION IN 50 YEARS.
WE ARE BROWN AND BLACK AND LGBTQ
PLUS LEADERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE ALSO HOUSING
ADVOCATES, RENTERS, AND TENANT
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. WE SEE COASTAL
INEQUITY AND FEEL ITS IMPACT
PERSONALLY. EVERY DAY. I
CERTAINLY DID, AND I HAVE DONE
FOR MY WHOLE LIFE. WE AGREE WITH
THE OBSERVATION THAT THE COAST
IS WEALTHIER AND LESS DIVERSE
THAN THE REST OF THE STATE. THIS
INJUSTICE LONG PREDATES THE
COASTAL ACT, AND THE COMMISSION
HAS SOUGHT TO CORRECT IT SINCE
THE BEGINNING. DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS ALREADY HAVE A PLACE IN
THE COASTAL ZONE, BUT THEY
PRIMARILY RESULT IN UNIT IN
LUXURY UNITS WHILE PROVIDING
LITTLE RELIEF FOR TEACHERS,
SERVICE WORKERS OR OUR HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS. ALTHOUGH THE COASTAL
ZONE SUPPORTS A $48 BILLION
COAST AND OCEAN ECONOMY, IT
MAKES UP JUST 1% OF THE STATE.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON POLICIES
THAT INCREASE AND ACCELERATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, RATHER THAN
RELYING ON SUPPLY SIDE TRICKLE
DOWN THEORIES, THE COMMISSION IS
EAGER TO ENGAGE IN A GOOD FAITH
DIALOG WITH LEGISLATORS TO FIND
MORE WAYS TO INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
THE INTEGRITY OF THE COASTAL
ACT. THESE GOALS ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE. ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMISSION, I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS ATTENTION
TO THIS ISSUE. THE COMMISSION'S
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER, SHAWN
DRAKE, AND I ARE HERE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, NEXT WITNESS, WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
LAURA WALSH, CALIFORNIA POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION. SURFRIDER PROTECTS
THE COASTLINE AND COASTAL
ACCESS. WE ARE DROPPING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WITH THE
ACCEPTANCE OF COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. WE'RE JOINED IN THIS
POSITION BY 47 OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ACCESS
ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL AS 300
GRASSROOTS MEMBERS OF SURFRIDER
WHO SIGNED OUR RELATED PETITION
OVER JUST THE LAST FOUR DAYS.
SURFRIDER STRONGLY SUPPORTS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL ZONE. WE'RE
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. STAFF
OF MOSTLY RENTERS IN THE COASTAL
ZONE, AND WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THE STRESSFUL NEED FOR
AFFORDABILITY IN THIS PART OF
THE STATE. WE ALSO HAVE A LONG
HISTORY AND HUGE GRASSROOTS
NETWORK DEFENDING COASTAL ACCESS
IN CALIFORNIA. WE WORK WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THE COAST, AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTED OUT. BUT
THE ANSWER ISN'T TO OVERRIDE THE
COASTAL ACT, THE COASTAL ACT IS
WHAT HAS FACILITATED OUR BASIC
RIGHT TO A FREE AND PUBLIC
COASTLINE. NOW WE NEED TO BUILD
OFF THAT WITH MORE ACTION TO
ADDRESS OUR MODERN CHALLENGES,
NOT PAVE THROUGH IT. WE SUPPORT
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE BILL.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO. CALIFORNIANS
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A PUBLIC,
HEALTHY COASTLINE. AND WE'RE
REALLY GLAD THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
TODAY, BECAUSE INSTEAD, WE HOPE
TO IN THE FUTURE, SESSIONS
SUPPORT LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAMS
BEING HARMONIZED WITH DENSITY
BONUS LAW AND INCENTIVIZED IN A
WAY THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ALREADY PROVEN THEY CAN DO.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR IN A TWEENER
POSITION TO THIS BILL? NAME
AFFILIATION. POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. ETHAN NAGLER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF CARLSBAD AND
RANCHO PALOS VERDES, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GABRIELLA FAZIO WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL. WITH THE NEW
AMENDMENTS WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
SOLANA BEACH AND CORONADO, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND CHRISTY HØI ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF REDONDO BEACH, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS
DAN JACOBSEN WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. IF ALL THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN, WE'LL
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
, MR. CHAIRMAN. MARCELO
GUTIERREZ FROM AZUL AND A LONG
TIME RESIDENT OF ADDED IN
NEUTRAL. GIVEN THE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU, KIM
DELFINO ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE REMOVING OPPOSITION
WITH THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
REMOVING OPPOSITION IN LIGHT OF
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
GIBBS. I'M WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION COMMITTEE
OF WEST MARIN, IN OPPOSITION, IF
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE NOT
TAKEN AND THE FOLLOWING GROUPS
ARE ALSO OPPOSED UNLESS THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN, THE
CLIMATE CENTER, CALIFORNIA
COASTKEEPER ALLIANCE, OUR CITY
SF RIVER ECOLOGY PROJECT,
WATERSHED ALLIANCE OF MARIN
PUVUNGA WETLANDS PROTECTORS,
FORESTS UNLIMITED RESOURCE
RENEWAL INSTITUTE, NORTH COAST
RIVERS ALLIANCE, SOCAL 350
CLIMATE ACTION, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATERSHED ALLIANCE,
CANYON BACK ALLIANCE, COASTAL
LANDS ACTION NETWORK, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY, PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, DEFEND
BALLONA WETLANDS, CALIFORNIA
RIVER WATCH ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER
OF SAN DIEGO, HUMBOLDT
WATERKEEPER, GREEN FOOTHILLS,
GAVIOTA COAST CONSERVANCY, SANTA
CLARA VALLEY, AUDUBON SOCIETY,
ENVIRONMENT, ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER, THEATER DE
LAGUNA FARM, LOS CERRITOS
WETLANDS TRUST, CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL RESOURCES PROTECTION
ALLIANCE, INC, SMITH RIVER
ALLIANCE, SAVE SONOMA COAST,
IDLE NO MORE, SOCAL, VENICE,
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE,
PROTECT, BALLONA WETLANDS, WEST
SONOMA COUNTY ALLIANCE PUBLIC
TRUST ALLIANCE, FRIENDS OF
HARBORS, BEACHES AND PARKS,
BALLONA WETLANDS INSTITUTE,
COAST WALK, AND THE I NO. OKAY,
ONE MORE PEDRO POINT COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU. DID YOU
FORGET ANY. NEVERMIND,
NEVERMIND. NO, I HOPE NOT. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ALLENA
SOUZA, POLITICAL SCIENCE STUDENT
AT UCLA AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS,
WE DROP OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
HI, I'M AISSATA DIALLO, PUBLIC
HEALTH STUDENT AT UC MERCED. AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS, WE DROP
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SUSAN
JORDAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL ORANGE COUNTY
COASTKEEPER AND THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL PROTECTION NETWORK IN
OPPOSITION. BUT WE WILL GO TO
NEUTRAL WITH THE ACCEPTANCE OF
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND VICTORIA ROME, WITH
NRDC, SIMILARLY WILL GO TO
NEUTRAL WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS,
SENATOR PADILLA, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES, I APOLOGIZE FOR
JOINING THE HEARING LATE. AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE AND PARTNER
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
AGREED UNEQUIVOCALLY TO ACCEPT
ALL THE AMENDMENTS. IT WASN'T
CLEAR TO ME, BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE CHAIR.
AND WITH THAT, I UNDERSTAND YOUR
RECOMMENDATION WILL BE I JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS, SOME OF IT A
LITTLE ANATHEMA. FIRST, I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BEING
WILLING TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, I'VE SPENT A
LITTLE TIME WORKING ON COASTAL
LAND USE ISSUES AND A LOT OF
CAPACITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE, AND THERE HAS FOR A LONG
TIME BEEN THIS ONGOING DEBATE
WITH RESPECT TO PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR HOUSING,
PRODUCING AFFORDABLE PRODUCT
EVERYWHERE, BUT NOT THE LEAST OF
WHICH IN THE UNIQUE PLACE THAT
IS THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL ZONE.
AND FOR MANY DECADES, MANY OF
YOU KNOW, IT HAS SORT OF BEEN
POLARIZED ON TWO OPPOSITE ENDS.
ONE IS TO TRY REPEATEDLY AND TO
ADVOCATE THE POSITION THAT WE
NEED EXEMPTIONS FROM COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT REVIEW AND
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE CHAPTER
THREE PROVISIONS THAT TEND AND
HAVE PROTECTED PUBLIC ACCESS AND
COASTAL RESOURCES. WHILE
BALANCING THAT WITH OTHER
REQUIRED CONSIDERATIONS. AND ON
THE OTHER END, THOSE WHO ARE
DEEPLY CRITICAL OF THE
COMMISSION'S LONG AGO AUTHORITY,
COMPLETE AUTHORITY ON MATTERS OF
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT SUMMON THE HOUSING AND
DEVELOPMENT BUSINESS FELT WAS
ABUSED IN WAYS THAT RESULTED IN
A LACK OF APPROVALS. I'M NOT
ENTIRELY CERTAIN THAT THE DATA
STACKS UP TO THAT. MY POINT IS
THIS WE CAN APPLY THE BENEFITS.
I THINK OF DENSITY BONUS LAW,
AND WE CAN FIND WAYS I THINK, AS
WE ATTEMPT TO DO HERE, TO
PROVIDE ADVANTAGES TO
INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
THIS PRODUCT IN THESE AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA AND NOT SACRIFICE THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE COASTAL ACT.
IT CAN BE BOTH. AND I THINK THAT
IS THE APPROPRIATE, APPROACH.
AND I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ELSE. A LOT OF THIS, THESE
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS, I THINK,
ARE VERY VALUABLE, BUT THEY ALL
OPERATE OFF THE SAME PREMISE.
AND I'M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
THAT'S A LITTLE ANATHEMA IN THE
HOUSING WORLD. WE WILL NOT AND
CANNOT JUST BUILD OUR WAY TO
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS NOT MERELY A
FUNCTION OF SCARCITY. IT IS NOT
MERELY A PRODUCT, A FUNCTION OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS INCREMENTAL FACTORS
THAT AFFECT AFFORDABILITY, BOTH
ON THE PRODUCTION AND ON THE
DEMAND SIDE. FRANKLY, NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH IS THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE A GROWING SEGMENT OF OUR
WORKFORCE AND A GROWING SEGMENT
OF OUR POPULATION THAT LIVE IN
WORKING POVERTY. MEANING NO
MATTER HOW HARD THEY WORK OR HOW
MANY HOURS THEY WORK, THEY
CANNOT MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS
AND THEY CAN'T EVEN QUALIFY FOR
WHAT WE CLASSIFY AS AFFORDABLE,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO WHILE
EFFORTS TO HELP WITH THE SUPPLY
END OF THIS ARE ALWAYS
APPROPRIATE AND LAUDABLE, AND
ARE PART OF THE SOLUTION, TRYING
TO DO INCREMENTAL EXEMPTIONS TO
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT, PERMIT
REVIEW AND EXEMPTIONS AROUND THE
PROVISIONS OF THE COASTAL ACT.
IN MY OPINION, WILL ONLY LEAD TO
ONE THING A BAD PRECEDENT AND A
PATTERN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT WILL CREATE BACK DOORS
AROUND THE COASTAL ACT UNTIL
IT'S LIKE SWISS CHEESE AND IT
COLLAPSES UPON ITSELF. WHICH, TO
BE FRANK, THERE ARE THOSE THAT
WOULD APPLAUD THAT. PLENTY TO
PLENTY TO DEBATE ABOUT IN TERMS
OF REFORMING HOW WE ADMINISTER
THE ACT. PERHAPS BUT CREATING
EXEMPTIONS AROUND THE
PROTECTIONS IS NOT SOMETHING I
CAN EVER SUPPORT. AND SO I'M
VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED THESE AMENDMENTS. AND
WITH THAT ACCEPTANCE, I'M HAPPY
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL.
AND THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR, FOR MEETING
WITH ME. AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. I THINK
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL. I THINK I
WANTED TO SPEAK TO 2 OR 3 OF THE
ISSUES THAT AT A HIGHER LEVEL
AND ONE IS, IS THE COMMENT WAS
MADE ABOUT, KIDS OR PEOPLE THAT
HADN'T BEEN TO THE COAST AND HOW
HARD IT WAS. AND IT'S I KNOW
WHEN I HEADED THE STATE'S OCEANS
PROGRAM, ONE OF THE SURPRISING
THINGS AND IT I THINK WILD COAST
IN SAN DIEGO WAS ONE WHERE THERE
WERE ALL THESE KIDS THAT HAD
GROWN UP 5 TO 6 MILES FROM THE
OCEAN AND HAD NEVER BEEN TO THE
OCEAN. AND IT IS TRUE IN THE
MONTEREY BAY AREA WITH THE
O'NEILL SEA ODYSSEY, THERE ARE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF KIDS
FROM SAN JOSE AND INLAND THAT
HAD NEVER SEEN THE OCEAN. AND AS
THEY'VE INTRODUCED IT TO 50,000
KIDS OVER 20 YEARS, THAT HAS
HAPPENED. IT IS NOT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THAT THE REASON
THAT'S TRUE. PERIOD. THE END. I
MEAN, THEY PROVIDE ACCESS THAT
WEREN'T THERE WASN'T THERE. AND
I THINK PART OF THE THERE HAVE
BEEN FOUR BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
AT ISSUE HERE THIS YEAR. AND,
AND FOR ME, THE BOTTOM LINE IS
DOING EXEMPTIONS OR
LEGISLATIVELY CARVING IN IT IS
MAKING IT WORK. AND I MEAN, THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO HAD A
BILL WHERE HE WANTED TO START
LEGISLATING JUST WHERE THE
COASTAL ZONE WAS. AND I
IMMEDIATELY HAD CONSTITUENTS
THAT HAVE HAD TO PROVIDE COASTAL
ACCESS. CALL ME AND SAY, WE WANT
TO BE WRITTEN INTO THE BILL. WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS. AND SO IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT, I THINK, TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE BOUNDARY
AND THE DUTIES OF THE COASTAL
ACT AND WORK WITHIN IT. AND I
WAS REALLY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
STUDY THAT WAS RELEASED, WHICH I
SORT OF THOUGHT WAS A HATCHET
JOB THAT, WHILE PEOPLE CAN TALK
TO ANY PART OF IT, I'M A FORMER
MAYOR OF ONE OF THE CITIES THAT
IS FREQUENTLY REPRESENTED IN
THERE, AND IT WAS REPRESENTED
THAT A COUPLE OF HOUSING
PROJECTS WERE REALLY HARASSED.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT TO BE
TRUE. AND THIS IS IN A CITY THAT
IS THAT HAS GOTTEN ONE OF THE
AWARDS FOR BEING, YOU KNOW,
HOUSING FRIENDLY CITY, WHICH IS
ON THE TRACK TO MEETING ALL ITS
RENA GOALS, YOU KNOW, EVEN
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE WHERE
THE MAYOR WROTE AN OP ED ON THIS
BILL AND SAID IT IS NOT A CHOICE
BETWEEN COASTAL PROTECTION AND
PROVIDING HOUSING. AND SO THE
AND AS WAS SAID, THE PRECISE
STATISTIC, I THINK THAT THE VICE
CHAIR, WHEN SHE SPOKE I THINK
66% OF THE OF THE CITIES IN THE
STATE ARE SORT OF ON TRACK WITH
THEIR RENA GOALS, 72% WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE. AND SO THE REAL
QUESTION IS NOT OVERRIDING THE
COASTAL ACT TO DO THIS. IT'S
TRYING TO GIVE THEM TOOLS TO DO
IT EVEN MORE. AND IT WAS THE
SENATOR FROM THE SEAT I SIT IN
THAT OVER 40 YEARS AGO WROTE THE
BILL TO EXEMPT HOUSING FROM FROM
THE COASTAL ACT. AND, AND OUR
COLLEAGUE CHRIS WARD ATTEMPTED 2
OR 3 YEARS AGO TO DO A BILL TO
REINSTITUTE IT BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE WAY TO
START TO HELP WITH HOUSING. IT
DIDN'T MAKE IT. AND BUT, YOU
KNOW, THAT IS A LOGICAL WAY TO
PROCEED. AND IT IS LOGICAL FOR
US SOME OF THE TOOLS OR TOOLS
THAT WOULD EXIST OR ARE
NECESSARY, WHETHER IT'S IN THE
COASTAL ZONE OR NOT, IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. AND THERE ARE
THINGS THAT CONTORT THIS DEBATE.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT IT'S PEOPLE
LIVING, I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT
TO CALL THEM MANSIONS, BUT LET'S
JUST SAY VERY WELL-TO-DO BIG
HOUSES THAT ARE DOING, ADUS FOR
THEIR FAMILY OR OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT HELPING THE HOUSING
SITUATION IN THE STATE. SO IT IS
A QUESTION OF HOW TO GUIDE IT IN
THE CORRECT WAY. IT IS NOT A
CHOICE BETWEEN COASTAL
PROTECTION AND HOUSING. AND I
THINK THAT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
STARTS TO GET A ROADMAP FOR HOW
TO DO THAT. AND I HOPE YOU CAN,
OVER TIME, CLAIM THAT AS A
VICTORY BECAUSE YOU STARTED THE
DISCUSSION AND YOU FIGURED OUT A
WAY THAT IT MIGHT BE HARMONIZED
AND THERE'S A WAY TO PUSH FOR
HOUSING WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE.
SO, I THINK DESPITE THE, JUST
HOW HARD THIS DEBATE WAS UP TO
THIS MOMENT, IT'S NOT A BAD
ENDING, AND IT IS A QUESTION OF
HOW TO MAKE SURE WE ALL DO
WHATEVER WE CAN, FOR THOSE TOOLS
AND, AND JUST MAYBE ONE IRONY, I
REPRESENT THE BIG SUR COASTLINE,
WHICH HAS MORE ISSUES PER CAPITA
THAN ANY PLACE IN THE UNIVERSE.
IT BURNS, IT FLOODS. HIGHWAYS
FALL INTO THE OCEAN. THERE'S
ONLY 2000 PEOPLE IN IN 70 MILES.
AND ONE OF THE BIG BEEFS WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION THERE IS
THE FACT THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, THEY BELIEVE, IS
COMMITTED TOTALLY TO ACCESS, NOT
NECESSARILY RESOURCE MANAGEMENT,
THAT WHENEVER THE ROADS ARE
OPEN, WHICH DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
REGULARLY, IT IS 4 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT PASS THROUGH THAT
FRAGILE 70 MILE COASTLINE IN A
YEAR, AND PEOPLE ARE PARKING ON
FIRE ROADS, THERE'S NOT ADEQUATE
BATHROOMS, THE FOREST SERVICE
CLOSES AT 6 P.M, AND NOW THERE'S
VIGILANTES GOING AROUND AND
PUTTING OUT CAMPFIRES BECAUSE
THEY'VE HAD FIRES OF HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ACRES AND LOST HOMES. AND
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT ON THAT.
AND SO PART OF THIS GOES THE
OTHER WAY, AS WELL IS LIKE, HOW
DO WE DO RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
WITHIN ALL THE ACCESS THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE PROVIDING? SO, THIS
DEBATE WILL NOT END. AND THIS
DEBATE HAS TAKEN VARIOUS TURNS,
BUT I HOPE IT GETS EVERYBODY TO
TURN TOWARD, PROVIDING HOUSING
AND PROTECTING THE COAST IN A
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE WAY,
WHICH I HONESTLY BELIEVE CAN BE
DONE. AND IF YOU LOOK AT A LOT
OF THE CITIES WITHIN THE COASTAL
ZONE, SUCH AS MY HOME CITY, IT
IS HAPPENING. IT IS I MISS THE
SLEEPY LITTLE COASTAL TOWN WHERE
I MOVED TO WHERE WERE SURFERS,
WAITED TABLES THREE NIGHTS A
WEEK, AND SURF THE REST OF THE
TIME. THAT DOES NOT EXIST
ANYMORE AND I REALLY MISS IT.
BUT IT'S HOW WE CAN DO THE
ACCESS WITHIN THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS DIVERSE AND SO I
APPRECIATE THIS DEBATE AS
PAINFUL AS IT WAS ALONG THE WAY.
AND I WILL BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. SENATOR LAIRD. AND I JUST
WANTED TO, YOU KNOW, OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM YOU ARE TAKING
BOTH AMENDMENTS, RIGHT? CORRECT.
AND YOU ARE DOING SO. I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR, BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN ACCUSED OF FORCING SUBTLE,
AMENDMENTS. YOU ARE TAKING THEM
OF YOUR OWN ACCORD. DO YOU HAVE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL AND WORK THE MEMBERS
AND TRY TO PASS IT? BUT YOU ARE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS, CORRECT.
OKAY. I JUST WANT TO SAY, AND
THAT IS THE POLICY OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND EVERY OTHER
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE IS THAT
WE HEAR ALL BILLS, WE OFFER
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO GET THIS TO
A PLACE WHERE WE CAN AGREE. AND
I'LL JUST START AT THE OUTSET BY
SAYING, I BELIEVE WE ARE IN A
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, THE NUMBER
ONE REASON FOR HOMELESSNESS IS
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING. THE
NUMBER ONE REASON PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING THE STATE IS THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING. YOU HAVE PEOPLE
IN MY DISTRICT IN ORANGE COUNTY,
KIDS COMING OUT OF COLLEGE AT A
LAW SCHOOL, MAKING OVER $100,000
A YEAR, STRUGGLING TO FIND
HOUSING. SO IT'S A CRISIS. I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING, AND I WILL
NOTE THAT UNTIL THIS YEAR, I
BELIEVE I HAD A 100% RECORD FROM
CALIFORNIA. YIMBY I BELIEVE THAT
RECORD IS UNIQUE AMONG SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY LEGISLATORS, SO I
WANT TO JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET,
I SUPPORT THOSE GOALS. I WILL
ALSO SAY THAT I HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED AS WELL WITH SOME OF
THE DECISIONS OR THE PACE WITH
WHICH THE COASTAL CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS APPROVED
NEW HOUSING. SO I UNDERSTAND THE
SOURCE OF ANGST HERE THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS, YOU KNOW, IN
MY DISTRICT, WE HAVE THE
MAGNOLIA TANK FARMS PROJECT,
WHICH IS A MULTI USE PROJECT
THAT I BELIEVE IS SLOTTED TO DO
25% VERY LOW INCOME HOUSING, A
PROJECT THAT HAD COMMITTED TO
USING ALL UNIONIZED LABOR TO USE
ALL UNIONIZED LABOR FOR THE
HOTEL THAT WAS PLANNING TO
BUILD. AND THAT PROJECT WAS
SEEMINGLY HELD UP FOR SOME TIME.
SO I GET SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION
HERE. I ALSO WILL JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES.
BEFORE THAT, I THINK THERE ARE,
YOU KNOW, MORE ARTFUL APPROACHES
HERE THAN TAKING A SLEDGEHAMMER
TO THE COASTAL ACT, WHICH IS
WHAT I SEE THIS BILL STARTING TO
DO. AND THE CONCERN I HAD AROUND
THIS BILL IS THAT IT WOULD LEAD
TO, IN MANY AREAS, UNLIMITED
BUILDING BY RIGHT, INCLUDING
MULTI USE, WITHIN 300FT OF THE
COASTLINE. AND I THINK THAT
ENSURING COASTAL PRESERVATION
AND COASTAL ACCESS ALSO HAVE TO
BE IMPORTANT GOALS. SO WE HAVE
TO BUILD OUT MORE HOUSING AND WE
SHOULD BUILD IN COASTAL ZONES.
WE SHOULD BE PUSHING THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO DO THAT. AT THE
SAME TIME, I THINK WE WANT TO
PRESERVE WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE SPECIAL, THAT WE DON'T
WANT OUR COASTLINE TO BECOME
WAIKIKI OR MIAMI. AND SO I THINK
WITH THE AMENDMENTS, WE MOVE
THAT WAY. AND I WILL JUST NOTE
THAT AS PART OF THE PROCESS, YOU
AND I MET VERY EARLY ON TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL, AND I
EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS TO YOU
BACK THEN. I SAID, IF YOU HAVE
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO ADDRESS MY
CONCERNS, WE'LL BE HAPPY TO HEAR
THEM. AND I WILL JUST NOTE THAT
ALONG THE WAY, MY STAFF
CONTINUED TO OFFER AMENDMENTS TO
TRY TO MAKE THE BILL MORE
AMENABLE TO THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUES AND MYSELF, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT GOING
FORWARD. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS. BUT THERE ARE REAL
CONCERNS HERE. THEY'RE NOT ANTI
YIMBY CONCERNS. THEY ARE PRO
HOUSING CONCERNS. BUT FINDING
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
BUILDING OUT MORE HOUSING IN A
ROBUST WAY IN THE STATE,
ADDRESSING THE ACTUAL HOUSING
CRISIS WE HAVE WHILE TRYING TO
PRESERVE THE COASTLINE AND WHAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA SPECIAL. I
THINK FINDING THAT RIGHT BALANCE
IS REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT. SO
WE'RE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. I
AM GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY WITH THAT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH. THANK YOU
AGAIN. I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. I KNOW IT'S THE POLICY OF
THE SENATE. YOU MADE IT PRETTY
CLEAR TO HEAR ALL BILLS, BUT I
STILL THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
HAVE A DIALOG EXPRESSED, ALSO
GRATITUDE TO THE MEMBERS WHO WHO
SHARED THEIR PARTICULAR,
CONCERNS OR THOUGHTS ABOUT ABOUT
THIS. I THINK THE WORD USED BY
SENATOR LAIRD WAS TO TRY AND
GUIDE THIS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I THINK CHAIRMAN'S
COMMENTS ALSO ARE ABOUT TRYING
TO GET TO THAT POINT, THAT'S
WHAT I'VE BEEN SEEKING ALL
ALONG, JUST TO BE, YOU KNOW,
VERY CLEAR. WHEN WE CAME TO THIS
POINT IN THIS COMMITTEE, WE HAD
ALREADY SUBSTANTIALLY NARROWED,
IN WAYS THAT WE HAD RECEIVED
FEEDBACK THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS,
TO TRY AND REACH THAT BALANCE, I
THINK AT LEAST THE THREE WHO
SPOKE, SHARED WITH US TODAY OF
HOUSING ACCESS, RESOURCES
PROTECTION AND ALL THAT. SO
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE INTENT,
AND SO WE HOPE THAT, THESE
AMENDMENTS CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THAT AND THAT THAT'S WHERE THIS
LEADS US TO. AND AGAIN, THANK
YOU FOR THE, FOR THE WILLINGNESS
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION. I
APPRECIATE THAT, THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR YOUR CLOSE
I'M GOING TO DO THIS, BUT I
MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LARA. I WAS GOING TO ASK
FOR A MOTION. SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON FILE ITEM 15 AB 2560.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR. MIN MIN. AYE. SATO HI.
SATO. AYE. ALLEN DALLI. DALLI.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO WAS NOT HERE.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN PADILLA.
PADILLA AYE. STERN. SEVEN ZERO.
THE VOTE COUNT IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL, OUR
NEXT BILL IS ALSO FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM 16, AB 3227, ASSEMBLYWOMAN,
YOU'RE FREE TO PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR, THIS, BILL 32, 27, HAS
HAD NO OPPOSITION, SO YOU
SHOULDN'T HEAR FROM. I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY TODAY AND NO, NO
VOTES THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS,
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD,
ASSIST WITH STORMWATER CHANNEL
MAINTENANCE. IT'S A STORMWATER
CHANNEL MAINTENANCE STREAMLINING
ACT, AGAIN, THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
STAFF FOR WORKING ON THE
ANALYSIS. THE BILL WOULD CREATE
A FIVE YEAR STATUTORY CEQA
EXEMPTION FOR ROUTINE
MAINTENANCE, ROUTINE MAINTENANCE
OF STORMWATER CHANNELS THAT ARE
FULLY CONCRETE, OR THAT HAVE A
CONVEYANCE CAPACITY OF LESS THAN
100 YEAR. STORM EVENT, WHICH IS
THE FEMA STANDARD FOR
ESTABLISHING FLOOD INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS. SPECIFICALLY, THIS
BILL PROVIDES CERTAINTY TO LOCAL
AGENCIES BY PROVIDING NARROW
EXEMPTION UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT FOR
MAINTENANCE OF STORMWATER
CHANNEL THAT PREVENT FLOODING.
STORMWATER INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDERFUNDED,
AND MANY CHANNELS ARE NOT BUILT
TO WITHSTAND MAJOR WEATHER
EVENTS, WHICH IS ONLY MADE WORSE
WHEN THOSE CHANNELS ARE NOT
MAINTAINED. WE SAW THIS IN
JANUARY IN SAN DIEGO.
UNFORTUNATELY, AS AN ATMOSPHERIC
RIVER BROUGHT NEARLY THREE
INCHES OF RAIN IN ONLY SIX
HOURS. TO PUT THAT INTO
PERSPECTIVE, THREE INCHES OF
RAIN IN SAN DIEGO IS ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
RAIN THAT WE GET FOR AN ENTIRE
YEAR. SO, AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
THAT CREATED AN UNPRECEDENTED
FLOODING, WHICH YOU PROBABLY SAW
IMAGES ON TELEVISION IN THE NEWS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA AFFECTING
THOUSANDS WHOLE HOUSEHOLDS,
WATER LEVELS RISING BEYOND FIVE
FEET, THINGS WE HAD NEVER SEEN
IN SAN DIEGO. SO AS CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCES MORE FREQUENT AND
MORE INTENSE RAIN EVENTS, WE
NEED TO ALLOW OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE PROACTIVE
MEASURES BY CLEARING OUT STORM
CHANNELS WITHOUT ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS, LAWSUITS
OR OTHER COMPLEX BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESSES. THAT'S WHAT AB 3227
DOES. RESPONDING BY CREATING A
FIVE YEAR EXEMPTION UNDER SEQUA
TO CUT THE RED TAPE AND PAVE THE
WAY FOR TIMELY UPKEEP OF THESE
ESSENTIAL FACILITIES. AND SO
WITH THAT, AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT DUE TO THE IMMEDIATE
NEED TO COMPLETE THE MAINTENANCE
TO PREVENT FUTURE FLOODING, WE
HAVE ADDED AN URGENCY CLAUSE SO
THAT THIS BILL MAY TAKE EFFECT
BEFORE THE RAINY SEASON BEGINS.
IN OCTOBER, THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY? AND WE HAVE ONE. WELL,
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. HOPEFULLY, I DON'T
EVEN NEED THAT. I AM WIRETAP.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO, WHERE THE SPONSORS
OF THE MEASURE, THIS BILL
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES LIKE OURS TO CLEAR
STORM STORM CHANNELS PRIOR TO
STORM EVENTS. CURRENT LAW
TRIGGERS MITIGATION, BUT THAT
MITIGATION IS REQUIRED TO BE
COMPLETED BEFORE THE CLEARING
WORK BEGINS. IF CHANNELS NEED TO
BE CLEARED AHEAD OF A STORM, A
STORM EVENT, CURRENT PROCESSES
OFTEN PREVENT THAT WORK FROM
BEGINNING, WHICH OF COURSE
INCREASES FLOOD RISK AND
EXACERBATES EMERGENCY CONDITIONS
. ESSENTIALLY, THIS BILL, AS THE
AUTHOR, MENTIONED, PROVIDES
CERTAINTY FOR US, ALLOWS US TO
MOVE QUICKLY WITH CRITICAL
MAINTENANCE WITHIN STORM
FACILITIES, AND PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC FLOODING. AB33227
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES MAY RELY ON THE
EMERGENCY EXEMPTION UNDER SEQUA
FOR ROUTINE CHANNEL MAINTENANCE
TO PREVENT FLOODING AND
ELIMINATE TIME CONSUMING
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS, AND
LASTLY, I WOULD NOTE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY SUFFERED UNDER
BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. AB 323 3227 WILL
HELP LOCAL AGENCIES EXPEDITE
FLOOD CONTROL MEASURES AHEAD OF
STORM EVENTS TO ENSURE THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
FLOODING, AND SO ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR TODD GLORIA AND THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO, WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SO ARE THERE ANY
METOOS THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL? JUST COME
UP AND SAY YOUR NAME. IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE PEOPLE ARE SCRAMBLING.
SO I'M GOING TO DISPENSE WITH
THE INSTRUCTIONS PART. ANYBODY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL? ANYBODY IN
FAVOR OF DELAYS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND HELPING PEOPLE? NO
OKAY, GOOD. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE DÍAS THEN, WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
I HEARD TWO, TWO MOVES. THE BILL
. SO MR. DOLLY WOULD LIKE TO BE
THE PERSON THAT MOVES THE BILL.
WELL, HE'S ON YOUR LEFT, SO.
YEAH MY LEFT EAR IS BETTER THAN
MY RIGHT. I'M SORRY, SO, ANYWAY,
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY DOLLY, I
JUST WANT TO SAY THIS IS ONE IN
A SERIES OF SIX BILLS,
OBVIOUSLY, IT POINTS OUT TO SOME
ISSUES THAT WE REALLY, REALLY
NEED TO ADDRESS SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO THIS FOR EVERY ONE OF
THESE TYPE OF IMPORTANT PROJECTS
THAT NEED TO GET DONE, BECAUSE
THAT SEEMS TO BE A THEME THIS
YEAR, IS EVERY OTHER BILL SEEMS
TO BE A CEQA EXEMPTION BILL,
WHICH MEANS SOMETHING WITH CEQA
IS CAUSING PROBLEMS THAT IT
SHOULDN'T BE. SO, I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL, THESE ARE
IMPORTANT PROJECTS THAT NEED TO
GET DONE IN A TIMELY FASHION.
AND WITH THAT, WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY DOLLY, AND YOU MAY
CLOSE. I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, WITH THAT, THIS IS A
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. GO
AHEAD AND CALL ROLL. SENATORS.
MIN SEYARTO. AYE AYE. ALAN.
DALLI. DALLI AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. STERN.
601 CALL. OKAY. WE'RE THAT'S,
HAS SIX VOTES, AND WE'RE GOING
TO LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN, I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE WAITED PATIENTLY PRETTY
MUCH ALL DAY TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THAT'S AB 2716. THAT IS
CORRECT. YOU MAY GO WHEN YOU'RE
READY. WELL, FIRST, MR. VICE
CHAIR, THANK YOU. AND THERE'S
REALLY NO OTHER WAY I'D WANT TO
PRESENT THIS NON-CONTROVERSIAL
BILL THAN TO HAVE YOU HOLDING
THE GAVEL. SIR, I FIGURED AS
MUCH, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2716, A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO, WE
OUTLINED HEALTH SETBACK ZONES
AND COMMUNITIES. 3200FT FROM
WHERE WE EAT, SLEEP, WORK, PLAY,
GO TO THE HOSPITAL, GET THE CARE
THAT WE NEED. WHAT WE FOUND OUT
RECENTLY IN A REPORT IS THAT IN
THAT HEALTH SETBACK ZONE, THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OIL WELLS THAT
ARE DOING LESS THAN 15 BARRELS A
DAY. AND THAT'S A INTERESTING
AMOUNT BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY
ITSELF REFERS TO THOSE AS
STRIPPER WELLS. THOSE ARE WELLS
THAT ARE DOING LESS THAN 15
BARRELS A DAY. WHAT WE ALSO
FOUND OUT FROM THE INDUSTRY IS
THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
THOSE WELLS IS COMPARABLE TO
WELLS THAT ARE DOING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXTRACTION.
SO WHETHER YOU'RE DOING 15
BARRELS OR 1500 BARRELS, YOU ARE
STILL HAVING AN INCREASINGLY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. AND
WHEN I SAY NEGATIVE IMPACT, I
MEAN THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE NEAR
THESE OIL FIELDS, THEY DIE
SOONER. THEY HAVE HIGHER RATES
OF HEART CONDITION. THE CHILDREN
HAVE HIGHER RATES OF ASTHMA.
POOR AIR QUALITY. THEY HAVE
SPILLS. WE HAD A SPILL IN MY
DISTRICT JUST A FEW YEARS AGO.
THAT WAS WITHIN 1000FT OF A
PLAYGROUND. IN FACT, THE LARGEST
URBAN OIL FIELD IN THIS STATE IS
IN MY DISTRICT, THE BALDWIN
HILLS INGLEWOOD OIL FIELD. AND
IT'S RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM KENNY HAHN STATE PARK. SO
IN RECOGNIZING THE DANGERS OF
THESE STRIPPER WELLS AND THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE STRIPPING THE
COMMUNITY OF THEIR LIFE
EXPECTANCY AND VALUABLE HEALTH
RESOURCES, WE PROPOSED THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
FINALLY MAKE THOSE WHO ARE
DECIDING TO DRILL FOR A
RELATIVELY INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT,
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE COST OF
CLEANING IT UP IS GREATER. WE
DECIDED TO CHARGE THEM A DAILY
PENALTY FOR CAUSING THIS KIND OF
HARM TO THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE,
AGAIN, THE ONLY REASON YOU'RE
OPERATING A WELL AT 15 BARRELS A
DAY AND SOME OF THESE WELLS ARE
GENERATING 150 BUCKS A DAY, IS
BECAUSE IT COSTS MORE TO CLEAN
IT UP. WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT
COST CALCULATION. WE HAVE TO
CHANGE IT FOR COMMUNITY. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO DO.
ESSENTIALLY, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
DRILL RIGHT NEXT TO MY
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE, THEN YOU
BETTER BE EXTRACTING ENOUGH OIL
TO LOWER MY GAS PRICES.
OTHERWISE YOU SHOULD CLEAN IT UP
WITH ME. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT JAMIE COURT
FROM CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND KYLE
FERRARA FROM FRACTRACKER
ALLIANCE. SO YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. WONDERFUL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIRPERSON. MIN
Þ ABSENT. I'VE BEEN HERE ALL
DAY. AND DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KYLE
FERRARA. I'M THE WESTERN PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT FRACTRACKER ALLIANCE
. I'VE WORKED THERE CONDUCTING
ACADEMIC RESEARCH ON THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION SINCE 2009. I'M
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2007 16 AND WHY IT IS IMPORTANT
TO PLUG LOW PRODUCING WELLS
IMMEDIATELY RATHER THAN ALLOW
THEM TO POLLUTE COMMUNITIES
WHILE CONTRIBUTING VERY LITTLE
TO CALIFORNIA'S GASOLINE SUPPLY.
IMPOSING A PENALTY ON
UNDER-PRODUCING WELLS POLLUTING
COMMUNITIES WILL ENCOURAGE
OPERATORS TO PLUG THOSE WELLS. I
HAVE SEEN IN DOCUMENTED
FIRSTHAND THE HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS THAT LEAK FROM OIL AND
GAS WELLS. I'VE INSPECTED
HUNDREDS OF WELLS AND DOCUMENTED
MANY DOZENS OF WELL SITES
LEAKING NEAR HOMES AND IN
COMMUNITIES. REPORTS TO THE AIR
DISTRICTS HAVE RESULTED IN
NUMEROUS NOTICES OF VIOLATIONS.
I MUST STRESS THESE LEAKS OCCUR
REGULARLY DUE TO CORROSION AND
DETERIORATION ON LOW PRODUCING
OIL AND GAS WELLS AS A RESULT OF
THE ENVIRONMENT ON THE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THE DATA WITH THE
COMMUNITY, WITH THE COMMITTEE,
RATHER, A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS
WAS THE WELLS RECENTLY
DISCOVERED LEAKING IN
BAKERSFIELD. THE RESULTED IN AN
OIL AND GAS CONTRACTOR
ERRONEOUSLY BLACK FLUSHING CRUDE
OIL AND WASTEWATER INTO THE
CITY'S PUBLIC DRINKING WATER.
THIS WAS THE RESULT OF A LEAK
FROM CORRODED GATHERING LINES
CONNECTING MARGINAL WELLS.
CALCIUM HAD ORDERED THE
OPERATOR, GRIFFIN, TO FIX THE
FLOW LINE CONNECTING 16 WELLS.
AFTER THE 28 LEAKS WERE FOUND,
VENTING FROM THOSE WELLS. IF AB
20 2716 WERE LAW, THE FINES
IMPOSED ON THESE LOW PRODUCING
WELLS MAY HAVE MOTIVATED THE
PRODUCER TO PLUG THE WELLS
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING THEM TO FALL
INTO DISREPAIR AND LEAK FROM THE
WELLHEAD INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS LAW WILL HAVE
A LITTLE IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
OVERALL PRODUCTION OF CRUDE OIL.
MY OWN CALCULATIONS SHOW THAT IN
TOTAL, LESS THAN 8% OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTION COMES FROM
WELLS PRODUCING LESS THAN 15
BARRELS PER DAY. LOCATED WITHIN
THE 3200 FOOT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTION ZONE. AS ESTABLISHED
BY SB 1137. THIS ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT 8000 LOW PRODUCING WELLS
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE PLUGGED TO
AVOID FINES. THIS WILL RESULT IN
THE CREATION OF OILFIELD JOBS
AND WAGES TO PLUG WELLS THAT
WILL FINALLY BE PAID TO OILFIELD
WORKERS, WAGES THAT, UP UNTIL
THIS POINT, HAVE BEEN DENIED TO
WORKERS AND INSTEAD HAVE BEEN
USED TO INCREASE CEO SALARIES
AND INFLATE SHAREHOLDER PROFITS.
IN CONCLUSION, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE
YES ON AB 2716 TO ASSURE THAT
THE COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED
AND TO SEE THAT OILFIELD WORKERS
ARE PAID THEIR DESERVED WAGES TO
PLUG AND ABANDON THESE WELLS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ARE YOU
ANOTHER PRIMARY SPEAKER IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL? I AM WELL, THEN,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. ALSO, I'M
JAMIE COURT. I'M PRESIDENT OF
CONSUMER WATCHDOG, I WANTED TO,
AMPLIFY SOMETHING THAT KYLE
SAID. LOW PRODUCING WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCE ONLY 8% OF
THE OIL THAT GOES IN TO CRUDE OR
EXPORTED IN THE STATE. THE
AVERAGE OIL WELL IN CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES, THREE BARRELS PER DAY,
WHICH IS NOT VERY MUCH WHEN YOU
CONSIDER IT'S 42 GALLONS IN A
BARREL IN COMMUNITIES IN THE
COMMUNITY SETBACK ZONE, THE
AVERAGE OIL WELL IS PRODUCING
TWO BARRELS A DAY, TWO BARRELS A
DAY, 83% OF THE WELLS IN THE
COMMUNITY. SETBACK ZONE PRODUCE
LESS THAN 15 BARRELS A DAY,
WHICH IS WHAT A STRIPPER WELL,
IS. SO WE ARE WITH THIS BILL
LIMITING UNPRODUCTIVE WELLS THAT
DON'T CONTRIBUTE TO OUR CRUDE
OIL SUPPLY, BUT DO CONTRIBUTE TO
COMMUNITY DEGRADATION OF HEALTH,
I HOPE YOU ALL NEVER HAVE ANYONE
IN YOUR FAMILY WHO IS LIKE NIALL
COBO. NIALL COBO GREW UP 30FT
FROM AN OIL WELL AND SHE, AT THE
AGE OF NINE, GOT VERY SEVERE
ASTHMA, VERY SEVERE ASTHMA. BY
THE AGE OF 16, SHE GOT OVARIAN
CANCER. SHE GOT RID OF THE WELL.
SHE CALLED A GROUP CALLED PEOPLE
NOT POZOS, AND SHE GOT RID OF
THE WELL IN HER COMMUNITY. BUT
BY 24 SHE LOST HER ABILITY TO
GIVE BIRTH BECAUSE SHE HAD TO
DEAL WITH HER OVARIAN CANCER,
ALL FOR A WELL, THAT WAS NOT
PRODUCING VERY MUCH OIL. THIS
LEGISLATURE SET BOUNDARIES. WE
SAID THE LATE STATE SAID WE ARE
NOT GOING TO CREATE ANY MORE
PERMITS FOR NEW WELLS WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF A COMMUNITY. THE
OIL INDUSTRY PUT A REFERENDUM ON
THE BALLOT TO CHALLENGE THAT.
AND NOW THIS BILL WILL SAY, OKAY
, WHATEVER HAPPENS WITH THAT
REFERENDUM, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A WELL, THAT'S NOT
PRODUCING MUCH OIL, BUT IS
PRODUCING A LOT OF HEALTH, A LOT
OF HEALTH IMPACTS THAT WELL
SHOULD BE FINED TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S NOT VIABLE FOR IT TO
BE WORKING. THANK YOU. I REALLY,
ON BEHALF OF NAYELI AND CONSUMER
WATCHDOG, I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. ALL RIGHT. AT THIS POINT,
WE'LL TAKE THE METOOS FOR THOSE
THAT ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL,
TINA GALLAGHER, FOR 350
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. VICTORIA.
ROME WITH NRDC AND SUPPORT.
GABRIELA FARSI WITH YOUR CLUB.
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO REPRESENTING
MY FAMILY THAT STILL LIVES IN
BAKERSFIELD TODAY, SOME OF WHICH
LIVE HUNDREDS OF YARDS AWAY FROM
THESE OIL WELLS. SO IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT, CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT, CARMEN GUZMAN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA, AND
STRONG SUPPORT, SANTIAGO
RODRIGUEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. KIM STONE I HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF SUPPORTERS TO
HOW LARGE LARGE ENOUGH LARGE.
I'LL GO AS FAST LIKE 150 PEOPLE.
NOT THAT LONG, NOT THAT LONG.
1000 GRANDMOTHERS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. I WILL NOT NAME
THEM. 350 BAY AREA ACTION 350
CORNEJO SAN FERNANDO VALLEY 350
SOUTH BAY, LOS ANGELES 350
VENTURA COUNTY CLIMATE HUB
BREAST CANCER ACTION CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE VOTERS, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE, CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK, CENTRAL COAST
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS, CITIZENS
CLIMATE LOBBY, SANTA CRUZ
CHAPTER. CLIMATE FIRST REPLACING
OIL AND GAS. CLIMATE HAWKS VOTE
CLIMATE HEALTH NOW, CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT SAN FRANCISCO
POLICY ACTION, CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT LOS ANGELES CHAPTER,
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT, SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY COMMUNITY OOPS,
WE ALREADY GOT HER COMMUNITY.
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY, ELDERS, CLIMATE
ACTION, NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER, ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO PROTECT
AMERICA COLD BLUE BLUE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP,
EXTINCTION REBELLION, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA FOOD AND
WATER WATCH, FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA, FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH, GLENDALE ENVIRONMENTAL
COALITION, GREENPEACE,
INDIVISIBLE, CALIFORNIA, GREEN
TEAM, INDIVISIBLE, MARIN,
MANHATTAN BEACH, HUDDLE, OIL AND
GAS ACTION NETWORK, PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, LOS
ANGELES, PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, SACRAMENTO,
PRESENTE.ORG, RESOURCE RENEWAL
INSTITUTE, ROOTS ACTION, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY, PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, SAN
FRANCISCO, BAYKEEPER, SAN
FRANCISCO CLIMATE EMERGENCY
COALITION, SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
DEMOCRATIC CLUB, SAN DIEGO, 350
SANTA BARBARA STANDING ROCK
COALITION, SANTA CRUZ CLIMATE
ACTION NETWORK SOCAL 350.
CLIMATE ACTION STAND.EARTH
SUNFLOWER ALLOWANCE ALLIANCE,
SUSTAINABLE MILL VALLEY, THE
CLIMATE CENTER, TRANSFORMATIVE
WEALTH MANAGEMENT, A PROFESSOR
FROM BERKELEY, VOTE SOLAR WEST,
LA DEMOCRATIC CLUB. THAT'S IT.
ARE YOU SURE? ARE THERE ANY
MORE? NO OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
ANY OTHER PERSONS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COME UP AND SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS? ONLY YOUR
NAME AND YOUR. OH, WAIT, WE
HAVEN'T EVEN DONE THE OP. THAT
WAS THE SUPPORT. MY BAD,
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THAT ARE
PRIMARY WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. PAUL DIEGO WITH WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL. AS
AS THE AUTHOR EXPLAINED, THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF HIGH PRODUCING
WELLS, LOWER PRODUCING WELLS.
THEY ARE ALL ECONOMICAL. THEY
ARE ALL REGULATED. THEY ARE ALL
TESTED, THERE IS NO DISTINCTION
ON THE, THE, THE CONSTRUCTION
STANDARD OF A WELL PRODUCING
LESS THAN 15 BARRELS A DAY
VERSUS A WELL, THAT'S PRODUCING
100 BARRELS A DAY, SO IT'S WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE THESE WELLS
ARE VALUABLE. THEY'RE ASSETS.
AND THE MANDATING SHUTTING THEM
DOWN IS SOMETHING WE ARE OPPOSED
TO. WE ARE WORKING AND HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH HIM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
PRIMARY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION?
ARE YOU THE TWO MINUTE PRIMARY?
YES. HE IS. OKAY. COME ON UP.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
MY NAME IS JONATHAN GREGORY. I'M
THE CEO OF MATRIX OIL
CORPORATION. I'M ALSO THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION, OR CPA, AS SOME OF
YOU KNOW, IT, ALSO HAPPENED TO
LIVE IN SENATOR ALLEN'S DISTRICT
IN SANTA MONICA, WHERE I'M
ACTUALLY ON THE BOARD OF THE
SANTA MONICA BLACK EMPOWERMENT
ASSOCIATION. I'M HERE TODAY
PRIMARILY ON BEHALF OF MY 16
EMPLOYEES. WE'RE A SMALL COMPANY
. I'M ALSO HERE FOR CPA AND HIS
350 COMPANIES. I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2716. MY
COMPANY OPERATES 150 PROPERLY
PERMITTED CLIMATE COMPLIANT
WELLS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. 90%
OF THOSE WELLS, 90% ARE LESS
THAN 15 BARRELS A DAY. AND FOR
THE RECORD, AT CURRENT PRICES OF
15 BARREL A DAY, WELL, THE NET
PROFIT IS OVER $200,000 A YEAR.
IT'S NOT UNPROFITABLE. IT'S VERY
ECONOMIC AND IT'S ENOUGH FOR ME
TO PAY MY EMPLOYEES A VERY GOOD
WAGE. ANOTHER FACT ABOUT OUR
COMPANY 80% OF OUR COMPANY Ã
MINORITIES, BLACK AND LATINO.
MAYBE THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT BIG
OIL. I'M NOT BIG OIL. I'M SMALL
COMPANY. I'M A SMALL BUSINESS
PUTTING MONEY BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THE COMMUNITY OF LA
HABRA HEIGHTS. WE OPERATE. WE
PUT OVER $1 MILLION A YEAR BACK
INTO THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE IN
THAT COMMUNITY. WE SPONSOR THEIR
MUSIC FESTIVALS, WE SPONSOR
THEIR EASTER EGG HUNT. WE TAKE
GOOD CARE OF THAT COMMUNITY. WE
WERE THE LARGEST TAXPAYER TO
THAT CITY. THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU THIS BILL WOULD PUT OUR
COMPANY OUT OF BUSINESS
COMPLETELY. WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU PUT US OUT OF BUSINESS, OR
YOU INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
IDLE WELLS, WHICH WE'RE TRYING
TO ALL AVOID? YOU ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE PROBABILITY OF MORE
ORPHAN WELLS, WHICH WE ALL WANT
TO AVOID. NÓ CASH FLOW CAN'T DO
NOTHING. WE NEED CASH FLOW IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
WELLS AND OF THESE PEOPLE. SO
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WRAP UP,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. AS I WRAP UP,
WHAT I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
ARE THE LIVES THAT ARE
IMMEDIATELY IMPACTED. YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT ONE SIDE OF IT. I
GET IT, BUT THINK ABOUT THE
GENERATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED WHO WORK IN THESE
FIELDS. MOSTLY THE
DISADVANTAGED, THE ONES YOU
ALWAYS SAY YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF
. MOST OF THE LATINO BLACK,
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOBS. THOSE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO
BE HURT AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HURT IMMEDIATELY. VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY.
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE
MEWTWO'S IN OPPOSITION. JUST
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU REPRESENT AND HOPEFULLY
ONLY ONE. AND, AND, WHETHER OR
THAT YOU OPPOSE THE BILL,
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GREAT. IF
THERE'S NO OTHERS, WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS FOR
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS, CONCERNS.
WE'LL START WITH, SENATOR STERN.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR,
SORRY. WE HAVE TO BE IN THIS
POSITION HERE, WHERE WHERE A
BILL LIKE THIS IS NECESSARY. I
DEEPLY RESPECT THAT YOU ARE
REFUSING TO ACCEPT THE STATUS
QUO, AND THAT WE HAVE TO SORT OF
FORCE THIS UNCOMFORTABLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT TO DO
WITH NOT JUST THE WELLS THAT GET
LEFT BEHIND, BUT THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE GETTING LEFT BEHIND. I'M
PROUDLY A COAUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE, BUT I WOULD JUST, I
GUESS I WOULD BE CURIOUS. EAGER
FROM THE OPPOSITION
SPECIFICALLY. AS TO WHETHER,
SUCH A BILL WOULD BE.
NECESSARILY IN CONFLICT OR EVEN
A PROBLEM IF YOU WERE ASSURED
THAT THE WELLS THAT YOU
CURRENTLY DO OPERATE, LIKE IN LA
HABRA HIGH HEIGHTS, IF THOSE
WELLS WOULDN'T BE, SAY, SHUT
DOWN, AUTOMATICALLY BY WHAT I
THINK IS ACTUALLY A FLAWED
INTERPRETATION OF SB 1137, BUT
INSTEAD THAT YOU'D BE ALLOWED TO
MAINTAIN THOSE WELLS, UNDER THE
SAFETY EXEMPTION. THAT'S WITHIN
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE THAT I
THINK IS OFTEN LOST ON FOLKS. SO
MY QUESTION IS NOT SO MUCH FOR
THE AUTHOR, BUT, TO THE
OPPOSITION IN SEARCHING FOR SOME
KIND OF BROADER COMPROMISE HERE,
I GET THAT WE'RE DEBATING THIS
SORT OF NARROW BILL, BUT IN THE
CONTEXT OF BOTH THIS BILL AND
THEN THE LARGER FRAMEWORK OF
OPPOSITION, HAS ANY INSIGHTS, IF
I MAY, MR. VICE CHAIR, I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR THAT, BECAUSE I DO
WORRY ABOUT THE FOLKS WHO, WORK
IN THESE INDUSTRIES. I THINK
IT'S A REAL THING. I THINK THE
AUTHOR DOES AS WELL. IN FACT, I
KNOW HE DOES BECAUSE HE'S WORKED
ON JUST TRANSITION FUNDS, WORKED
ON JOB TRAINING. I THINK THERE'S
HUGE POTENTIAL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO TAKE THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN THESE FIELDS AND TO
GET BETTER AT PLUGGING AND
ABANDONMENT OF WELLS. WE'RE NOT
USING, TO GROW, IN FACT, THE
WORKFORCE, BY CLEANING UP OUR
COMMUNITIES, BUT WITHOUT TAKING
AWAY THAT SORT OF THOSE, THOSE,
THESE WELLS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. SO IF I MAY, MR.
CHAIR. THAT'S ALL RIGHT. WE'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM OPPOSITION AS
TO WHETHER, DESPITE YOUR
OPPOSITION, YOU HAVE ANY, ANY
CAUSE FOR HOPE HERE. IF THERE'S
ANY OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR A
BROADER COMPROMISE OR IF YOU
THINK THAT, WE'RE SORT OF JUST
GOING TO STAY IN OUR CORNERS AND
PROCEED, PAUL DARROW
REPRESENTING WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION, A DECENT
QUESTION. WE THE PREMISE OF THE
BILL FROM WHAT I GATHER, IS THAT
WELLS THAT PRODUCE 15 BARRELS OR
LESS A DAY ARE MORE THREATENING
TO COMMUNITIES THAN WELLS THAT
ARE PRODUCING, PRODUCING 150
BARRELS A DAY. THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
THE CASE. IF THERE ARE IF THEY
ARE LEAKING, THEY ARE. THEY ARE
TESTED BY CAL JAM AND REGULATED.
AND IF THEY ARE LEAKING, YOU
SHUT THEM DOWN. I MEAN, I THINK
THE LARGER PROBLEM WE HAVE IN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT THESE WELLS
AND NOT IDLE WELLS PER SE, BUT
ORPHAN WELLS. WE HAVE 5300
ORPHAN WELLS THAT DON'T HAVE A
DESIGNATED OWNER THAT CAN PLUG
AND ABANDON THESE ORPHAN WELLS
THAT ARE NO LONGER PRODUCING
OIL. AND I AND WE WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THAT. WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS A MAJOR ISSUE. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
LOOKS LIKE ALLEN AND EGGMAN ARE
POINTING AT EACH OTHER. WHO'S
GOING FIRST HERE? OKAY, SENATOR
EGGMAN WANTS TO HAVE THE FINAL
WORD AFTER ME. I DON'T KNOW.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
ALREADY EXPRESSED TO YOU THAT, I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. AND I HEARD YOUR
CONTINUING TO BE IN
CONVERSATIONS, AND WE'LL LOOK
FOR THAT LATER. I'M ALSO JUST. I
FEEL LIKE WE, YOU KNOW, I
REPRESENT AN AREA THAT THAT USES
A LOT OF GAS, RIGHT. TRUCKS AND
TRACTORS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I, YOU KNOW, AND SORRY, EVERYONE
GETS TO HEAR MY, MY LOOK BACK ON
12 YEARS, BUT A LOT OF THE
THINGS WE'VE DONE IN, IN 12
YEARS TIME HAVE, HAVE WE'VE LOST
A LOT OF OUR SMALLER FARMS, A
LOT OF THE REGULATIONS AND LAWS
WE PASS HAVE MADE A LOT OF OUR
SMALLER FARMS GO AWAY, FOR
ECONOMY REASONS AND GONE TO THE
BIGGER ONES. AND AS SOMEBODY WHO
GREW UP IN A SMALL FARMING
FAMILY, IT MAKES ME SAD, AND I
JUST SEE THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO
THIS WITH DIFFERENT, INDUSTRIES
WITH OIL. RIGHT? I MEAN, AND
WE'RE PHASING OUT. WE'RE ON OUR
WAY OUT. I WAS JUST AT A
CONFERENCE THIS, THIS LAST
WEEKEND ON TRANSPORTATION, WHERE
WE TALKED ABOUT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE AT, BY 2030, 30% UPTICK ON
ON EV CARS. I DRIVE AN EV CAR
PLUG IN HYBRID, BUT WE'RE STILL,
LIKE, AT 23 WITH NO, WITH OUR
UPTICK NOT GOING UP, AND WE'RE
STILL, BEST SELLING VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA REMAIN TRUCKS AND
SUVS. SO CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIOR
CONTINUES TO LAG BEHIND. AND SO
WE STILL NEED WE STILL NEED OUR
GAS AND OIL FOR NOW, AND I JUST
THINK GOING AFTER THESE SMALL
ONES THAT ARE NOT PRODUCING THAT
MUCH IS, AGAIN, JUST ANOTHER WAY
OF PUTTING THIS SMALLER GUYS OUT
OF BUSINESS. WHEN I AGREE, THE
ORPHAN WELLS THAT WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT FOREVER ARE, ARE THE BIG
ISSUE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO GO
AFTER, I THINK WITH MORE VIGOR.
SO THAT'S MY POSITION FOR TODAY,
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE. WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS, BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT YOU TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EGGMAN. WE HAVE ALAN,
THEN WE HAVE HURTADO, DALLEY AND
GROVE. I JUST LOVE TO GIVE THE,
AUTHOR THE CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY,
MY CONSTITUENT. I SUPPOSE, FROM,
TALKING ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ASPECT OF THIS, OF
THIS CONVERSATION AND HOW HOW
YOUR DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN GOING
AND HOW YOU, HOW HOW YOU, HOW
YOU RESPOND TO THOSE KINDS OF
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED. YEAH.
NO. FIRST, I'M REALLY GLAD TO
HEAR THAT EVERYBODY IS GOING
AFTER ORPHAN WELLS BECAUSE I
HAVE A COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA WHO HAS A BILL COMING
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS JUST THAT. NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WERE MENTIONED BY
THE OPPOSITION WAS WAS SAID IN
READING THE BILL, WHICH PERHAPS
THEY HAVE NOT FULLY READ THE
BILL THAT I AM SUGGESTING, THAT
WELLS THAT PRODUCE LESS ARE MORE
DANGEROUS. THAT IS NOT AT ALL
WHAT I'M SUGGESTING. I'M
SUGGESTING THEY ARE EQUALLY
DANGEROUS AND THEY'RE GETTING NO
OIL. THAT'S A DIFFERENT CONTEXT
FOR COMMUNITIES. IT'S A
DIFFERENT REASON FOR THE IMPETUS
OF THIS BILL, I APPRECIATE MR.
GREGORY. WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS. THE G. AND ISAAC
G. BRIAN IS GREGORY, BY THE WAY,
FOR FOLKS AT HOME WHO DIDN'T
KNOW THAT. SO YOU GUYS COUSINS
WE ACTUALLY WE FOUND THAT OUT ON
A PLANE FLIGHT THE OTHER DAY,
AND I FORGOT TO MENTION WHO I'M
HERE REPRESENTING. WHICH IS,
DEEP RESPECT FOR THE 14,
EMPLOYEES OF HIS OPERATION.
THERE ARE 2.7 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE WITHIN
3200FT OF THESE WELLS. THERE ARE
OVER 500,000 PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT, HALF OF WHOM ARE BLACK
AND BROWN, WHO LIVE NEXT TO THIS
INGLEWOOD OIL FIELD. I'M
THINKING OF FRAN DUMONT, WHO IS
A MATRIARCH OF BLACK LOS ANGELES
WHO LOST HER HUSBAND, BERNIE.
AND WHEN I SEE HER AND WE TALK
ABOUT THE OIL FIELD, IT BRINGS
TEARS TO HER EYES BECAUSE BERNIE
WAS A RUNNER. BERNIE NEVER
SMOKED. BERNIE WAS HEALTHY. AND
THE REASON HE DIED OF
RESPIRATORY ISSUES, SHE FIRMLY
BELIEVES IN, THE DOCTORS
BELIEVED IS RELATED TO THIS
FIELD THAT THEY LIVED RIGHT NEXT
TO, ON TO OVERLAND. AND SO, AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY MY
SUPPORTING WITNESSES AND OTHERS,
MANY TIMES, THERE ARE MORE JOBS
AND CLEANING UP SOME OF THESE
FIELDS. I'M NOT ALSO TELLING YOU
THAT YOU HAVE TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS OR STOP DOING IT. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO RUN A
STRIPPER, WELL, YOU CAN RUN IT
FOR FOREVER. YOU WILL JUST PAY A
PENALTY BECAUSE THERE IS A COST
TO THE DAMAGE THAT YOU ARE DOING
TO COMMUNITY. AND I THINK MR.
GREGORY RAISED A GREAT POINT. I
DO WANT TO LOOK AT WHERE THAT
PENALTY GOES, BECAUSE I THINK IT
SHOULD HAVE A DIRECT BENEFIT FOR
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED. SO WE CAN STILL
SPONSOR THE SOCCER TEAMS AND
STILL SPONSOR THE FLAG FOOTBALL
TEAMS AND STILL DO THAT
RIGHTEOUS COMMUNITY WORK. SO I'M
HAPPY TO BE INSPIRED TO LOOK AT
THOSE KIND OF AMENDMENTS GOING
FORWARD. BUT THAT WOULD BE MY
RESPONSE IS THAT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO PUT ANYONE OUT OF
BUSINESS. WE'RE NOT GOING TO PUT
ANYBODY OUT OF BUSINESS. WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS PROMOTE
HEALTH, WELLBEING AND
OPPORTUNITY IN ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND JUST AND NOT JUST THE
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
LIVE RIGHT NEXT TO NEIGHBORHOOD
DRILLING. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE'LL
MOVE TO HURTADO, THEN DALY, THEN
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RYAN, THERE ARE
CONCEPTS IN YOUR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT I CAN
COMPLETELY SIGN ON TO AND
SUPPORT, HOWEVER, OVER THE LAST
YEARS, I KNOW THAT MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES, MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ANTITRUST ISSUES IN AGRICULTURE
SPECIFICALLY. AND THIS YEAR I'VE
KIND OF CHALLENGED MYSELF AND
TAKEN IT MORE, MORE BROAD, LIKE
EXPANDING, THE, THE WORK THAT
I'VE DONE ON ANTITRUST ISSUES
TO, TO, TO OTHER AREAS. AND, YOU
KNOW, I FIRMLY, BEEN TAKING LIKE
A TOUGH POSITION ON ANY KIND OF
LEGISLATION THAT I SEEK THAT
COULD CREATE MARKET
CONCENTRATION. AND UNFORTUNATELY
, I THINK THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT WILL DO JUST
THAT. AND I UNDERSTAND THE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS, IS
GOOD. IT'S I THINK WE ALL CAN
AGREE ON THAT, THAT WE THAT'S WE
WANT TO DO GOOD FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES, FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, BUT I ALSO KNOW
THAT PEOPLE ARE HURTING ACROSS
THE STATE WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
POCKETBOOKS. AND WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING MARKET CONCENTRATION
WITHIN THE OIL INDUSTRY ALREADY.
I JUST I DO STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL FURTHER, CREATE
CONSOLIDATION. AND THAT'S NOT
GOOD FOR THE CONSUMER, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S A SITUATION
WHERE, LIKE, YOU'RE IF YOU DO,
IF YOU DON'T EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE,
BUT, I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
HERE. AND WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
THAT HAPPEN WITHOUT THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. AND, AND I HOPE
THAT IN THE FUTURE THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS AND THAT
I CAN SUPPORT THEM. BUT ON THIS
MEASURE AT THE MOMENT, I WILL
JUST I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR HURTADO, SENATOR
DALLI, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. SENATOR MEMBER.
SO I SAID ON SUB TWO, WHERE WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT CAL CHEN. SO I
JUST WANT TO START THERE BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THERE'S, SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY DO SOME
GOOD WORK IN THE AREA THAT
YOU'RE WANTING TO FOCUS ON. SO,
EVERY YEAR THE OIL INDUSTRY PAYS
INTO A FUND TO SHUT DOWN ORPHAN
WELLS AND CAL CHEN HAS TRIED TO
HIRE PEOPLE OVER THE YEARS THAT
EVERY YEAR WE INCREASE THE
BUDGET TAX, OIL DRIES UP THE
COST OF OIL FOR CALIFORNIANS.
BUT TO GO DO THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO GET DONE ON THOSE ORPHAN
WELLS. SO I WANT TO JUST SAY
THAT I THINK THERE'S A PROBLEM
AT CAL CHEN AND GETTING THE WORK
DONE AT THE PACE AND SCALE. WE
NEED TO GET IT DONE. NUMBER ONE,
NOW I WANT TO FOCUS ON AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE ALL
SHOULD BE WORKING ON. WE ALL
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
BECAUSE THE OIL INDUSTRY HAS
STEPPED UP AND PUT THE MONEY
FORTH ON WELLS THAT THEY DIDN'T
GET A PROFIT OFF OF, AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW, AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY BEEN
FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT WE HAVE
EVERY YEAR INCREASE THAT AND WE
DON'T GET THE WORK DONE. IT'S
WRONG AND IT'S IMPACTING THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S THOSE
ORPHAN WELLS. AND FORTUNATELY I
DON'T HAVE ANY OIL IN MY
DISTRICT. I HAVE NATURAL GAS,
BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY OIL IN MY
DISTRICT THAT I'M AWARE OF. NOW.
I WANT TO CHANGE GEARS A LITTLE
BIT, AND I WANT TO THANK THE
GENTLEMAN THAT CAME, THAT MR.
GREGORY, FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I'M
A SMALL FARMER, AND I WANT TO
JUST. I'VE BEEN HERE 12 YEARS.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I'VE DONE
IN THE 12 YEARS. NOTHING TO SAVE
MY FARM. I'VE NEGOTIATED THE
DEATH OF MY BUSINESS WHEN IT
COMES TO PESTICIDES, WHEN IT
COMES TO MILL TAXES COMING
THROUGH, WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR,
WHEN IT COMES TO COST OF ENERGY.
I'M AN ORGANIC SEED FARMER. I'M
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
CALIFORNIA. I'M TAKING CARE OF
LAND THAT'S BEEN IN THE FAMILY
FOR 93 YEARS, AND I'M GLAD YOU
CAME AND TESTIFIED, BECAUSE WE
NEED TO HEAR THOSE STORIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE REAL. YOU'RE NOT
THE PROBLEM. THE BIG GUY IS
GOING TO ABSORB IT. HE'S GOING
TO MAKE MONEY, AND THE SMALL GUY
IS GOING TO GET CRUSHED. IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE GOING TO USE THAT PRODUCT.
THIS IS THE POINT I WANT TO
MAKE. I THINK THE BIGGEST THING
THAT WE MISS IS THAT WE'RE
DESTROYING ALL THESE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS OUT THERE, AND
IT'S NOT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHO'S TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING TO I HEAR I WANT YOU WANT
A SAFE, YOU WANT SOMETHING SAFE.
YOU WANT YOUR COMMUNITY SAFE. I
GET THAT I WANT TO EAT SAFE
FOOD. WE HAVE THE BEST LAWS IN
THE WORLD IN CALIFORNIA FOR
FOOD, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, I'M NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THEM
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE PRICING ME
OUT. I'M COMPETING WITH CHINA.
I'M COMPETING WITH NEVADA,
OREGON, WASHINGTON, AND THEY'RE
SHIPPING THE PRODUCTS THAT I
MAKE IN HERE FOR CHEAPER THAN I
CAN MAKE THEM FOR, BECAUSE I'M
REGULATED TO DEATH. AND THEY'RE
ALSO COMING FROM MEXICO AND
THEY'RE COVERED IN PESTICIDES
AND HERBICIDES AND ALL THE
THINGS WE DON'T WANT. AND
THEY'RE VERY CHEAP LABOR THERE
AND ALL THE WATER THEY WANT, AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS WE HAVE AND
THEIR CARBON FOOTPRINT IS HUGE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THROW OUT
THAT. I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY AND
THE SENATOR STERN ASKED THE
QUESTION, HOW CAN YOU NEGOTIATE
A BETTER DEAL FOR YOURSELF? THAT
IS REALLY WHAT YOU WANT TO SAY.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU GUYS OF
HOW WE HOW WE MITIGATE. SO WHAT
HE'S REALLY SAYING TO YOU IS
YOU'RE GOING TO NEGOTIATE THE
DEATH OF YOUR BUSINESS. YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT,
BECAUSE TODAY YOU'RE IN A BIND.
YOU'RE EITHER GOING TO BE OUT OF
BUSINESS OR YOU'RE GOING TO
NEGOTIATE THE DEATH OF IT. SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S BEEN
VERY FRUSTRATING FOR ME AS A
SMALL FARMER WATCHING, WATCHING
ME HAVE TO NEGOTIATE THE DEATH
OF MY BUSINESS. IT'S WE'RE GOING
TO PHASE IN THE OVERTIME FOR YOU
GUYS. WE'RE GOING TO PHASE IN
THIS. BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
YOU STILL GET IT. FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW OR FOUR YEARS FROM NOW,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE OUT OF
BUSINESS. SO I THINK THERE HAS
TO BE A BROADER DISCUSSION. HOW
DO WE SAVE THE NEIGHBORHOOD?
LET'S FIRST GO AFTER THE MONEY
THAT'S OUT THERE RIGHT NOW AND
PLUG THE WELLS THAT ARE
ORPHANED, THAT WE KNOW ARE OUT
THERE, THAT THAT TO ME, SHOULD
BE A PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S NOT. I BRING IT UP EVERY
YEAR. SO TO THE AUTHOR, I HEAR
YOU TO THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER,
I HEAR YOU. THERE HAS TO BE
SOMETHING BETTER THAN TO RUN YOU
OUT OF BUSINESS. AND THERE HAS
TO BE SOMETHING BETTER THAN TO
MAKE YOUR PEOPLE SICK IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. THE REGULATIONS ARE
THERE. THEY'RE IN PLACE. YOU'RE
ABIDING BY THEM. BUT TO SAY THAT
JUST BECAUSE YOU ONLY PRODUCE 15
BARRELS OF DAY, OR THREE BARRELS
OR WHATEVER IT IS, IS WRONG. I
ONLY PRODUCE 400,000 POUNDS. AND
THERE'S GUYS THAT PRODUCE
MILLIONS OF POUNDS. WHY SHOULD I
HAVE TO PAY THE BURDEN FOR THAT?
NO, I SHOULDN'T, AND I WILL
GUARANTEE YOU THIS. I DO A
BETTER JOB OF TAKING CARE OF MY
LAND THAN THEY DO, AND I DO A
BETTER JOB FOR THE ENVIRONMENT,
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE. I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY. WE GOT TO COME
UP WITH SOMETHING BETTER. A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH THAT
WORKS. AND FOR GOD'S SAKE, LET'S
GO PLUG THOSE ORPHAN WELLS WHERE
THERE'S MONEY TO GO. DO IT AND
MAKE MAKE THE GALGIANI MAKE IT
HAPPEN. THANK YOU, SENATOR DALY,
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY IS TRYING TO GET
ACCOMPLISHED HERE, AND. BUT I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
REGARDING SOME COMMENTS THAT YOU
WERE MADE IN THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
IN YOUR BILL. SURE, THERE WAS A
COMMENT THAT YOU WANTED TO DRIVE
MR. GREGORY OUT OF BUSINESS, AND
YOU SAID, NO, YOU ARE NOT
DRIVING MR. GREGORY OUT OF
BUSINESS. IF YOU PRODUCE. AND I
WROTE IT AS FAST AS I COULD, IF
YOU PRODUCE LESS THAN 15, 15
BARRELS A DAY OR LESS, THEN YOU
WILL PAY A FINE. IS THAT WHAT
YOU SAID? CORRECT. AND IN FACT,
IF YOU CAN PRODUCE MORE THAN 15
BARRELS A DAY, YOU WON'T. OKAY,
SO THEN I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
MR. GREGORY THROUGH THE CHAIR.
YES, YES. SORRY MR. GREGORY, YOU
MAY ANSWER THE QUESTION. MY
APOLOGIES. I WAS USED TO GIVING
THE GAVEL AWAY, SO. BUT I'LL
KEEP IT JUST TO USE A
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION, YOU HAVE
SEVERAL WELLS, 90. YOU SAID THAT
WOULD BE A SET FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BE TAKEN OUT OF PRODUCTION. IS
THAT TRUE? THAT'S TRUE. OKAY, SO
JUST BASED ON WHAT THE CHAIR
JUST SAID OR EXCUSE ME, THE
AUTHOR JUST SAID YOU CAN EITHER
TAKE YOUR TEN BARRELS A DAY OR
15 BARRELS A DAY AND PRODUCE
THAT. AND AT $60 A BARREL, IT'S
365 DAYS A YEAR. THAT'S ROUGHLY
$219,000 A YEAR TO. AND IF IT'S
$80 A BARREL, IT'S LIKE $350,000
A YEAR. I NEED YOU TO TELL ME AS
A BUSINESS OWNER, WHEN YOU PAY
PAYROLL TAXES, WORKERS COMP
LIABILITY INSURANCE AND ALL
THESE THINGS THAT YOU DO JOBBERS
TO TRANSPORT THE OIL TO THE, YOU
KNOW, TO THE REFINERIES, ALL OF
THAT. I NEED YOU TO TELL ME HOW
YOU WOULD TAKE A $10,000 A DAY.
FINE TIMES 365 DAYS A YEAR,
WHICH IS $36,500,000, AND PAY
THAT FINE OUT OF WHAT YOU MAKE
ON THESE $15,000 AND NOT GO OUT
OF BUSINESS. WELL, AS YOU'RE
STATING THE MATH DOESN'T WORK.
OKAY, SIR, DOES THE MATH WORK? I
THINK THE MORE INTERESTING PART
ABOUT THAT IS, IS MR. GREGORY AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT EVEN THE SMALL
PRODUCERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA, OR
EVEN THE MEMBERS OF SIPAH
REPRESENT AND I SIT NEXT TO
SIGNAL HILL AND SENTINEL PEAK IN
LOS ANGELES. SENTINEL PEAK SITS
ON 1600 ACRES OF LAND. IT'S THE
LARGEST MEMBER OF SIPAH. THAT'S
THE LARGEST URBAN OIL FIELD IN
THE COUNTRY, IS A MEMBER OF THE
SMALL BATCH OIL PRODUCERS. NOW,
I EMPATHIZE WITH MR. GREGORY,
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HAVING DEEP
CONVERSATIONS. BUT MR. GREGORY,
FOR MORE THAN ONE REASON, IS AN
ANOMALY IN SIPAH. AND HE'S BEEN
BROUGHT HERE TODAY TO BRING THAT
EXAMPLE THAT I HEAR HEARTFELT
PLEA, AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TALKING. BUT THE IDEA
THAT SMALL PRODUCERS WILL BE PUT
OUT OF BUSINESS IS JUST SIMPLY
NOT TRUE. MR. GREGORY'S UNIQUE
AND PERSONAL BUSINESS DECISIONS
THAT LED HIM TO COME HERE SIX
YEARS AGO TO PURCHASE THIS
COMPANY ARE BETWEEN HIM AND THE
BUSINESS MOTIVATIONS OF THE
OVERALL CALIFORNIA CLIMATE. BUT
I'M SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT THIS
BILL MIGHT MEAN FOR HIS PERSONAL
INVESTMENT IN THIS OIL COMPANY.
AND THAT'S WHY OUR CONVERSATIONS
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE. SO I'M ON
MY OWN TIME, MR. CHAIR. SO MR.
CAHILL PRODUCES HE HAS NINE
WELLS, 4.5 WELLS IS THE HIGHEST
PRODUCTION, 12.23 AND THEN 3.7
BARRELS PER DAY, IT WAS HIS
GRANDFATHER'S PASSED DOWN TO HIS
FATHER, PASSED DOWN TO HIM. AND
JUST LIKE YOU PUT ON A SUIT
EVERY DAY AND YOU COME TO THIS
BUILDING AND GO TO WORK MONDAY
THROUGH THURSDAY, AND I'VE SEEN
YOU AT THE AIRPORT, YOUR
T-SHIRT, JEANS, GO HOME, BUT
JUST LIKE YOU PUT ON A SUIT
EVERY DAY AND YOU DO THIS JOB.
THAT'S MR. CAHILL'S JOB. IT'S
PAID FOR HIS HOME, HIS COLLEGE
EDUCATION, HIS TWO EMPLOYEES,
HIS KIDS COLLEGE EDUCATION,
THEIR CARS. IT'S JUST A JOB.
JUST LIKE WE HAVE. MR. CAHILL
COULD NOT PAY THAT $10,000 A
DAY. FINE. AND THESE ARE OLD
WELLS THAT PRODUCE. TO SAY THAT
HAVING 15 BARRELS A DAY OR LESS
AT, YOU KNOW, DEPENDING ON THE
PRICE OF OIL THAT'S NOT SET IN
KERN COUNTY OR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, IT'S A GLOBAL PRICE
SET. THEY CAN MAKE ANYWHERE
BETWEEN $100,000 A YEAR TO
$500,000 A YEAR. AND IF YOU HAVE
SEVERAL OF THESE WELLS, THAT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL COMPANY, A
SUBSTANTIAL SMALL COMPANY. I
BELIEVE MR. GREGORY HAS 16
EMPLOYEES. I COULD BE WRONG,
HE'S NODDING. YES, 16 EMPLOYEES,
ONE OF THEM IS HERE TODAY
THROUGH THE CHAIR. COULD I ASK
HIM A QUESTION? IS THAT
POSSIBLE? YES. BUT HOW MANY MORE
QUESTIONS ARE WE GOING? ME? JUST
A FEW, SIR. OKAY. I'M SORRY. AND
WHICH WAS YOUR. WHO DID YOU WANT
TO ASK? AMELIO HERE. DID HE
LEAVE? I'M SORRY AMELIO HAD TO
LEAVE. EMILIO GREW UP NEXT TO AN
OIL FIELD. YES ACTUALLY. SET,
SET. BRIONES WAS WITH ME. HE
GREW UP NEXT TO THE FIELD THAT
HE CURRENTLY IS THE SUPERVISOR
FOR. HE GREW UP WITHIN 300FT OF
18 WELLS. AND HE'S A HE'S A VERY
HEALTHY YOUNG MAN. HE ACTUALLY
TOOK OVER BEING A SUPERVISOR
FROM HIS DAD, WHO WORKED THAT
FIELD FOR 40 YEARS, WHO'S ALSO A
VERY HEALTHY MAN. THANK YOU SIR.
SO REPRESENTING WHAT WE USED TO
BE, THE STATE'S 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL AND GAS IN KERN
COUNTY, YOU KNOW, 55% PEOPLE OF
COLOR, VETERANS, WOMEN, 43%
SECOND CHANCERS. THEY WOULD COME
FROM LÀ TO GET A JOB BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THEY COULD PROVIDE A
JOB. YOU KNOW, WE GOT GUYS AT
BODY WITH 13 TATTOOS AND
EVERYTHING. AND YOU ASK THEM AND
SAID, HEY, YOU KNOW, HOW LONG
YOU BEEN HERE? AND HE'S LIKE,
YEAH, I'VE BEEN HERE NINE YEARS,
MA'AM. AND, YOU KNOW, MY MOM
USED TO GET TOGETHER. JERRY
FLORES I MEAN, MY MOM USED TO
GET TOGETHER TO FOR BAIL MONEY
FOR ME. AND NOW I BUILT A HOUSE
BEHIND MY HOUSE SO THAT SHE HAS
A PLACE TO LIVE. AND I CAN TAKE
CARE OF HER, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
DESTROYING JOBS, ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT YOU CARE ABOUT, YOU SHOULD
GO MEET SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE REALLY
INCREDIBLE HARD WORKERS AND A
LOT OF THEM DON'T HAVE COLLEGE
EDUCATIONS. YOU STATED THAT,
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DRIVE
THESE PEOPLE OUT OF BUSINESS,
BUT I DON'T. I'M IN BUSINESS AND
I DON'T I MEAN, EVEN THOSE THAT
AREN'T IN BUSINESS, THERE'S NO
WAY WE COULD COME UP WITH A $36
MILLION FINE WHEN YOU'RE ONLY
MAKING $250,000 ON A. WELL,
THERE'S JUST NO WAY THAT PENCIL,
SIR, THE WAY YOU HAVE THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL WRITTEN, I
HAVE ALSO, YOU KNOW HOW MANY
WELLS WILL THIS BILL AFFECT YOUR
LANGUAGE? HOW MANY? IT WILL
AFFECT ALL OF THE WELLS IN THE
SETBACK ZONE THAT PRODUCE LESS
THAN 15 BARRELS A DAY. OKAY, SO
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY ABOUT WHEN
YOU CALCULATE OUT OR GO OUT THE
NUMBER AND I WON'T GO THROUGH
THE MATH I CAN I JUST DID IT'LL
IMPACT 8% OF CALIFORNIA'S OIL
PRODUCTION, WHICH IS 10 MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL. IT'S 10 MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL. WHETHER WE DO
PERCENTAGES OR ANOMALY, WHATEVER
FRAMING WORKS BEST. YOU ARE
WELCOME TO SENATOR, BUT IT'S 10
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL. AND
ACCORDING TO THE GENTLEMAN WHO'S
JUST COMING TO THE MARK THE
FRACK FOUNDER OR FRAC, WHATEVER
IT IS, THE FRACK REPORT, THESE
WELLS MOST WAS 88. YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF MY NUMBER'S WRONG,
SIR. 88. ACCORDING TO YOU, YOUR
SUPPORT WITNESS, 88% OF THESE
WELLS ARE 3.3 BARRELS A DAY. 83%
Þ 83. SORRY. UNDER 15 BARRELS
PER DAY. 80 AVERAGE IN THE STATE
IS 3.3 BARRELS PER DAY. AND THIS
AFFECTS, ABOUT 8% OF PRODUCTION
OF THOSE WELLS. SO THE AVERAGE
FOR THE BARRELS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, ACCORDING TO YOUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES, IS 3.3
BARRELS. THAT INCLUDES ALL OF
THE 200,000 WELLS THAT INCLUDE
SUPPORT WELLS. YES, SO BUT TOTAL
WELLS. YEAH. OKAY. THAT 8%
EQUATES TO ABOUT 10 MILLION
BARRELS WE CONSUME IN
CALIFORNIA, ABOUT 1.4 MILLION
BARRELS EVERY SINGLE DAY. WHERE
ARE WE GOING TO GET THAT
REPLACEMENT AFTER WE DRIVE? MR.
GREGORY OUT OF BUSINESS, MR.
CAHILL, MR. HATHAWAY, MR. HOLMES
, AND WHEN MR. GREGORY'S STORY
IS NOT DIFFERENT, MR. HOLMES
STARTED A FOUNDATION. HE HAS
PAID FOR 439 STUDENTS THAT ARE
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC, DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS TO GO TO THE COLLEGE OF
THEIR CHOICE AND GIVES OUT OVER
$1 MILLION IN SCHOLARSHIPS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. I THINK THAT ON HIS
20 WELLS, AND HE'S GOING TO BE
OUT OF BUSINESS BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL, I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT AT
ALL. THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF DRILLING IN COMMUNITIES IS
THE SAME, WHETHER YOU'RE GETTING
3000 BARRELS OR THREE BARRELS.
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD ALLOW
FOLKS TO CONTINUE TO DRILL FOR
THREE BARRELS A DAY, LESS THAN
15 BARRELS A DAY, STRIPPER WELLS
IS AN INDUSTRY TERM EVEN THEY
HAVE DISAGGREGATED THIS AS ITS
OWN UNIQUE TYPE OF OIL
PRODUCTION, A PRODUCTION THAT IS
BELOW SIGNIFICANTLY FAR BELOW
THE INDUSTRY STANDARD. THE ONLY
REASON FOLKS ARE OPERATING THESE
WELLS IN MANY INSTANCES AND NOT
CONVERTING THAT LAND, WHICH IS
MORE VALUABLE TO OTHER
RESOURCES, IS BECAUSE OF THE
COST OF CLEANING IT UP. THEY
SIMPLY DON'T WANT TO CLEAN IT
UP. THEY STILL OWN THE LAND
RIGHTS YOU CAN CONVERT TO
BATTERY STORAGE, WHICH I KNOW
MR. GREGORY IS ACTUALLY
EXPLORING AND DOING IN HIS. THEY
CAN CONVERT TO REMEDIATE AND
THEN BUILD ON THAT LAND. THERE
ARE MANY, MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO
KEEP BOTH THE BUSINESS ALIVE, TO
KEEP EQUITY IN THE FAMILY AND TO
KEEP PARCELS THAT YOU CAN PASS
DOWN THROUGH GENERATIONS, WHICH
YOU CAN'T DO IS LOWER THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF EVERYBODY AROUND
YOU, INCREASE THE ASTHMA RATES
OF ALL OF THE CHILDREN AROUND
YOU, INCREASE THE CARDIAC
CONDITIONS, THE ADVERSE CARDIAC
CONDITIONS OF EVERYBODY AROUND
YOU FOR A MEASLY PIECE OF OIL
PRODUCTION THAT IS NOT HAVING A
MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON OUR STATE'S
OVERALL OIL SUPPLY OR GAS
PRICES. THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
THAT YOU CAN TRANSITION. IT'S
GOT TO BE JUST IT'S GOT TO BE
FAIR. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING AS
AN OVERALL FRAMEWORK. BUT IN
THIS CONVERSATION, WHEN IT COMES
TO STRIPPER WELLS, IT'S TIME TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT
TRANSITIONING OUT. OKAY. WELL, I
GUESS I'M GOING TO WANT TO SAY
WE AGREE TO DISAGREE. I JUST,
THERE'S NO WAY THAT I GUESS MY
RIGHT WHEN YOU SAID THAT SO BIG
OIL IS YOUR PREFERENCE. YOU WANT
TO KEEP BIG OIL BIG PRODUCTION
AND SMALL BUSINESS LIKE MR.
GREGORY'S NON-EXISTENT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T PRODUCE ENOUGH TO
MEET YOUR STANDARD OF WHAT WOULD
BE ACCEPTABLE IN THIS? NO,
MA'AM. I THINK CALIFORNIA HAS TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
PRODUCTION ALTOGETHER. BUT I
THINK AS WE TAKE THOSE
INCREMENTAL STEPS, RIGHT, WHICH
WE HAVE ALL TALKED ABOUT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES UP NORTH AND
OTHERWISE, WE HAVE TO TAKE
SMART, PRAGMATIC, THOUGHTFUL
APPROACHES. SO THE IDEA THAT WE
WOULD ALLOW FOLKS TO PRODUCE TWO
BARRELS, THREE BARRELS LESS THAN
15 BARRELS A DAY, AS WE'RE
HAVING AN OVERALL ENERGY
TRANSFORMATION THAT WOULD RESULT
IN ELECTRIFICATION, A
TRANSFORMATION IN OUR VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE, A TRANSFORMATION
AND INVESTMENTS IN OUR GRID AND
ALTERNATIVE RENEWABLE ENERGIES.
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHAT CLEAN
HYDROGEN SHOULD BE, IF WE SHOULD
HAVE HYDROGEN AT ALL. ALL OF
THESE IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
ARE HAPPENING SIMULTANEOUSLY. SO
WHAT THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY IS
PRAGMATIC. OKAY, WELL, I
DISAGREE WITH YOU IN THAT
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IS, IS
THAT, IT DOES AFFECT SMALL
PRODUCERS, NOT BIG OIL. YOUR BIG
OIL IS SAFE WITH YOUR BILL, BUT
OUR SMALL PRODUCERS IS NOT SAFE.
I THINK IF BIG OIL PRODUCES
SMALL AMOUNTS, THEN THEY DO. BUT
THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH ABSOLUTELY
DO. NO, THEY I MEAN, BIG OIL
WILL PAY SIGNIFICANT. IF I
MIGHT, SENATOR, I MIGHT JUST SAY
LIKE BIG OIL IF YOU'RE GOING TO
JUST I MEAN I WITH ALL RESPECT,
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE REHASHING THE
SAME ARGUMENT. AND SO I JUST ASK
YOU TO IF YOU HAVE NEW ARGUMENTS
OR NEW POINTS, THAT'S GREAT. BUT
CLEARLY YOU AND THE ASSEMBLYMAN
DISAGREE. OKAY. I JUST SAY THAT
BIG OIL, LET'S JUST TAKE BIG
OIL. THEY COULD LOSE ALL OF
THEIR CHEVRON OPERATION OR
EXCUSE ME, THEIR CALIFORNIA
OPERATIONS, AND THEY'D BE A BLIP
ON THEIR RADAR SCREEN. MR.
GREGORY LOSES HIS CALIFORNIA
OPERATIONS. HIS BUSINESS IS
GONE. HIS EMPLOYEES JOBS ARE
GONE. AND I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE, BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY THAT THAT MAN SITTING HERE
AND COUNTLESS 360 OTHER SIPAH
OPERATORS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO PAY
$10,000 A DAY, WHICH IS $336
MILLION A YEAR WHEN YOU'RE,
WELL, ONLY PRODUCES 219 TO 4,
38,000. AND SO, I JUST, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WOULD, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY NOT HAVE THE
BILL ENFORCED, BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. APPRECIATE IT, SENATOR
LIMÓN, THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. CERTAINLY. YOU
KNOW, MOST CONVERSATIONS THAT
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE, RELATED
TO THIS TOPIC GENERATE A WHOLE
LOT OF EXPERIENCES, YOU KNOW,
LIVED EXPERIENCES FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR STATE. AND, YOU
KNOW, AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
WHAT'S HAPPENED. OVER THE YEARS,
AS WE'VE LOOKED AT OIL
PRODUCTION IN OUR STATE, YOU
KNOW, AND I THINK OF THE FACT
THAT IF FOR DECADES, IF IT
WASN'T, IF IT WASN'T FOR
LEGISLATION, WE WOULDN'T
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO SAY THAT ANY
INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW, IN THIS
SPACE RELATED TO OIL REALLY JUST
KIND OF STEPPED UP ON THEIR OWN.
IT'S TAKEN LEGISLATION, IT'S
TAKEN PUBLIC DISCOURSE, IT'S
TAKEN LEGISLATIVE REVIEW AND
ANALYSIS AND FEEDBACK AND DEBATE
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE LAND, AND
YOU KNOW, ON THIS POINT, I'VE
HEARD A LOT ALSO ABOUT THE
BOTTOM LINE, RIGHT? THE NUMBERS
OF WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE ANY
BUSINESS. AND I HEAR THAT AND I
HEAR A VERY DEEP LIVED
EXPERIENCE FROM COLLEAGUES, THAT
MATTERS AND THAT IT IS ALSO PART
OF AN IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
THAT WE NEED TO DEBATE AND
DELIVER, YOU KNOW, HERE IN OUR
STATE. AND IT'S HARD. AND THEN I
THINK ABOUT WHO'S NOT IN THE
ROOM AND WHO DIDN'T GET TO MAKE
IT TO TALK ABOUT THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND THEIR BOTTOM LINE
BECAUSE OF THE HEALTH IMPACTS
THAT THEY HAVE LIVED, BECAUSE OF
THESE WELLS. AND IT IS REALLY,
REALLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHEN I
SEE AND I WANT TO VALIDATE AND
CALL TO ATTENTION THAT, YES, AS
WE LOOK AT WHAT, YOU KNOW, FOR
EVERYONE WHO HAS A BUSINESS IN
THIS SPACE AND LOOKING AT WHAT
IT WOULD MEAN IN THE FUTURE AND
HOW THIS WOULD IMPACT THEM,
THERE'S REALLY DEEP FEELINGS.
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO
SICK AND NEVER GET TO ACTUALLY
HAVE A BOTTOM LINE, BECAUSE THAT
HEALTH IMPACT CHANGED THEIR
FUTURE, CHANGED THEIR COURSE OF
LIFE, AND IN SOME CASES, THEY'RE
NOT HERE, ON THIS PLANET, TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION,
I THINK OF THE FACT THAT THIS
IS, YOU KNOW, IN PART WHAT WE'RE
DEBATING, WE ARE DEBATING ALSO,
THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAS TO THE
HEALTH OF HUMAN LIVES. AND ALL
OF THOSE FOLKS CAN'T MAKE IT UP
WHEN WE SEE OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WHEN WE TALK TO FOLKS, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU TALK TO KIDS THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE, THE ASTHMA
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAVE, I THINK
OF WHAT THAT BOTTOM LINE LOOKS
LIKE. AND I THINK ABOUT HOW HARD
IT IS TO LEGISLATIVELY TRANSLATE
THAT INTO A NUMBER, TO GIVE YOU
A FORMULA OF HOW MANY WELLS IT
TOOK AND HOW MANY HOURS OF
PUMPING IT TOOK TO GET THAT
INDIVIDUAL, YOU KNOW, SICK. AND
THAT'S A PIECE THAT WE REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH. AND I YOU KNOW, I
MENTIONED THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT IS ANOTHER REALITY.
WHAT HAS BEEN SAID BY ALL
MEMBERS, WHETHER I AGREE WITH IT
OR NOT, IS REAL. IT IS ALL REAL
AND OUR LIVED EXPERIENCES. BUT
THERE IS MORE TO THIS, AND
CERTAINLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT I
THINK UP THAT I THINK OF A LOT.
I THINK OF THE FACT THAT, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T SEE A WHOLE LOT OF
STEPPING UP UNLESS WE LEGISLATE
THE REQUIREMENT TO STEP UP, YOU
KNOW, IN THIS SPACE, I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO USE
THE RESOURCES WE HAVE AT CAL JAM
TO PLUG AND ABANDON WELLS
PROPERLY, AND CERTAINLY KNOW
THAT CAL GÒM UNTIL LEGISLATION
THAT PASSED THROUGH THIS DIDN'T
ACTUALLY TAKE HEALTH
CONSIDERATIONS INTO THEIR
PROCESS UNTIL THAT WAS
LEGISLATED. SO WE REALLY DO NEED
LEGISLATION IN THIS SPACE, AND I
THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO BRING
FORWARD I DO THINK IT'S
DIFFICULT. I ABSOLUTELY THINK
IT'S DIFFICULT. I THINK THAT
THIS IS HARD WORK, AND, YOU
KNOW, DISAPPOINTED THAT WHEN,
YOU KNOW, MY COLLEAGUE, YOU
KNOW, FROM THE ALSO REPRESENTS
VENTURA AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BROUGHT FORWARD THE QUESTION OF
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE, RIGHT, TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE SOME OF THESE,
YOU KNOW, IMPACTS TO OTHERS WHAT
KIND OF AN AGREEMENT COULD WE
COME TO THAT THE ANSWER WAS, YOU
KNOW, NOT MUCH. RIGHT. AND SO I
THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
MORE ON THE TABLE AND IT, IT
MATTERS, YOU KNOW, HOW MUCH WE
WANT TO WORK TOWARDS THIS, BUT I
CERTAINLY FEEL THAT THIS IS A
NEEDED CONVERSATION, BUT REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW REAL IT IS TO ALL
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE
AND THE LIVED EXPERIENCES AND
REGRET THAT SO MANY WHO HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES SIX SICK AND
WITH HIGH MEDICAL DEBT, YOU
KNOW, AS IT RELATES TO THE
IMPACTS THAT THE ENVIRONMENT HAS
HAD ON THEM, ARE NOT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LIMÓN, SEEING
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
I'LL. OH, I'M SORRY, SENATOR
SARATOGA, I APOLOGIZE. WE GOT TO
GET THE FULL COMMITTEE. SORRY
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE AHEAD
OF YOU THAT WAS NOT INTENTIONAL.
GO AHEAD. SORRY NO. YOU KNOW
WHAT A LOT'S BEEN SAID ABOUT THE
BUSINESS END OF THIS. AND THEN A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HEALTH END
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE OF
THIS, THERE'S A FEW FACTORS IN
HERE THAT I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
CONSIDER WHEN THEY'RE GETTING
READY TO SHUT DOWN SOMEBODY'S
BUSINESS, BECAUSE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. AND ONE OF
THOSE IS THAT IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS AREA, YOU KNOW, THOSE
OIL FIELDS WERE THERE A LONG
TIME BEFORE THE HOUSES WENT IN.
AND IN FACT, KENNY HAHN PARK WAS
BUILT AROUND THE OIL FIELD RIGHT
ACROSS FROM THE OIL FIELD. THE
PARK WHERE THEY HAVE THEY THEY
THEY DO POP WARNER FOOTBALL.
THEY DO A LOT OF THEY HAVE A
TRACK THAT GOES AROUND THE
DISTRICT. WELL. SO YEAH, I KNOW
THE DISTRICT WELL, I'VE WATCHED
IT DEVELOP. I KNOW THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY WAS INVOLVED WITH
KENNY HAHN PARK BUILDING IT,
THESE THINGS WERE ALREADY THERE,
THE SOUTH BAY HAS SOME OF THE
CLEANEST AIR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
INVERSION LAYER. IF YOU COME OUT
TO MY DISTRICT, OUR AIR IS MUCH
DIRTIER THAN THE AIR THAT'S OVER
IN SOUTH BAY. AND THAT INCLUDES
INGLEWOOD AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT INGLEWOOD ALWAYS HAS
BEEN KNOWN FOR. AND THOSE FIELDS
AND THAT AREA AROUND INGLEWOOD
IS THAT THEY'VE ALWAYS HAD THE
OCEAN BREEZE, AND THE OCEAN
BREEZE KEEPS THEIR AIR PRETTY
DARN CLEAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH OIL. AS TO
WHY THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE DIABETES.
THEY HAVE HEART PROBLEMS. THEY
HAVE ALL OF THOSE. I USED TO GO
ON THOSE FOLKS ALL THE TIME.
KIDNEY PROBLEMS, THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH OIL OR THESE
OR THE WELLS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE LIVING IN VERY EXPENSIVE
HOUSES. THEY'RE NOT VERY FAR
FROM THEM, DON'T SEEM TO BE
FLEEING THE SCENE BECAUSE THEY
THEY THINK THEY'RE GETTING
POISONED. AND IN FACT, THEY'RE
REALLY NOT, SO, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU'RE, IF YOU'RE HAVING SOME
HEALTH IMPACTS FROM WHERE YOU
LIVE, THEN THERE IS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO, TO, TO GO
AWAY, TO TAKE YOURSELF AWAY FROM
THAT SITUATION. RIGHT. AND WHEN
YOU HAVE PROPERTY THAT'S AS
VALUABLE AS THE PROPERTY AROUND
THOSE AREAS, YOU HAVE THOSE
CHOICES. AND SO, YOU KNOW, RIGHT
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SHUTTING
DOWN SOME BUSINESSES, TAKING
THIS FURTHER THAN WE'VE TAKEN IT
ALREADY. AND NOW CLOSING DOWN
SMALL OPERATORS SO THAT THEY'RE
OUT OF BUSINESS. AND THE PEOPLE
THAT DEPEND ON THEM ARE OUT OF
BUSINESS, I THINK THIS IS THIS
IS GOING TOO FAR. I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR US TO CAP. YOU WANT TO
FOCUS ON ONE AREA FIRST AND GET
THOSE DONE, AND THEN, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT? I HOPE THE GENTLEMAN
THERE, SENDS TO MY OFFICE ALL OF
THOSE REPORTS FROM THAT AREA,
WITH THOSE, WITH THOSE,
STATISTICS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LIVED EXPERIENCES. I'VE
HAD ONE CALL IN AN OIL FIELD IN
THE 35 YEARS IN THE FIRE SERVICE
THAT I WAS ABLE TO SERVE THIS
AREA, AND IT WAS A BRUSH FIRE
FROM A SQUIRREL THAT BIT THROUGH
A LINE AND CAUGHT ON FIRE. IT
LANDED IN THE BRUSH AND THAT WAS
IT. WE HADN'T HAD BIG INCIDENTS
RELATED TO OIL FIELDS, NOT THE
GAS, NOT THE AIR. WE HAD A
COUPLE RELATED TO THE REFINERIES
THAT ARE OUT MORE ON THE COAST.
MY DAUGHTER LIVES A MILE AWAY
FROM THE TORRANCE REFINERY, SO
I, YOU KNOW, I THINK WE'RE USING
THAT A LOT. I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE MORE
SENSITIVE TO THINGS THAN OTHERS,
BUT PEOPLE AREN'T OUT IN MY
AREA. THERE'S NOT A DROP OF OIL
WITHIN 50 MILES OF MY HOUSE,
MAYBE A LITTLE LESS THAN THAT,
BUT BUT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE KIDS
WITH ASTHMA. WE HAVE ALL THOSE
SAME PROBLEMS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUT IN THE
INGLEWOOD AREA. IT'S NOT JUST
IT'S NOT JUST OIL, IT'S OTHER
FACTORS. IT'S HOW THEY LIVE, HOW
THEY EAT ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
SO, YOU KNOW, I WE DON'T NEED TO
VILLAINIZE THESE SMALL
PRODUCERS, AND, AND I THINK IT'S
OUR EFFORTS NEED TO BE ON THE
ORPHAN WELLS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE ENOUGH OF THOSE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON. AND, YOU KNOW,
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
I'M I'M KIND OF TIRED OF
LISTENING TO AREAS THAT I KNOW
EXTREMELY WELL BEING
CHARACTERIZED AS, YOU KNOW, IT'S
LIKE THE OIL FIELDS CAME IN AND
SET UP NEXT TO HOUSES. THEY DID
NOT. IT WAS THE OTHER WAY
AROUND. AND PEOPLE HAD THEY
PEOPLE HAD CHOICES. SO ANYWAY,
WITH THAT, YEAH, I'LL BE, NOT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND,
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO ALL
OF OUR CONCERNS HERE TODAY
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN YOU LIKE A
LONG TIME TO RESPOND TO THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES OR I'LL BE DOING MY
CLOTHES. OKAY, NO, THERE'S, WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
STERN. I'LL JUST CLOSE, A LONG,
LONG TIME AGO, I REMEMBER TAKING
ECONOMICS 101, AND, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE THIS CONCEPT OF WHAT'S
CALLED NEGATIVE EXTERNAL COSTS.
AND I THINK THE CLASSIC EXAMPLE
IS WHEN YOU HAVE A TEXTILE MILL,
I THINK THIS WAS LIKE THE
ORIGINAL, THE OLD SCHOOL ENGLISH
ECONOMIST TALKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'D POLLUTE INTO THE WATER.
IT DIDN'T COST THEM ANYTHING,
BUT OBVIOUSLY IT IT COST THE
PEOPLE DOWNSTREAM. AND THIS IDEA
OF A COST THAT YOU DON'T INCUR
THAT OTHER PEOPLE BEAR BECAUSE
OF YOUR ACTIVITIES IS SOMETHING
THAT, REGULATION IS ONE OF THE
KEY ROLES OF REGULATION IS ONE
OF THE BASES OF HOW WE REGULATE
POLLUTION, POLLUTION, YOU KNOW,
IS NOT NECESSARILY A COST BORNE
BY THE POLLUTER, BUT IT'S A COST
BORNE BY THOSE AROUND THE
POLLUTER, AND WE KNOW AND, YES,
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
ASTHMA. I THINK MY CHILD HAS
ASTHMA. AND MY CHILD, ONE OF MY
CHILDREN HAS, ADHD, BUT WE KNOW
FOR A FACT THAT THERE IS A HIGH
CORRELATION. MANY PEOPLE, MANY
MOST SCIENTISTS, I BELIEVE,
THINK A CAUSATION ESTABLISHED
BETWEEN THE OIL PRODUCTION
ACTIVITIES YOU'RE DESCRIBING AND
INCIDENCE OF CANCER, OF ASTHMA,
OF RESPIRATORY DISEASES, AND
THAT IS ESTIMATED TO HAVE AN
ENORMOUS COST, $77 BILLION EACH
YEAR IN THIS COUNTRY DUE TO OIL
PRODUCTION ACTIVITIES. SO THAT'S
AN ENORMOUS COST WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT IS NOT BORNE RIGHT
NOW BY THE PEOPLE WHO CREATE
THAT POLLUTION THAT GENERATE
THAT ACTIVITY, WE ALSO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH ORPHAN WELLS IN
THIS STATE, WHERE WE HAVE
INCREASINGLY SEEN SMALL
PRODUCERS IN PARTICULAR,
SOMETIMES LARGE, BUT A LOT OF
SMALL PRODUCERS ABANDON THEIR
FIELDS, WALK AWAY, AND THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT BE JUDGMENT PROOF,
MAY OR MAY NOT BE PEOPLE WE CAN
GO AFTER. THAT'S ANOTHER FORM OF
NEGATIVE EXTERNAL COSTS THAT WE
ARE NOT CAPTURING AT THE SOURCE.
SO IN MY VIEW, YOUR BILL TAKES A
SENSIBLE APPROACH TO TRYING. WE
CAN'T QUANTIFY EXACTLY HOW MUCH
IT COSTS WHEN WE HAVE THIS
PRODUCTION, BUT WE KNOW IT'S A
LOT. AND WHEN YOU POINT OUT THAT
IT'S JUST AS HARMFUL TO THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORS, THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN AN AREA TO
HAVE THE OIL GENERATING
ACTIVITIES OF A SMALL
PRODUCTION, LOW PRODUCTION
FACILITY VERSUS A HIGH
PRODUCTION. AND I SAY THIS TO
MR. GREGORY, I'M NOT I FEEL FOR
YOU. BUT, YOU KNOW, I WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO GO TO BUSINESS,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE NEED TO
START CAPTURING THOSE COSTS, THE
COSTS OF CAPPING OUR WELLS WHEN
THEY GO FULLY DRY, THE COSTS
THAT ARE BORNE BY SURROUNDING
PEOPLE AS FAR AS THEIR AILMENTS
AND DISEASES. AND I THINK THIS
IS A REASONABLE EFFORT TO TRY TO
CAPTURE THOSE COSTS AND SO I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
FOR THOSE REASONS. I THINK THIS
HAS BEEN A ROBUST DEBATE, AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE VARIETY
OF VIEWPOINTS. AND I THINK THE
STORIES ARE IMPORTANT AS WELL.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, LIKE
I GUESS I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR
AND THIS MAY BE A PHILOSOPHICAL
OR SCIENTIFIC DIFFERENCE. WE
HAVE WITH SOME MEMBERS, BUT THAT
THAT OIL PRODUCING ACTIVITIES DO
RESULT IN HARMS. AND WE CAN
POINT TO ONE OFF EXAMPLES OF
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
SICK BECAUSE THEY LIVE NEAR OIL
FIELD, BUT WE KNOW THAT IT'S
HIGHLY CORRELATED WITH THERE'S
MUCH HIGHER PROBABILITY OF BEING
SICK IF YOU'RE AROUND AN OIL
GENERATING FIELD. SO THAT'S WHY
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL, I
THINK IT'S SENSIBLE AND I, AS
YOU POINT OUT, WILL NOT
MEANINGFULLY IMPACT OIL
PRODUCTION. I THINK THIS IS A
CLOSE. UNFORTUNATELY SENATOR, I
WAS ASKING BEFORE IF YOU HAD ANY
QUESTIONS. I DIDN'T TELL YOU.
YOU JUST SAID WHAT YOU SAID. BUT
I THINK AS THE CHAIR IS MY
PREROGATIVE TO HAVE THE LAST
WORD. SO WITH THAT, I'LL ALLOW
THE SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU, COLLEAGUES AND
INCREDIBLY ROBUST DISCUSSION.
LOTS OF LOTS OF THOUGHTS. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MARIETTA, NOT
EVERYBODY DID HAVE A CHOICE. YOU
WERE REDLINED IN A CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AND TOLD EXACTLY
WHERE YOU COULD AND COULDN'T
LIVE. AND, YOU KNOW THE AREA
WELL. AND SO YOU KNOW THAT IT
WAS A REDLINED COMMUNITY. IT WAS
A RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANT.
AT ONE POINT THAT THEN
EXPERIENCED WHITE FLIGHT AND
BECAME A BLACK MECCA AS THE ONLY
PLACE YOU COULD LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AS IT BECAME TO GROW AND
DEVELOP. AND SO YOU COULDN'T
JUST LEAVE BECAUSE THE OIL
FIELDS WERE THERE. PEOPLE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THESE NEGATIVE
HEALTH HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
DECADES, AND THEY ARE NOT WITH
HERE WITH US. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA MENTIONED, WE
COULD PACK THIS ROOM IN MANY,
MANY, MANY OTHERS WITH THOSE WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED DIRECT, HIGHLY
CORRELATED CAUSAL RELATIONSHIPS
TO THEIR HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
THAT PARTICULAR OIL FIELD, OTHER
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE NEGATIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. A CHILD WITH
ASTHMA IN TEMECULA DOES NOT
DISPROVE THE IMPACT HEALTH
IMPACT OF OIL WELLS AND
COMMUNITIES, ANY MORE THAN
CARRYING A SNOWBALL INTO
CONGRESS DISPROVES GLOBAL
WARMING. THERE'S GOOD DATA
BEHIND THIS. THERE'S BEEN
RESEARCH AND LIVED EXPERIENCE
BUILT BEHIND THIS. WE HAVE TAKEN
THE INCREMENTAL STEPS FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO
START TO TRANSITION TO A CLEAN,
SUSTAINABLE, THRIVING AND
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. AND PART OF
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO DO
THAT IS MOVING AWAY FROM
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE CAUSED
HARM. AND I'VE THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT THE WORKERS. I THINK OFTEN
ABOUT THE WORKERS, ESPECIALLY
THE DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK AND
BROWN WORKERS. I'M ALWAYS
FRUSTRATED BY THE FACT THAT
BLACK AND BROWN WORKERS SEEM TO
ONLY FIND THRIVING OCCUPATIONS
THAT HAVE NEGATIVE HEALTH
EXTERNALITIES, OR THAT HAVE A
CAUSAL IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE AROUND THEM. THOSE ARE
THE ONLY JOBS AND THE ONLY
BUSINESSES BLACK AND BROWN FOLKS
CAN GET. AND SO WE NEED TO
INVEST IN ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL. WE NEED TO INVEST IN AN
EDUCATION PIPELINE THAT ALLOWS
FOR EVERYONE TO REACH THEIR FULL
EDUCATION POTENTIAL. I AM GLAD
THAT WE ALL CARE SO STRONGLY
ABOUT THOSE BLACK WORKERS,
BECAUSE THERE'S A THOUGHTFUL
REPARATIONS PACKAGE THAT TAKES
US A STEP FURTHER THAN THAT,
THAT WILL BE ON THE SENATE FLOOR
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY THOUGHT
PROVOKING CONVERSATION. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR IT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR STERN. THE MOTION IS DUE
. PASS, TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. MIN MIN. AYE. SATO.
CIARDO NO. ALLEN. DALLY. NO.
DALLY NO. EGGMAN. GROVE NO.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO HURTADO. NO.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN
AYE. PADILLA STERN. STERN AYE.
OKAY FOUR FOR ITS. FOUR FOR THE
VOTE IS FOUR. FOUR OR LEAVE IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WE WILL NOW,
REOPEN THE. WE'LL LIFT THE CALL
ON A NUMBER OF BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. BEFORE WE DO
THAT IS WHO IS MISSING ALLEN AND
PADILLA, RIGHT. CAN WE PLEASE
CALL FOR ALLEN AND PADILLA TO
TRY TO COME BACK? YEAH OKAY.
OKAY, SO WE'LL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HERE. JUST AS A
REMINDER, THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
IT CONSISTS OF FIVE ITEMS.
NUMBER TWO, AB 2960 68, FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 1828, FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 1987 FILE.
ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 2538 FILE.
ITEM NUMBER 13 AB 2469 FILE ITEM
NUMBER 19, AB 2939, AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER 20, AB 2983.
ASSISTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR ALLEN.
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. PADILLA.
ALL RIGHT. WE JUST HAVE 990.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 828
BY ASSEMBLYMAN CONNELLY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR THREE. SENATOR
ALLEN HURTADO NØ HURTADO NØ
PADILLA. FOUR FOUR. THAT VOTE IS
FOUR FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL, WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 1581, THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. SENATOR ALLEN
HURTADO HURTADO AYE. PADILLA ON
THAT VOTE COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL, WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR,
AB 2509. ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO. SENATOR ALLEN HURTADO.
OKAY. PADILLA EIGHT ZERO, THAT
VOTE COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 1889 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO. SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. PADILLA.
OKAY SIX TWO. THAT VOTE COUNTS
SIX TWO WILL EVEN ON CALL. WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB 2552. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
IS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS,
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ONE.
SENATOR HUR. SENATOR ALLEN
HURTADO HURTADO NØ PADILLA. OKAY
SEVEN TWO. THAT VOTE COUNT IS
SEVEN TWO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL, WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 2060. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR ALLEN
HURTADO HURTADO AYE. PADILLA
OKAY, NINE ZERO. THAT VOTE COUNT
IS NINE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT TO,
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2091.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
SENATOR ALLEN HURTADO HURTADO.
AYE. LIMÓN. AB 2091 BY SENATOR
GRAYSON. I'M ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON
, OKAY, OKAY. PADILLA ALL RIGHT.
SO SEVEN ZERO. THE VOTE COUNT IS
SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL, JUST A MOMENT. WE. DO YOU
WANT TO JUST CHECK THE ONES
EGGMAN'S MISSING? SINCE SHE'S
BEEN.
SO I'M JUST MISSING THE
ALPHABETICAL. SO WE JUST KEEP
GOING IN ORDER. I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT. OKAY, WE'LL GO TO NEXT TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 12, AB 2330.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO.
SENATOR ALLEN HURTADO HURTADO
AYE. PADILLA NINE ZERO. THAT
VOTE COUNTS NINE ZERO. OKAY.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 14 AB 2537.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO.
SENATOR ALLEN HURTADO HURTADO.
AYE PADILLA OKAY. SIX TWO. THE
VOTE COUNT IS SIX TWO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 15 AB 28 2560, THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO. SENATOR
ALLEN HURTADO HURTADO. AYE
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE. STERN A STERN
AYE TEN ZERO. THAT VOTE IS TEN
ZERO, WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL,
WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT TO, FILE ITEM
16 AB 3227. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. SENATOR. MIN A
MIN. AYE. ALLEN HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN NOT VOTING.
SHE SAID STERN A STERN AYE.
NINE. THAT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. NEXT
BILL, WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
17, AB SEVEN 2716. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR SENATOR
ALLEN BERGMAN. OKAY. PADILLA. I
SUPPOSE THE SAME, VOTE COUNT IS
FOR FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL, NEXT BILL IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 18, AB 2827 BY REYES. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE
COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR
ALLEN HURTADO. LAYING OFF.
REYES. REYES. INVASIVE SPECIES
PROTECTION, 2820. SHE SAID, I, I
HURTADO I PADILLA OKAY. NINE
ZERO THAT VOTE COUNT IS NINE
ZERO. OKAY WE'LL OPEN UP THE
CALL ON A COUPLE ON EGGMAN.
EGGMAN, WHAT DID YOU MISS AGAIN.
AND YOU GOT YOU GOT THE CALL.
DID YOU WANT TO VOTE ON THE BILL
YOU LAID OFF? SO AB 828, WE'LL
GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
828, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR FOUR.
SENATOR EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
OKAY, OKAY. THAT VOTE COUNTS
FIVE FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL AND WE'LL TAKE A SHORT
RECESS WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
REMAINING AUTHORS.
YES. I WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY. YEAH, LET'S. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL REOPEN THE ROLL
FOR SENATOR ALLEN, STARTING
WITH, THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MAYBE YOU JUST TELL ME WHICH
BILLS TO DO. YEP. OKAY WE'LL
REOPEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR ALLEN
Ã ALLEN. AYE. OKAY TEN ZERO.
OKAY. THAT VOTE IS TEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL, OKAY.
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE AB
828, MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL RIGHT. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
FOR SENATOR ALLEN. ALLEN AYE.
SIX FOR THE VOTE IS SIX FOR.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 1581.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROACH ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR
ALLEN Ã ALLEN. AYE NINE ZERO.
THAT VOTE IS NINE ZERO. WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2509 BY KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN.
AYE NINE ZERO. VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL,
MOVE TO FILE ITEM SIX, AB 1889.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. VOTE IS SIX
TWO. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN. AYE.
SEVEN TWO. THE VOTE COUNT IS
SEVEN TWO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 2005 52. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS IS AMENDED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL, SENATOR. CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN TWO. SENATOR ALAN
ALLEN. AYE. OKAY THAT VOTE IS
EIGHT TWO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. WE'LL MOVE TO A FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE, AB 2060. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN.
AYE, TEN. THAT VOTE COUNT IS TEN
ZERO, WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
MUST HAVE VOTED FOR SOME OF
THESE. SO SOME OF THESE SHOULD
BE GETTING OUT. CAN YOU LET ME
KNOW NEXT TIME K¾T IS VOTED YES,
THEN THE BILL SHOULD BE OUT.
IT'S JUST, ON 15 AND 15. YEAH.
DON'T NEED IT. OKAY. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB
2091, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
SENATOR ALAN ALLEN. AYE. EIGHT
ZERO. THAT VOTE COUNTS EIGHT
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM 1212 AB
2330. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED. THE APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
SENATOR ALAN ALLEN, AYE, TEN
ZERO. VOTE COUNTS TEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 14. AB
2537. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO. SENATOR
ALAN ALLEN. AYE 772. VOTE COUNTS
SEVEN TWO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM 15
AB 2560. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE ON THIS ONE IS
CURRENT. VOTE ON THIS ONE IS TEN
ZERO. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN. AYE.
OUT, THE VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. THAT'S IRONIC. THE
FIRST BILL ON THAT ONE. I'M
SORRY. I HAVE 11 ZERO. SO, YES,
WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM 16 AB
3227. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR ALLEN. ALAN.
AYE. THAT VOTE COUNTS TEN ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT, WE'LL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 17, ACTUALLY, DID
ALLEN ALREADY VOTE ON THAT?
OKAY. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
APPROPRIATIONS AB 2716
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR FOUR.
SENATOR ALLEN Ã ALLEN. AYE
OKAY. FIVE FOUR. THE THAT, VOTE
IS FIVE FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. FINALLY, FOR SENATOR ALLEN
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM 18 AB
2827. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR ALAN ALLEN.
AYE, TEN ZERO ONE. THE VOTE
COUNT IS TEN ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. WE'LL TAKE ANOTHER
SHORT RECESS UNTIL SENATOR
PADILLA REJOINS.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE NOW RESUMED,
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE IS BACK, AND
WE'LL OPEN THE FILE HERE,
STARTING WITH CONSENT. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE 11
ZERO. THE VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. THE BILLS ARE OUT.
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE, AB 828.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX FOUR.
SENATOR PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
THAT VOTE COUNT IS SEVEN FOUR.
THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THREE AB 1581. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR PADILLA Ã
PADILLA. AYE. THAT VOTE COUNT IS
TEN ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2509.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR PADILLA
PADILLA. AYE. THE VOTE COUNT IS
TEN ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB
1889. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN TWO. SENATOR PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. OKAY. THE VOTE
COUNT IS EIGHT TWO. THE BILL IS
OUT. WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. AB 2552. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR PADILLA
OF CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT TWO.
SENATOR PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
THAT VOTE COUNT IS NINE TWO. THE
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 2060. BUT
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN ZERO.
SENATOR PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
THE VOTE COUNT IS 11 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM TEN AB 2093. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO. SENATOR PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. THAT VOTE COUNTS
NINE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM 12 AB
2330. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND VOTE IS TEN ZERO. SENATOR
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. OKAY. THE
VOTE COUNT IS 11 ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT, WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
14 AB 2537. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN TWO.
SENATOR PADILLA. PADILLA AYE.
THE VOTE IS EIGHT TWO. THE BILL
IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 17, AB 2716. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE FOUR.
SENATOR PADILLA Ã PADILLA. AYE.
OKAY. THAT VOTE IS SIX FOR THE
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM 18 AB 20 2827. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED. APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN ZERO.
SENATOR PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
THE VOTE IS 1011 ZERO. THE VOTE
IS OUT. THE BILL IS OUT, THANK
YOU, EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION. WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED AT 1615 AND 16 SEVEN.
YOU HAVE MY VOTE.